THAT SUBCOMMITTEE ON LOW SPEED
RAIL CORRIDOR RESILIENCY WILL
NOW COME TO ORDER. GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYBODY. WE'RE HAPPY
TO SEE YOU THERE. THANK YOU FOR
COMING IN THE AUDIENCE AND
WATCHING ON TELEVISION. THE
SENATE CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE
PUBLIC AND HAS PROVIDED ACCESS
TO IN-PERSON PARTICIPATION FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. FOR TODAY'S
HEARING, WE WILL BE HEARING ALL
OF THE PANELS OF WITNESSES ON
THE AGENDA PRIOR TO TAKING ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT. ONCE WE HAVE
HEARD ALL THE WITNESSES, WE WILL
HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD.
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO COMMENT ON
THE TOPICS ON TODAY'S AGENDA. SO
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING IS OUR
FIFTH HEARING OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ON LOW SPEED RAIL
CORRIDOR RESILIENCY. AND IT'S
OUR FIRST OVERSIGHT HEARING. THE
PREVIOUS HEARINGS HAVE BEEN
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS. I'D
FIRST LIKE TO THANK THE
PANELISTS FOR COMING UP HERE TO
SACRAMENTO. AND ALSO THE STATE
AGENCIES WHO ARE JOINING US THIS
AFTERNOON AS WE CONTINUE MAKING
PROGRESS TOWARD A RESILIENT AND
HIGH PERFORMING RAIL CORRIDOR,
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE WORK
COLLABORATIVELY AND SPEAK
HONESTLY ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITIES
AND CHALLENGES BEFORE US. OVER
THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF, THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE HAS DISCUSSED THE
URGENT AND EMERGENCY CONDITIONS
ALONG THE 351 MILE COASTAL RAIL
CORRIDOR THAT RUNS BETWEEN SAN
LUIS OBISPO AND SAN DIEGO.
TODAY, OUR FOCUS WILL BE ON THE
PASSENGER SERVICES, AND WE'LL
HEAR FROM THE STATE AGENCIES
RESPONSIBLE FOR RAIL SAFETY
PLANNING AND PERMITTING. BEFORE
WE BEGIN, IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT THE BEST TIME IS
NOW FOR STRATEGIC, COORDINATED
AND BOLD ACTION. WE'VE ALREADY
SEEN FIVE TRACK CLOSURES OVER
THREE YEARS, LASTING MANY MONTHS
AT A TIME, AND TOTALING MORE
THAN A YEAR OF CLOSURES THAT
THIS HAS IMPACTED SERVICE
RELIABILITY FOR DAILY PASSENGERS.
I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
THE OPERATING AGENCIES. I'D LIKE
TO RECOGNIZE AND THANK THE
AGENCIES AND THE EXECUTIVES THAT
ARE WITH US TODAY FOR THE
PROGRESS THAT WE'VE MADE. SO
FAR. WHILE WE ACKNOWLEDGE THIS
VERY IMPORTANT PROGRESS, THE
REALITY IS THAT THESE IMPORTANT
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION SERVICES
COULD BE AND SHOULD BE MOVING
FAR MORE PASSENGERS. IF WE'RE
SERIOUS ABOUT MEETING OUR
REGION'S CONGESTION, AIR QUALITY
AND EQUITY GOALS, WE MUST
SIGNIFICANTLY AND DRAMATICALLY
INCREASE OUR RIDERSHIP ALONG
THIS CORRIDOR. WE'LL ALSO HEAR
FROM OUR STATE AGENCY PARTNERS
WITH THE IMPORTANT
RESPONSIBILITY FOR RAIL SAFETY,
PLANNING AND PERMITTING. I'D
LIKE TO THANK TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY SECRETARY OMISAKIN,
NATURAL RESOURCES SECRETARY
CROWFOOT, AND PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
PETERSON FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO RECOGNIZE THE
AGENCY STAFF THAT WE HAVE HERE
TODAY AND THANK THEM FOR THEIR
PUBLIC SERVICE THROUGH THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. WE'RE FOCUSING THE
STATE RESPONSE ON COLLABORATIVE
ACTION. WE'LL NEED A BOLD AND
STRATEGIC RESPONSE TO ENSURE OUR
NATURAL RESOURCES ARE PROTECTED
AND OUR TRANSPORTATION CORRIDOR
IS HIGH PERFORMING. WE KNOW THIS
IS COMPLICATED AND CHALLENGING,
AND I DON'T MEAN TO DIMINISH
THAT IN ANY WAY. HOWEVER, THE
TRUTH IS, WE MUST DO BETTER. I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES AND
SENATORS FOR BEING HERE TODAY,
AND ALSO THANK YOU TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO HAVE
TAKEN THE TIME TO COME TODAY AND
WHO ARE WATCHING ONLINE. I WOULD
LIKE TO ASK MY SUBCOMMITTEE
MEMBERS IF ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE ANY COMMENTS BEFORE WE
BEGIN. YES, I JUST. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND ALL
OF THE PARTICIPANTS TODAY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR CONTINUING
THIS CONVERSATION AS WE SPEAK. I
THINK YOU KNOW A PLAN AND
RESOURCES FOR SHORING UP THE
LOSSAN CORRIDOR OVER THE YEARS
TO COME. SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SO OUR FIRST PANEL IS HERE
AT THE TABLE. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US. THEY'RE ALREADY AND
I'M JUST GOING TO INTRODUCE
THEM. SO WE ALL KNOW WHO'S
SITTING WITH US. FIRST. WE HAVE
JASON JEWELL LAUSANNE RAIL
CORRIDOR AGENCY MANAGING
DIRECTOR. THEN DARREN KETTLE
METROLINX CEO AND SHAUN DONAGHY,
NTDS CEO. NORTH COUNTY TRANSIT
DISTRICT IS WHAT NCTD STANDS
FOR. I WANT TO THANK YOU IN
ADVANCE FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND
FOR JOINING US TODAY, AND WE
WILL START WITH JASON JEWELL.
OKAY. LET ME GET THESE SLIDES
GOING. CAN YOU SEE THAT THERE?
WE CAN WE CAN SEE IT UP HERE.
THERE WE GO. PERFECT OKAY. THANK
YOU. CHAIR BLAKE SPEER AND
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE FOR
INVITING ME TO SPEAK IN FRONT OF
YOU TODAY, ALONGSIDE MY
COLLEAGUES, DARREN KETTLE AND
SHAUN DONAGHY. AGAIN, MY NAME IS
JASON JEWELL, MANAGING DIRECTOR
OF THE RAIL CORRIDOR AGENCY. AND
AS YOU KNOW, WE ARE A JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY WHICH MANAGES
AND OVERSEES THE AMTRAK PACIFIC
SURFLINER SERVICE ALONG THE 350
MILE LONG LOSSAN CORRIDOR. SO
MOVING ON TO THE SECOND SLIDE.
THIS SLIDE HIGHLIGHTS THE
UNIQUENESS AND COMPLEXITY OF THE
RAIL CORRIDOR, WHICH IS
COMPRISED OF SEVEN RIGHT OF WAY
OWNERS, BOTH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE.
ROUGHLY 55% OF THE CORRIDOR IS
OWNED, MAINTAINED AND OPERATED
BY PRIVATE FREIGHT RAILROADS OF
UNION PACIFIC AND BNSF. THIS MAP
ALSO SHOWS THE 29 STATIONS
SERVED BY THE AMTRAK PACIFIC
SURFLINER SERVICE. THE AMTRAK
PACIFIC SURFLINER SERVICE AS YOU
WELL MAY KNOW, IS HISTORICALLY
BEEN THE BUSIEST STATE SUPPORTED
SERVICE. AMTRAK ROUTE IN THE
NATION IN TERMS OF RIDERSHIP,
AND THE SECOND BUSIEST INTERCITY
RAIL CORRIDOR BEHIND THE
NORTHEAST CORRIDOR. MOVING ON TO
THIS SLIDE, THIS REALLY PRESENTS
ALL OF THE SERVICES BEING
PROVIDED ALONG THE CORRIDOR
THROUGH THE SURFLINER STOPS.
OBVIOUSLY, I JUST MENTIONED
THERE'S 29 OF THOSE, BUT THERE
ARE ACTUALLY 41 STATIONS ALONG
THE CORRIDOR WITH THOSE
ADDITIONAL 12 BEING SERVED ONLY
BY COMMUTER RAIL SERVICE. THERE
ARE ALSO AMTRAK LONG DISTANCE
SERVICE ROUTES THAT UTILIZE THE
CORRIDOR. IN TOTAL, THERE ARE
CURRENTLY 145 INTERCITY OR
COMMUTER TRAINS OPERATING ALONG
THE LOW SPEED RAIL CORRIDOR, AND
AS YOU ARE ALL FAMILIAR WITH THE
NATIONAL IMPORTANCE OF THE LOW
SÐNG CORRIDOR, THE US DEPARTMENT
OF DEFENSE HAS IDENTIFIED A
LARGE PORTION OF THE CORRIDOR AS
PART OF THE STRATEGIC RAIL
CORRIDOR NETWORK, OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS STRATEGIC, FOR ITS KEY
ROLE IN PROVIDING ACCESS TO NOT
ONLY THE PORT OF SAN DIEGO, BUT
THE MARINE CORPS BASE CAMP
PENDLETON AND MIRAMAR. AS WELL
AS THE NORTH ISLAND NAVAL AIR
STATION, NAVAL AIR STATION,
WHICH IS A MAJOR PORT FOR THE
UNITED STATES NAVY FLEET. THE
NORTHERN END OF THE CORRIDOR IS
ALSO CONSIDERED A CONNECTOR LINE
UNDER STRETCH NECK FOR ITS
ABILITY TO CONNECT NORTHERN AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA, AND ITS
ACCESS TO VANDENBERG SPACE FORCE
BASE. SO DIVING IN TO SOME OF
OUR OPERATIONAL INFORMATION, I
WANTED TO SHARE SOME SPECIFIC
INFORMATION ABOUT PACIFIC
SURFLINER RIDERSHIP AND
SPECIFICALLY RIDERSHIP RECOVERY.
WE ARE CURRENTLY OPERATING ABOUT
84% OF PRE-COVID SERVICE LEVELS,
AND ARE AVERAGING ABOUT 75% OF
PRE-COVID RIDERSHIP. HOWEVER
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE RIDERSHIP
PER TRAIN MILE, WHICH IS THE
YELLOW LINE SHOWN ON THIS CHART,
WE ARE RUNNING ABOUT 98% OF
PRE-COVID RIDERSHIP, SO WE'RE
RUNNING LESS MILES. HOWEVER, THE
NUMBER OF PASSENGERS PER MILE IS
JUST ABOUT THE SAME OF WHAT IT
WAS PRE-COVID, WHICH IS A GOOD
INDICATION THAT THE DEMAND IS
THERE. JULY PRELIMINARY NUMBERS
ARE SHOWING JUST ABOVE 200,000
RIDERS, WHICH IS THE HIGHEST
RIDERSHIP WE'VE SEEN SINCE
FEBRUARY OF 2020. OUR FAREBOX
RECOVERY IS AT ABOUT 62%. WE
HAVE A MANDATED 55% RECOVERY
RATIO AND THIS IS EXPECTED TO
INCREASE THROUGH JULY. THIS NEXT
SLIDE SHOWS THE BOARDINGS AND
ALIGHTINGS FOR FEDERAL FISCAL
YEAR 24. SO FAR, THE STATIONS AT
THE TOP OF THE GRAPH REFLECT THE
MOST POPULAR STATIONS ALONG THE
LINE, BASED ON BOARDINGS AND
ALIGHTINGS. THESE INCLUDE LA
UNION STATION, OF COURSE, SAN
DIEGO, WHICH IS ACTUALLY THE
SANTA FE DEPOT STATION. SANTA
BARBARA, OLD TOWN, SAN DIEGO AND
IRVINE. SO THIS CHART REALLY
GIVES AN INDICATION ON THE
CUSTOMER USAGE AND REALLY THE
POPULARITY OF THESE PARTICULAR
STATIONS. SO NEXT, I WANTED TO
DIVE A LITTLE DEEPER INTO SOME
ON TIME PERFORMANCE INFORMATION.
OUR ON TIME PERFORMANCE GOAL OF
90% IN TIME ON TIME PERFORMANCE,
I'LL REFER TO IT AS OTP IS SET
THROUGH AN INTERAGENCY TRANSFER
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE AGENCY AND
THE STATE AND ENDPOINT. OTP
REPRESENTS THE PERCENTAGE OF
TRAINS ARRIVING TO THEIR FINAL
STATION WITHIN 15 MINUTES OF
THEIR SCHEDULED ARRIVAL TIME. SO
SINCE THE REOPENING OF THE
TRACKS AT MARIPOSA POINT IN SAN
CLEMENTE BACK ON MARCH 25TH, WE
HAVE BEEN AVERAGING ABOUT 83% ON
TIME PERFORMANCE. WE DO PROVIDE
A QUARTERLY REPORT TO OUR BOARD
OF DIRECTORS ON ON TIME
PERFORMANCE AND QUARTER TRENDS,
WHICH ARE IN OUR BOARD AGENDAS
ONLINE. HOWEVER, WE'RE WORKING
TO SYNTHESIZE THIS INFORMATION
AND PUT IT UP ON OUR WEBSITE TO
BE MORE READILY AVAILABLE AND
ACCESSIBLE TO THE PUBLIC. MOVING
ON TO THE NEXT SLIDE, I WANTED
TO GET INTO SOME OF THE DATA
AROUND ACHIEVING OUR ON TIME
PERFORMANCE GOALS. THIS CHART
SHOWS DELAYS BY RESPONSIBLE
PARTY PER 10,000 TRAIN MILES,
BUT I REALLY WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT
REALLY THE TOP FIVE DELAY TYPES
THAT WE SEE FOR PACIFIC
SURFLINER. AND THOSE DELAY TYPES
INCLUDE PASSENGER TRAIN
INTERFERENCE, SIGNAL DELAYS,
COMMUTER TRAIN INTERFERENCE,
PASSENGER RELATED DELAYS, AND
SLOW ORDERS. I WANTED TO TOUCH
UPON A COUPLE OF THESE AREAS
BRIEFLY. I WANTED TO TOUCH UPON
PASSENGER TRAIN INTERFERENCE.
THIS IS REALLY WHEN ANOTHER
AMTRAK TRAIN IS OUT OF ITS
SCHEDULED SLOT, AND CREATES A
DELAY TO ANOTHER PACIFIC
SURFLINER TRAIN. THIS COULD BE
CAUSED BY A SERIES OF DIFFERENT
ISSUES RELATED TO MECHANICAL
DELAYS, EVEN PASSENGER RELATED
DELAYS, OR ANYTHING ELSE THAT
COULD INITIALLY DELAY A
SURFLINER TRAIN IN ROUTE. THIS
IS TYPICALLY ASSOCIATED WITH
CASCADING DELAYS FROM ANOTHER
SOURCE, AND GIVEN THE WIDE, WIDE
RANGE OF ROOT CAUSES FOR THIS
TYPE OF DELAY, THERE ISN'T A
SINGLE APPROACH REALLY TO
ADDRESSING IT. STAFF CONTINUES
TO WORK WITH OUR HOST RAILROADS
ON DISPATCHING PRIORITIES TO
MINIMIZE THESE TYPES OF DELAYS, WE ALSO WORK WITH OUR AMTRAK
MECHANICAL TEAM TO IDENTIFY
ROUTE MECHANICAL ISSUES, TO
REALLY TRY TO LIMIT ISSUES THAT
COULD CREATE AN INITIAL DELAY.
SOME OF THE OTHER DELAYS THAT I
WANTED TO QUICKLY MENTION ARE
SIGNAL DELAYS. NOW, THESE ARE
OFTEN CAUSED BY SIGNAL
MALFUNCTIONS, WHICH SOMETIMES
COULD BE A SIMPLE FAILURE OF A
PART. BUT MOST RECENTLY, WHICH I
THINK DARREN MAY GET INTO AS
PART OF HIS DISCUSSION, IS
VANDALISM, WHERE THERE'S
ACTUALLY THIEVES TAKING THE
COPPER COMMUNICATION WIRING FROM
THE CONTROL BOXES, WHICH
OBVIOUSLY CAUSES SIGNIFICANT
DISRUPTIONS. ALSO, A LOT OF OUR
SIGNAL DELAYS HAVE BEEN TIED TO
CHALLENGES BEING FACED ON THE
NORTHERN END OF OUR CORRIDOR
RELATED TO GRADE CROSSINGS. NOW,
THIS ISSUE IS WHERE THE TRAINS
ARE NOT CONSISTENTLY ACTIVATING
CROSSINGS WITH THE APPROPRIATE
AMOUNT OF LEAD TIME. THIS IS
KNOWN AS A SHUNTING ISSUE, AND
TO MAINTAIN SAFETY WHILE
OPERATING, THE RAILROADS HAVE
IMPLEMENTED SLOW ORDERS AT THESE
CROSSINGS TO AVOID THE POTENTIAL
OF A STRIKE. A LONG TERM
SOLUTION HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED TO
INSTALL AN ANTENNA ON THE TRUCKS
OF BOTH THE LOCOMOTIVE AND THE
CAB CONTROL CARS, WHICH
BASICALLY ENHANCES THE
ELECTRICAL SIGNAL BETWEEN THE
RAILS THAT ALLOW THE CIRCUIT
CONTROLLING THE CROSSING TO
SHUNT MORE RELIABLY. SO WE ARE
EXCITED ABOUT A TEST OF THIS
PROTOTYPE ANTENNA IS SCHEDULED
WITH UNION PACIFIC ON THE LOW
SAN CORRIDOR FOR SEPTEMBER, BUT
UNTIL THAT POSSIBLE FIX IS
IMPLEMENTED, WE WILL CONTINUE TO
SEE THESE THESE TYPES OF DELAYS
UP IN THE NORTHERN END OF OUR
CORRIDOR. MOVING ON TO SLIDE
EIGHT. NOW, I WANTED TO TALK
ABOUT ANOTHER TOPIC THAT CAUSES
DELAYS AND THAT IS THE
UNFORTUNATE INCIDENT OF
TRESPASSER STRIKES. THIS SLIDE
SHOWS THE TRENDS AROUND
TRESPASSER STRIKES AND VEHICLE
STRIKES FOR PACIFIC SURFLINER.
SINCE FEDERAL FISCAL YEAR 20
1819, A FEW KEY PIECES OF
INFORMATION I WANTED TO POINT
OUT IS THAT IN FEDERAL FISCAL
YEAR 24, 68% OF STRIKES HAVE
BEEN TRESPASSERS, WHILE 32% ARE
VEHICLES, 95% OF FATAL STRIKES
HAVE BEEN TRESPASSERS, AND 86%
OF TRESPASSER STRIKES HAVE NOT
BEEN AT A CROSSING. SO 95% OF
TRESPASSER STRIKES HAVE BEEN
FATAL, AND OR EXCUSE ME, 95% OF
THE FATAL STRIKES HAVE BEEN
TRESPASSERS, STRIKES ARE
TYPICALLY HIGHER DURING WINTER
MONTHS LIKE WE SAW THIS PAST
JANUARY. I DO WANT TO MENTION
THAT WE ALSO PROVIDE A QUARTERLY
REPORT TO OUR BOARD ON THE
SYSTEM SAFETY. THAT DOES INCLUDE
DETAILS ON TRESPASSER STRIKES,
AND WE ARE LOOKING TO MAKE THIS
INFORMATION ALSO MORE READILY
AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE. IN
ADDITION TO THE QUARTER TRENDS,
INFORMATION THAT I SPOKE ABOUT,
WE DO RECOGNIZE THE IMPACTS THAT
THESE TRESPASSER STRIKES HAVE ON
OUR CUSTOMERS AND OUR
OPERATIONS. AND THIS ISN'T
REALLY A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
SOLUTION. WE HAVE RECENTLY
COORDINATED WITH CALIFORNIA
OPERATION LIFESAVER ON OPERATION
SAFE SURF INITIATIVE, WHICH IS A
MULTIFACETED STRATEGY FOR
ENHANCED RAIL SAFETY, EDUCATION
AND AWARENESS. AS PART OF THIS,
WE HAVE RECENTLY COMPLETED RAIL
SAFETY ADVERTISEMENTS DISPLAYED
ON INTERNET CONNECTED TVS AND
STREAMING PLATFORMS THROUGHOUT
AREAS ON THE CORRIDOR WHERE
INCIDENTS ARE MOST PREVALENT.
THESE AREAS INCLUDE SOLANA BEACH
AND OCEANSIDE, LÀ, TÊ,
FULLERTON, OXNARD, AND
CAMARILLO, AS WELL AS SANTA
BARBARA. WE ALSO HAVE DONE
GEOFENCE SAFETY MESSAGING
DISTRIBUTED THROUGH CELL PHONE
ADVERTISING. WE ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING ON DESIGNING SIGNAGE TO
BE INSTALLED ALONG HIGH RISK
AREAS OF THE CORRIDOR, AND THEN
THE FINAL LEG OF THE PROGRAM IS
TO ENGAGE WITH LOCAL RESOURCES
ALONG THE CORRIDOR FOR
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THEY MAY BE
ABLE TO HELP PROVIDE OUTREACH TO
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE LIVING NEAR
THE TRACKS TO OFFER RAIL SAFETY
INFORMATION AND RESOURCES. WE'RE
ALSO CURRENTLY LOOKING TO GET
PSA EDUCATIONAL VIDEOS AND
INFORMATION OUT TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT JURISDICTIONS WHO
HAVE LOCAL BROADCAST CHANNELS,
REALLY TO GET A BROADER REACH
OUT TO OUR LOCAL REGIONS AND
FINALLY, WE ARE LOOKING AT
TECHNOLOGICAL OPPORTUNITIES TO
PILOT THAT INCLUDE TRACK
INTRUSION AND DETECTION
SOLUTIONS, AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO COORDINATING WITH NCTD,
METROLINK AND UP ON THESE
POSSIBLE SOLUTIONS, I DID WANT
TO MENTION ONE LAST ITEM, AND
THAT IS THAT WE ALSO HAVE
COORDINATED WITH AMTRAK POLICE
DEPARTMENT ON EMERGENCY RESPONSE
TRAINING FOR TRESPASSER
INCIDENTS IN WHICH THEY HAVE
DEVELOPED TRAINING CLASSES AS
PART OF A STATEWIDE TRAINING FOR
FIRST RESPONDERS AND CORONERS ON
HOW TO REALLY DEAL WITH
TRESPASSER STRIKES AND REALLY
RAIL EMERGENCIES. AND THIS
TRAINING IS PLANNED TO BE ROLLED
OUT THIS YEAR. OKAY, NOW I
WANTED TO CHANGE GEARS A LITTLE
BIT AND TALK ABOUT OUR ANNUAL
BUSINESS PLAN PROCESS, UNDER OUR
INTERAGENCY TRANSFER AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE AGENCY AND THE
STATE, THE AGENCY IS REQUIRED TO
SUBMIT AN ANNUAL BUSINESS PLAN.
I'M GOING TO REFER TO IT AS OUR
AVP, TO THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION SECRETARY BY
APRIL 1ST OF EACH YEAR. AND OUR
AGREEMENT WITH THE STATE
PRESCRIBES ELEMENTS OF THE AVP,
WHICH IS A TWO YEAR PLANNING,
OPERATIONS AND BUDGET DOCUMENT
AND SERVES REALLY AS THE
AGENCY'S PLAN FOR OPERATING THE
PACIFIC SURFLINER INTERCITY RAIL
SERVICE. IT ALSO INCLUDES A
REPORT ON OVERALL PERFORMANCE,
MARKETING PLAN, CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS ALONG THE
CORRIDOR AND INCLUDES THE
AGENCY'S FUNDING REQUESTS FOR
ADMINISTRATION, OPERATIONS AND
MARKETING. THIS PAST YEAR, WE
BEGAN INCORPORATING THE
REQUIREMENTS OF SB 677 INTO OUR
AVP, WHICH INCLUDES A DISCUSSION
ON THE EFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
ON THE CORRIDOR, AS WELL AS IT
HIGHLIGHTS CAPITAL PROJECTS
PLANNED ALONG THE CORRIDOR TO
INCREASE RESILIENCY AND RELATED
FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES IDENTIFIED
FOR EACH PROJECT. AND THE AVP
PROCESS ITSELF IS REALLY A SIX
MONTH PROCESS THAT STARTS WITH
OUR AGENCY DEVELOPING KEY
ASSUMPTIONS THAT ARE REVIEWED BY
OUR TECHNICAL ADVISORY COMMITTEE
AND THEN ADOPTED BY THE AGENCY
BOARD. ONCE THE INITIAL DRAFT OF
THE AVP DOCUMENT IS COMPLETED IN
THE JANUARY TIME FRAME, WE
REQUEST THAT THE TECHNICAL
ADVISORY COMMITTEE, OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS OUR TAC MEMBERS, TO
REVIEW AND PROVIDE FEEDBACK ON
IT, WHICH THEN GETS INCORPORATED
INTO A REVISED DRAFT. WE BRING
BACK TO OUR TAC BEFORE
PRESENTING IT TO OUR BOARD IN
THE FEBRUARY TIME FRAME FOR
REVIEW AND COMMENT. ANY COMMENTS
FROM BOARD MEMBERS IS THEN
INCORPORATED INTO A FINAL DRAFT,
WHICH IS ALSO RECIRCULATED BACK
THROUGH THE TAC AND BOARD AGAIN
BEFORE FINAL APPROVAL OR
APPROVAL IN THE MARCH TIME FRAME
BEFORE IT IS FINALLY SUBMITTED
TO CALSTAR BY APRIL 1ST, THE
MOST RECENT AVP FOR FISCAL YEAR
24, 25 AND 2526, INCLUDES
ASSUMPTIONS TO RESTORE
APPROXIMATELY 95% OF PRE-COVID
SERVICE LEVELS FOR THE AMTRAK
PACIFIC SURFLINER SERVICE IN
FISCAL YEAR 2425. THIS INCLUDES
RESTORING THE 11TH AND 12TH
ROUND TRIPS BETWEEN LA AND SAN
DIEGO AND MAINTAINING A FIFTH
ROUND TRIP BETWEEN SAN DIEGO AND
GOLETA, WITH TWO OF THOSE TRIPS
CONTINUING TO SAN LUIS OBISPO.
AS WE LOOK TOWARDS FISCAL YEAR
2526, WE ARE ANTICIPATING EITHER
THE RESTORATION OF THE 13TH
ROUND TRIP, WHICH IS WHAT WE HAD
PRE-COVID BETWEEN SAN DIEGO AND
LOS ANGELES OR INTRODUCING A
POSSIBLE THIRD ROUND TRIP TO SAN
LUIS OBISPO, REALLY DEPENDENT ON
OUR MARKET ANALYSIS AND FEEDBACK
WE RECEIVE FROM OUR TECHNICAL
ADVISORY COMMITTEE AND APPROVAL
FROM OUR BOARD, WE ARE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THE SUPPORT OF
CALTRANS CALSTAR, THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR FOR
APPROVING THE 2024 BUDGET, WHICH
INCLUDES AN INCREASE TO THE
CALIFORNIA INTERCITY RAIL
FUNDING BY 210, BASICALLY 211
MILLION OVER THREE YEARS TO
SUPPORT THE RESTORATION OF OUR
SERVICES AND FUTURE GROWTH. WE
ARE CURRENTLY COORDINATING WITH
CALSTAR AND CALTRANS ON REFINING
FORECASTS AND FLEET PLANNING
THAT WILL SUPPORT AND MAXIMIZE
SERVICE RESTORATION FOR ALL
THREE CALIFORNIA JPAS ALL THREE
CORRIDORS. AND FINALLY, FOR THE
LAST SLIDE, I MENTIONED THE
CAPITAL PROJECTS LIST THAT IS
INCLUDED IN OUR AVP. THIS SLIDE
SHOWS THE PROJECTS THAT ARE
ACTIVE IN MAP FORM ALONG THE
CORRIDOR. ACTIVE PROJECTS ARE
THOSE IN SOME LEVEL OF ACTIVE
PLANNING, DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCTION, OR RECENTLY
COMPLETED OR CLOSED OUT. THESE
PROJECTS ARE BEING IMPLEMENTED
BY VARIOUS HOST RAILROADS,
MEMBER AGENCIES, AND
STAKEHOLDERS AND REALLY SERVES
AS A REMINDER OF THE AMOUNT OF
CAPITAL, INVESTMENT AND WORK
THAT IS NOT ONLY BEING
COORDINATED ALONG THE CORRIDOR,
BUT IS ALSO NECESSARY TO IMPROVE
THE CORRIDOR FOR THE FUTURE,
INCLUDING THE ADDRESSING THE
LONG TERM RESILIENCY OF THE
CORRIDOR. AND I'M SURE KYLE
GRADINGER FROM CALTRANS, WHO IS
ON THE SECOND PANEL TODAY, WILL
GET INTO THIS DURING HIS
DISCUSSION. BUT WE ARE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT OUR CORRIDOR BEING
ACCEPTED INTO THE FEDERAL
CORRIDOR IDENTIFICATION AND
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM. OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS CORRIDOR ID. WE BELIEVE
THIS WILL SOLIDIFY A ROADMAP FOR
DEVELOPING A PIPELINE OF FUTURE
INTER-CITY RAIL RELATED
IMPROVEMENTS AND EXPANSIONS
ALONG THE CORRIDOR, AS WELL AS
FUNDING STRATEGIES TO MAXIMIZE
THE INVESTMENTS NEEDED FOR THE
CORRIDOR. WITH THAT, THAT
CONCLUDES MY BRIEF PRESENTATION,
AND I'LL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. OKAY,
THANK YOU FOR THE MEMBERS WHO
HAVE RECENTLY ARRIVED. WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR FROM ALL THE
PANELISTS AND THEN ASK QUESTIONS.
SO WE'LL MOVE ON. SEAN, ARE YOU
NEXT OR I'M NOT SURE WHICH OF
YOU IS NEXT. SHOULD YOU GO AHEAD?
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND
COLLEAGUES, ANY TIME WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME AND SPEAK
HERE AT THE CAPITOL ABOUT THINGS
THAT REALLY IMPACT PUBLIC
TRANSIT, IT'S A GREAT HONOR TO
DO SO AND TO BE ABLE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS FOR ANYBODY THAT THEY
HAVE OF US. MY NAME IS SEAN
DONAGHY. I'M THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER AT THE NORTH COUNTY
TRANSIT DISTRICT. OBVIOUSLY,
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE
TODAY. OUR MAIN TOPIC OF
DISCUSSION IS RAIL SERVICE ALONG
THE LAWCENTER CORRIDOR. BUT
FIRST, I'D LIKE TO PROVIDE A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF NTDS OVERALL
TRANSIT SYSTEM AND HOW OUR
SERVICES WORK TOGETHER. NCTD
OPERATES SIX MODES ACROSS
APPROXIMATELY 1020MI² OF SERVICE
AREA IN NORTH SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
THE NTDS MODES INCLUDE COASTER,
COMMUTER RAIL OR SPRINTER HYBRID
RAIL, RAIL, AS WELL AS FIXED
ROUTE AND FLEXIBLE BUS SERVICE,
PARATRANSIT AND MICRO TRANSIT.
WE ARE ONE OF ONLY SEVEN
AGENCIES IN THE NATION THAT
OPERATE HYBRID RAIL SERVICE, AND
WE ARE ONE OF ONLY THREE
AGENCIES IN THE NATION THAT
OPERATE HYBRID RAIL, HEAVY RAIL
AND BUS SERVICE. THE DISTRICT IS
UNIQUE IN THAT WE OWN A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE SAN
DIEGO SUBDIVISION OF THE LOW SAN
CORRIDOR THAT IS NOT VERY COMMON
IN PUBLIC TRANSIT. NCTD IS THE
RAILROAD OF RECORD AND THE RAIL
COMMON CARRIER FOR THE SAN DIEGO
SUBDIVISION AS DESIGNATED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, AND THESE
DESIGNATIONS COME WITH QUITE A
FEW RESPONSIBILITIES. NCTD IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR MAINTENANCE OF
THE SAN DIEGO SUBDIVISION, AND
MUST ENSURE THAT THE LINE
REMAINS OPEN FOR AMTRAK,
METROLINK, METROLINK SERVICES,
FREIGHT MOVEMENT AND AMTRAK.
NET. AS MENTIONED BEFORE, IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE MILITARY AS
THE OWNER, NCTD ENTERS SHARED
USE AGREEMENTS WITH EACH ENTITY
THAT USES OUR RAIL LINE. WE ARE
ALSO RESPONSIBLE FOR DISPATCHING
EVERY TRAIN THAT ENTERS THE SAN
DIEGO SUBDIVISION TO ENSURE THE
SAFE MOVEMENT OF PASSENGERS AND
GOODS AT NCTD WORKS WITH
METROLINK, AMTRAK AND BNSF,
ALONG WITH LOW SAN ON SCHEDULING
TO OPTIMIZE RAIL SERVICE AND
CONNECTIVITY BETWEEN OUR
SERVICES. RIDERS ON ANY OF THESE
MODES CAN CONNECT TO METROLINK
AND AMTRAK PACIFIC SURFLINER AT
OUR OCEANSIDE TRANSIT CENTER,
WHICH SERVES AS A HUB FOR
REGIONAL CONNECTIVITY. FROM
THERE, THEY CAN CONTINUE THEIR
JOURNEY THROUGH NORTH LOS
ANGELES TO ENDLESS DESTINATIONS
ON AMTRAK. WE'RE ALSO WORKING
TOGETHER TO ADVANCE CAPITAL
PROJECTS THAT STRENGTHEN OUR
SHARED RAIL LINE, NCTD AND THE
SAN DIEGO ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS RECENTLY SUBMITTED
STATE AND FEDERAL FUNDING
APPLICATIONS FOR THE EASTBROOK
TO SHELL DOUBLE TRACK PROJECT.
THIS PROJECT MAKES NECESSARY
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE RAIL
INFRASTRUCTURE NORTH OF THE
OCEANSIDE TRANSIT CENTER TO
IMPROVE RAIL OPERATIONS ON THE
SAN DIEGO SUBDIVISION, ONE OF
THE MAIN PROJECTS, ONE OF THE
MAIN PROJECT COMPONENTS IS
REPLACING A 100 YEAR OLD BRIDGE
OVER THE SAN LUIS REY RIVER IN
OCEANSIDE. REPLACEMENT OF THIS
BRIDGE IS CRUCIAL TO MAINTAINING
STATE OF GOOD REPAIR ON THE LINE
AND REDUCING NTDS CONTINUING
MAINTENANCE COSTS. THE PROJECT
IS KEY TO ENSURING CLIMATE
RESILIENCY ON THE CORRIDOR AS
WELL AS SEA LEVELS RISE RAIL
BRIDGES ALONG LOW SAND CORRIDOR
ARE MORE SUSCEPTIBLE TO WASHOUT
BY REPLACING THE EXISTING BRIDGE
ACROSS THE RIVER WITH A CONCRETE
BRIDGE, IT MITIGATES THESE
RISKS. THE PROJECT WILL ALSO
CONSTRUCT AN ADDITIONAL TRACK,
WHICH WILL ELIMINATE A MAJOR
BOTTLENECK AND CREATE TEN MILES
OF CONTINUOUS DOUBLE TRACK. THE
ELIMINATION OF THIS BOTTLENECK
WILL INCREASE SERVICE
RELIABILITY THROUGHOUT THE
CORRIDOR. SINGLE TRACK
BOTTLENECKS CAN CONTRIBUTE TO
SEVERAL TRAIN DELAYS, WHICH MAY
HAVE CASCADING EFFECTS ON OTHER
SERVICES AND WITH OUR PARTNERS
HERE AT THE TABLE. DOUBLE
TRACKING IS ALSO ESSENTIAL TO
ALLOW NCTD, METROLINK AND LO SAN
TO INCREASE SERVICE FREQUENCIES
IN THE FUTURE. AS PREVIOUSLY
DISCUSSED, NCTD AND SANDAG
FUNDING APPLICATIONS FOR THIS
PROJECT WERE SUPPORTED BY
LAUSANNE, AMTRAK, BNSF AND
METROLINK, EACH HIGHLIGHTING THE
BENEFITS THAT THE PROJECT WILL
HAVE TO THEIR SERVICES. WE ARE
ALSO VERY APPRECIATIVE OF
SENATOR BLAKE SPEER'S SUPPORT AS
WELL. WE'RE ALSO ADVANCING
SEVERAL OTHER STATE OF GOOD
REPAIR PROJECTS, CAPACITY
ENHANCING AND CLIMATE RESILIENCY
ON THE SAN DIEGO SUBDIVISION
THAT ARE FULLY FUNDED. SANDAG
BEGAN CONSTRUCTION THIS YEAR OF
THE PHASE FIVE OF THE DEL MAR
BLUFFS PROJECT, WHICH WILL
STABILIZE THE BLUFFS FOR 30
YEARS. THIS PROJECT CONTINUES
NCTD AND SANDAG DECADES LONG
EFFORT TO SHORE UP THE BLUFFS
AND MAINTAIN RESILIENCY WITHIN
THE CORRIDOR, AND LAST YEAR, THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AWARDED NCTD
100 MILLION FOR THE SAN DIEGUITO
DOUBLE TRACK PHASE TWO PROJECT.
THIS PROJECT WILL REPLACE THE
SAN DIEGUITO RIVER RAILWAY
BRIDGE AND PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
DOUBLE TRACKING SUPPORT FOR THE
LINE. THE PROJECT ALSO ADDS NEW
SPECIAL EVENT STATION AT THE DEL
MAR FAIRGROUNDS, AND MAKES IT
EASIER FOR TO TAKE THE AMTRAK
PACIFIC SURFLINER AND COASTER TO
SOME OF THE REGION'S MOST
POPULAR EVENTS. ADDITIONALLY,
SANDAG RECEIVED 103 MILLION FOR
THE BATIQUITOS LAGOON DOUBLE
TRACK PROJECT, WHICH SIMILARLY
REPLACES AN AGING RAIL BRIDGE
AND ADDS ADDITIONAL DOUBLE
TRACKING ALONG THE LINE.
COMPLETION OF PROJECTS LIKE
THESE ALONG THE CORRIDOR ARE
CRITICAL TO PROVIDE THE BEST
RAIL SERVICE POSSIBLE FOR OUR
RIDERS, WE WORK TOGETHER TO
PRIORITIZE THE ADVANCEMENT OF
PROJECTS THAT PRESENT THE MOST
NEED. NCTD PARTICIPATES IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE STATE RAIL
PLAN, WHICH PROVIDES A STRATEGY
FOR NEAR, MID AND LONG TERM
INVESTMENTS NEEDED TO ENHANCE
STATEWIDE RAIL SERVICE. NCTD
ALSO PARTICIPATES IN CORRIDOR ID,
THE EFFORT FOR THE LOW SPEED
CORRIDOR BETWEEN THE STATE AND
FEDERAL RAILROAD ADMINISTRATION,
THE LAUSANNE OPTIMIZATION STUDY
AND SANDAG REGIONAL PLAN ALSO
LAYS OUT THE FRAMEWORK FOR THE
PRIORITIZATION OF THE SAN DIEGO
REGION REGION'S PROJECTS. THIS
COORDINATION IS IMPORTANT TO
FUNDING APPLICATIONS, BUT ALSO
TO ENSURE EFFECTIVE INVESTMENTS
ARE BEING MADE TO ATTRACT NEW
RIDERS AND ADAPT TO CHANGING
RIDERSHIP PATTERNS. RIDERSHIP IS
CONTINUING TO RECOVER, AND WE'VE
MADE SOME CHANGES TO OUR SERVICE
TO BETTER MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR
CUSTOMERS. WE'VE IMPROVED FIRST
AND LAST MILE CONNECTIONS ALONG
OUR RAIL CORRIDOR. NCTD RECENTLY
LAUNCHED FIVE NEW FLEX BUS
ROUTES TO EXPAND CONNECTIVITY
FROM ONE OF OUR KEY COASTER
STATIONS TO THE SAN DIEGO
REGION'S LARGEST EMPLOYMENT
CENTER AND MAJOR EDUCATIONAL,
RETAIL AND HEALTHCARE
DESTINATIONS. NCTD INCREASED
COASTER FREQUENCIES IN OCTOBER
OF 2021 AND HAS SEEN AN INCREASE
IN RIDERSHIP YEAR OVER YEAR.
WEEKEND RIDERSHIP ON THE COASTER
IS ACTUALLY HIGHER THAN
PRE-PANDEMIC LEVELS, AND WE'RE
WORKING TO WORKING TO MAKE
PAYING FOR YOUR TICKET EASIER TO
RIDE FOR THOSE WHO AREN'T
FAMILIAR WITH OUR SYSTEM, AS OF
ABOUT A MONTH AGO, RIDERS CAN
SIMPLY TAP THEIR CREDIT CARD,
PHONE OR SMARTWATCH TO PAY FOR
THEIR TICKET. NCTD ALSO
RECOGNIZES THAT SECURITY IN OUR
MODES IS A HUGE FACTOR AFFECTING
OUR RIDERS AND CGRTS BOARD OF
DIRECTORS RECENTLY APPROVED AN
18% INCREASE IN OUR SECURITY
BUDGET AND WE'RE VERY THANKFUL
FOR THAT. WE'RE USING THOSE
RESOURCES TO EXPAND OUR PRESENCE
AT TRANSIT CENTERS AND ON OUR
MODES TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
RIDERS FEEL SAFE. WE'RE ALSO
IMPLEMENTING TEXT BASED SECURITY
ALERTS, ENHANCING CLOSED CIRCUIT
TV VIDEO EQUIPMENT, AND
IMPROVING LIGHTING AT ALL OF OUR
TRANSIT CENTERS. NCTD CONTINUES
TO IDENTIFY WAYS THAT WE CAN
ENHANCE THE RIDER EXPERIENCE AND
UTILIZE EXISTING RESOURCES
EFFECTIVELY TO DO SO. OUR FISCAL
2025 BUDGET INCLUDES FUNDING FOR
SEVERAL PRIORITY PROJECTS,
INCLUDING WAYFINDING AND
NAVIGATING OUR TRANSIT CENTERS,
EASIER TICKETING ENHANCEMENTS TO
MAKE PURCHASING AND VALIDATING
TICKETS AND PASSES MORE
CONVENIENT, AND A NEW PEDESTRIAN
CROSSING AT THE OCEANSIDE
TRANSIT CENTER TO IMPROVE
CONNECTIONS BETWEEN MODES. WHILE
NTD'S FIVE YEAR BUDGET IS
BALANCED, FUNDING FOR THE IN THE
OUT YEARS IS MORE CHALLENGING
DUE TO SLOWING SALES TAX
REVENUES AND FORMULA FUNDING
PROJECTIONS. NCD HAS WORKED HARD
TO DIVERSIFY OUR REVENUE SOURCES
TO MITIGATE SOME OF THE IMPACTS
OF CHANGING FISCAL ENVIRONMENTS.
WE RECENTLY AND THEN HAVE, OVER
THE PAST FEW YEARS, LAUNCHED A
TRANSIT ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM AND HAVE ENGAGED
PARTNERS TO REDEVELOP SIX OF OUR
TRANSIT CENTERS. SO FAR, THE
DISTRICT HAS STRUCTURED THESE
AGREEMENTS AS GROUND LEASES.
NCTD MAINTAINS OWNERSHIP OF THE
LAND AND OUR TRANSIT CENTERS TO
DEVELOP, SO THE DEVELOPERS PAY
US A LEASE FEE. TRANSIT ORIENTED
DEVELOPMENT NOT ONLY GENERATES A
STABLE SOURCE OF REVENUE FOR THE
DISTRICT, BUT ALSO CREATES
ORGANIC RIDERSHIP. WE CONTINUE
TO WE CONTINUE TO BE EXCITED
ABOUT OUR EXPANSION OF OUR
OUTREACH AND COMMUNITY PARTNERS
THROUGH THESE DEVELOPMENTS AND
BEYOND. WHILE WE MAINTAIN GREAT
RELATIONSHIPS WITH JURISDICTIONS
IN OUR SERVICE AREA, WE ARE
PLACING A SIGNIFICANT FOCUS ON
OUR INCREASING OUR PRESENCES
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'VE REPEATEDLY
SAID TO SOME OF THE CITIES IN
OUR JURISDICTION IS WE WANT TO
BE MORE THAN A TRANSIT AGENCY.
WE WANT TO BE PART OF PROJECTS
THAT MAY NOT NECESSARILY BE
EXACTLY TRANSIT FOCUSED, AND WE
WANT TO PUT ENERGY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE CITIES IN NORTH COUNTY
HAVE THE ENERGY FROM OUR
ORGANIZATION, THAT THEY NEED TO
BE ABLE TO FUND AND SUPPORT ALL
PROJECTS THAT WILL IMPROVE
QUALITY OF LIFE PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN NCTD AND OUR
COMMUNITIES, AND ELECTED
OFFICIALS, AS WELL AS MY
COLLEAGUES HERE ON THE PANEL,
ARE INTEGRAL TO THE SUCCESS OF
OUR SHARED TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK. AND AGAIN, I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF NCTD, AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE AS WE ENGAGE
IN DISCUSSION WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. MR. JEWELL, WOULD YOU
MIND, I THINK ON THE, ON THAT ON
THE VERY FIRST PAGE IS OUR
PRESENTATION THAT IS, I'M GOING
TO BE SUPER COMPLICATED. I HAVE
A SINGLE SLIDE, YEAH. IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND PUTTING THAT UP. I
APPRECIATE THAT, THANK YOU,
JASON. AND THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE, FOR THE INVITATION
TO SPEAK TO YOU TODAY. MY NAME
IS DARREN KETTLE, CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA REGIONAL
RAIL AUTHORITY. SRA WHICH
OPERATES METROLINK, IS A JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY CONSISTING OF
THE TRANSPORTATION COMMISSIONS
OF LOS ANGELES, ORANGE,
RIVERSIDE, SAN BERNARDINO AND
VENTURA COUNTIES. WHEN METROLINK
LAUNCHED OUR FIRST TRAIN IN
1992, WE OPERATED ON THREE
LINES. METROLINK PROVIDES
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WITH A SAFE,
EFFICIENT, DEPENDABLE CUSTOMER
COMMUTER RAIL SERVICE. WE OFFER
AN OUTSTANDING CUSTOMER
EXPERIENCE. WE REDUCE EMISSIONS
AND FOSTER ECONOMIC VITALITY BY
CONNECTING JOBS AND HOUSING IN A
TRADITIONALLY CAR CENTRIC
REGION. TODAY, WHAT YOU SEE ON
THE SCREEN BEFORE YOU IS OUR
SYSTEM. WE OPERATE A 545 ROUTE
MILE EIGHT LINE SYSTEM SERVING
SIX COUNTIES, MAKING METROLINK
THE THIRD LARGEST REGIONAL
PASSENGER RAILROAD IN THE UNITED
STATES. AS YOU ARE AWARE,
REDUCING VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
IS A MAJOR GOAL FOR CALIFORNIA.
METROLINK IS UNIQUELY POSITIONED
TO PROVIDE VIABLE ALTERNATIVE
TRANSPORTATION TO THOSE
TRAVELING LONGER DISTANCES. WE
REMOVED 4.1 MILLION CAR TRIPS IN
FISCAL YEAR 24, WITH AN AVERAGE
TRIP LENGTH OF 37 MILES. THIS
EQUATES TO A WHOPPING 152
MILLION FEWER VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
OUR ANTELOPE VALLEY AND ORANGE
COUNTY LINES RUN PARALLEL TO
I-5. OUR RIVERSIDE LINE RUNS
PARALLEL TO SR 60. THE 91 PARIS
VALLEY AND INLAND EMPIRE LINES
PARALLEL THE 91 CORRIDOR BETWEEN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND ORANGE
COUNTY. OUR SAN BERNARDINO LINE
OPERATES ALONGSIDE I-10 AND 210,
AND THE VENTURA COUNTY LINE
PARALLELS THE 101 AND 118
FREEWAYS FROM LOS ANGELES TO
VENTURA. NOT ONLY DO THESE
PASSENGER RAIL LINES OFFER
ALTERNATIVES TO DRIVING, BUT
THEY TRANSPORT RESIDENTS IN MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING MARKETS TO
JOBS AND ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES
IN THE REST OF THE REGION. JUST
AS SEAN MENTIONED. NATIONWIDE
COMMUTER RAILROAD. COMMUTER
COMMUTER RAIL RIDERS HAVE BEEN
SLOW TO RETURN TO THE WORKFORCE
AND METROLINK IS NO EXCEPTION.
WITH PANDEMIC RELATED HYBRID
REMOTE WORK SCHEDULES APPEARING
PERMANENT, WE HAVE TO PLAN TO
REBUILD OUR RIDERSHIP INSTEAD OF
INSTEAD OF CATERING MAINLY TO 9
TO 5 COMMUTERS TRAVELING TO JOB
CENTERS IN LOS ANGELES AND
ORANGE COUNTY, WE ARE TAKING A
MAJOR STEP TO TRANSITION OUR
SERVICE MODEL FROM A COMMUTER
RAIL ORIENTATION TO THAT OF A
REGIONAL PASSENGER RAIL MODEL
UNDER WHAT WE CALL METROLINK
REIMAGINED SERVICE. WE WILL
INCREASE OFF PEAK TRAIN
AVAILABILITY IN THE MIDDLE PART
OF THE DAY AND INTO THE EVENINGS
ON WEEKDAYS, OUR REGIONAL RAIL
TRANSITION IS SIMILAR TO OTHER
EFFORTS AROUND THE COUNTRY AND
IS BASED ON PROJECTED UNMET
RIDERSHIP DEMAND. WHEN WE
SURVEYED OUR CUSTOMERS IN 2022,
RESPONDENTS WERE QUICK TO CALL
OUT THE LIMITATIONS OF A
COMMUTER CENTRIC SYSTEM.
RESPONDENTS NOTED THAT
METROLINK'S EXISTING HOURS OF
OPERATION PRECLUDE THEM FROM
TAKING THE TRAIN TO MANY LEISURE
ACTIVITIES, INCLUDING SPORTING
EVENTS, CONCERTS AND DAY TRIPS.
THREE AND FOUR RIDERS SAID THEY
WOULD BE MORE LIKELY TO RIDE
METROLINK IF WE INCREASED MIDDAY
SERVICE AND A SIGNIFICANT 87%
ASKED FOR MORE WEEKEND TRAINS
BEGINNING IN OCTOBER. WE INTEND
TO EXPAND SERVICE TO MEET THIS
DEMAND. SPECIFICALLY, WE INTEND
TO ADD 32 TRAINS GOING FROM 142
TO 174 TRAINS DAILY. WE WILL
SPREAD SERVICE ACROSS THE DAY
AND INTO THE EVENING. THE
SCHEDULE WILL PROMOTE, TRANSFER
OPPORTUNITIES THROUGH PULSE OR
CLOCK FACE SCHEDULING ACROSS ALL
LINES, PROVIDING A BETTER
ALTERNATIVE TO DRIVING AND
BETTER CONNECTIVITY AT LA UNION
STATION. WE WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO DO THAT WERE IT NOT FOR
THE FIVE MEMBER AGENCIES OF THE
ERA SYSTEM. HAD THEY NOT
APPROVED AN ADDITIONAL $7.2
MILLION TO OUR BUDGET THIS YEAR
TO ALLOW US TO APPROACH THIS NEW
MODEL, METROLINK IS ALSO
BUILDING RIDERSHIP THROUGH FARE
ALTERNATIVES, MUCH LIKE OUR
SISTER AGENCIES. ONE OF THE MOST
EXCITING OF THESE HAS BEEN THE
LAUNCH OF OUR STUDENT ADVENTURE
PASS. WE LAUNCHED IT IN OCTOBER
OF 2023, AND IT WAS DONE WITH AN
INITIAL GRANT FROM THE FROM
CALTRANS OUT OF THE LOW CARBON
TRANSIT OPERATIONS PROGRAM,
STUDENTS CAN NOW RIDE THE
METROLINK SYSTEM ALL EIGHT LINES
FOR FREE. IT'S FUNDED THROUGH
THROUGH THAT GRANT, OVER 1
MILLION STUDENT TICKETS HAVE
BEEN ACTIVATED TO DATE. STUDENT
TICKET SALES IN MAY AND JUNE OF
THIS YEAR. MORE THAN DOUBLED
WHEN COMPARED TO LAST YEAR, AND
THESE STUDENTS ARE OFTEN NEW
RIDERS. A RECENT POLL SHOWED
THAT 34% OF THE STUDENTS HAD
NEVER TAKEN METROLINK. PRIOR TO
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR
STUDENT ADVENTURE PASS. AS I'VE
SHARED WITH THIS COMMITTEE
BEFORE, I CAN PERSONALLY REPORT
AS A FREQUENT VENTURA COUNTY AND
VENTURA COUNTY LINE RIDER AS I
LIVE IN VENTURA COUNTY, I HAVE
SPOKEN TO STUDENTS ON BOARD WHO
EXPRESS TRUE GRATITUDE IN THIS
PROGRAM THAT OPENS BOTH
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES AND LIFE
EXPERIENCE TO THE NEXT
GENERATION OF PUBLIC TRANSIT
USERS. WE ARE ALSO MAKING
SERVICE MORE CONVENIENT AND
FREQUENT THROUGH EXPANDED
PARTNERSHIPS WITH OUR GREAT
PARTNER IN LAUSANNE, OUR CODE
SHARE PROGRAM THAT ALLOWS
METROLINK TICKET HOLDERS TO RIDE
ALL PACIFIC SURFLINER TRAINS
BETWEEN UNION STATION AND
VENTURA. THIS PROGRAM IS
DESIGNED TO INCREASE SERVICE
LEVELS FOR CUSTOMERS ON THE
VENTURA COUNTY LINE, WHERE WE
RUN FEWER METROLINK TRAINS. THE
LAUNCH. THE LAUNCH OF THE CODE
SHARE PROGRAM HAS PROVEN HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL. RIDERSHIP BETWEEN
UNION STATION AND VENTURA WAS UP
96% IN THE LAST 12 MONTHS,
INCREASING ABOUT FROM ABOUT
30,000 TO 60,000 RIDERS. COMPARE
THAT TO SOUTH OF UNION STATION,
WHERE OUR RAIL TO RAIL PROGRAM,
WHICH IS ALSO AN EFFECTIVE TOOL,
ALLOWS FOR TRAVEL ON BOTH
SYSTEMS. AGAIN METROLINK AND
SURFLINER, BUT ONLY FOR MONTHLY
PASS HOLDERS. RIDERSHIP HAS ALSO
INCREASED, BUT AT A SMALLER
MARGIN OF ABOUT 45%. AT THE
REQUEST OF SANTA BARBARA AND
VENTURA COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES, WE HAVE PROVIDED A
PROPOSAL TO OPERATE NEW COMMUTER
RAIL SERVICE AS FAR NORTH AS
GOLETA IN IN SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY, THE VENTURA COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION
APPROVED $3.8 MILLION OF SB1
FUNDING, AND THE SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENT
INTENDS TO USE LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION SALES TAX DOLLARS
TO SUPPORT THIS SERVICE.
EXPANSION. CONCURRENT WITH THESE
EFFORTS, WE ARE ALSO EVALUATING
CHANGES TO SIMPLIFY AND REDUCE
OUR COMPLICATED FARE OFFERINGS.
RECOMMENDATIONS WILL BE
PUBLISHED LATER THIS YEAR WITH
THE GOAL OF REDUCING CUSTOMER
CONFUSION AND SUPPORTING LONG
TERM GROWTH ACROSS OUR SYSTEM.
ADDITIONALLY, IT IS WORTH NOTING
THAT METROLINK HAS HELD THE LINE
ON TICKET PRICING, HAVING NOT
RAISED TICKET PRICES PRICES
SINCE PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC.
WHILE MANY OTHER OF OUR DAILY
EXPENSES HAVE INFLATED SINCE THE
PANDEMIC, OUR FARES HAVE NOT,
AND I'M PLEASED TO REPORT THAT
THESE INITIATIVES ARE GARNERING
RESULTS. METROLINK RIDERSHIP
REACHED 6.3 MILLION BOARDINGS IN
FISCAL YEAR 24, AN INCREASE OF
22% OVER FISCAL YEAR 23. AND ON
OUR BEST DAYS, WE AVERAGE ABOUT
58% OF PRE-PANDEMIC RIDERSHIP AS
COMPARED TO 2019. WITHIN THE
CONTEXT OF THIS ENCOURAGING
GROWTH STORY ACROSS OUR SYSTEM,
I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS PERFORMANCE
ON THE LOW SAN CORRIDOR, WHICH
IS HOME TO SOME OF THE BUSIEST
STATION PAIRS ACROSS OUR SYSTEM.
OUT OF THE TOP 20 STATION PAIRS,
FIVE OF THEM ARE ON THE LOW SAN
CORRIDOR. LAST YEAR, THE UNION
STATION AND FULLERTON STATIONS
HOSTED NEARLY 148,000 TICKET
RIDERS. OUR BUSIEST STATION PAIR
SYSTEM SYSTEMWIDE TO KEEP THESE
POSITIVE NUMBERS GROWING, WE
PLACE MAJOR EMPHASIS ON ON TIME
PERFORMANCE THAT WAS REFERENCED
BY MR. JEWELL. A SHORT TIME AGO.
WE KNOW THAT CUSTOMERS RELY FOR
US ON HIGH QUALITY, DEPENDABLE,
ON TIME SERVICE. ONE OF THE
CAUSES OF DELAY IS FREIGHT.
FREIGHT TRAIN INTERFERENCE.
HOWEVER, OUR COORDINATION WITH
THE BURLINGTON NORTHERN, SANTA
FE AND U.P. RAILROADS HAS
IMPROVED OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS
AS WE HAVE INCREASED OUR DIALOG
WITH REGULAR MEETINGS TO
IDENTIFY HOTSPOTS AND WORK WITH
OPERATORS TO IMPLEMENT CHANGES
AS NEEDED TO REDUCE DISRUPTIONS
AND DELAYS. MORE RECENTLY,
ANOTHER LEADING CAUSE, AND THIS
IS JUST ALSO ADDRESSED BY MR.
JEWELL, AS WAS HE WOULD
REFERENCED MY REMARKS FOR BOTH
PASSENGER TRAINS AND FREIGHT
TRAINS. IS VANDALISM ON OUR
SIGNAL SYSTEMS BY VANDALISM, I
MEAN THE DISTURBING TREND OF
COPPER WIRE THEFT WHEN OUR
SIGNAL HOUSES ARE BROKEN INTO,
OR CABLES THAT CONNECT SIGNALS
OR GRADE CROSSINGS ARE CUT, IT
CREATES A SERIOUS SAFETY ISSUE
AND REQUIRES US TO OPERATE AT
SLOW SPEEDS. OF COURSE, THIS
IMPACTS OUR ON TIME PERFORMANCE,
AND MR. JEWELL ALSO REFERENCED
THE ISSUE RELATED TO ON TIME
PERFORMANCE THAT COMES ABOUT DUE
TO THE VERY SAD TRAGEDY OF
PEDESTRIAN STRIKES. I WILL NOT
GO INTO ANY GREATER DETAIL ON
THAT. IT'S A DIFFICULT ISSUE FOR
US AS THIS WHOLE SYSTEM, TO HAVE
TO ADDRESS, BUT WE ARE TRYING TO
MAKE ATTEMPTS AND NOT LETTING GO
OF JUST THE SITUATION OCCURRING
IN ADDRESSING THE CHALLENGE,
METROLINK HAS SECURED A EARMARK
FROM CONGRESSMAN BRAD SHERMAN
AND AN ADDITIONAL FEDERAL GRANT
TO DEVELOP PIONEERING TRACK
INTRUSION DETECTION SYSTEM. IT
IS OUR INTENT TO USE AI TO
CONNECT WITH OUR EXISTING
POSITIVE TRAIN CONTROL
TECHNOLOGY. CAMERAS WILL
IDENTIFY TRESPASSERS AND
UTILIZING THE PTC SYSTEM, PTC
SYSTEM INFORM TRAIN ENGINEERS TO
SLOW OR STOP TRAINS. I WILL END
MY REMARKS BY EMPHASIZING, WHILE
THIS IS AN EXCITING TIME IN THE
METROLINK HISTORY, WE HAVE
CHALLENGES OR OPPORTUNITIES
AHEAD. MOST IMPORTANTLY,
METROLINK NEEDS THE STATE'S HELP
IN IDENTIFYING ALTERNATIVE,
DEDICATED REVENUE SOURCES THAT
COMMUTER RAILROADS CAN LEVERAGE
FOR CAPITAL OR OPERATING
EXPENSES. SB 125 WAS A LIFELINE
FOR TRANSIT OPERATIONS. WE
APPRECIATE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT TRANSIT THROUGH THE VERY
CHALLENGING FY 2425 STATE
BUDGET, BUT LONG TERM, A LACK OF
DEDICATED FUNDING IS A MAJOR
OBSTACLE TO OUR PLANS FOR
SERVICE GROWTH. NEW RAILROAD
TRACK CAPACITY AND THE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT STATE OF
GOOD REPAIR NEEDS OF ALL OF OUR
SYSTEMS. ADDITIONALLY, OUR
AGENCY IS SEEKING GRANT FUNDING
TO REPLACE OLDER POLLUTING
LOCOMOTIVES WITH TIER FOUR. THE
CLEANEST BURNING DIESEL
LOCOMOTIVES IN THE UNITED
STATES. IN MARCH 2021, THE
METROLINK BOARD APPROVED OUR
CLIMATE ACTION PLAN IN ORDER TO
AND TO DO OUR PART TO REDUCE AIR
POLLUTION, WE HAVE REPLACED 40
OLDER LOCOMOTIVES WITH TIER
FOURS OUT OF A CORE FLEET OF 55
BY FAR THE STATE, AND PROBABLY
THE NATION'S LARGEST TIER FOUR
FLEET. FOR A PASSENGER RAIL
SYSTEM. BUT WE NEED TO REPLACE
15 MORE, AND IF WE CAN'T EXPAND
OUR TIER FOUR FLEET BY 2030 OR
EARLIER, WE RISK BEING OUT OF
COMPLIANCE WITH CARB'S. RECENTLY
ADOPTED IN USE LOCOMOTIVE
REGULATION. AND WE MAY HAVE TO
REPURPOSE OPERATIONS, FUNDING
AND CUT SERVICE. THOUGH WE HAVE
REPEATEDLY TRIED TO SECURE
FEDERAL GRANTS TO REPLACE OUR
REMAINING FLEET, OUR
APPLICATIONS HAVE NOT BEEN
SUCCESSFUL THUS FAR. WE COULD
SURE USE THE HELP OF LAWMAKERS
SUCH AS YOURSELVES, EXPRESSING
SUPPORT FOR OUR FEDERAL
APPLICATIONS. REGIONAL AND STATE
CONSENSUS GOES A LONG WAY. AND
THEN FINALLY, GIVEN WHERE WE ARE
TUESDAY AFTER THE OLYMPICS, WE
ARE NO LESS THAN FOUR YEARS AWAY
FROM 2028. THE REGIONAL PUBLIC
TRANSIT SYSTEM MUST BE READY TO
ACCOMMODATE THE ESTIMATED 3
MILLION EXPECTED ATTENDEES.
METROLINK WILL SERVE AS THE
REGIONAL BACKBONE OF PUBLIC
TRANSIT SERVICE, CONNECTING
PEOPLE TO VENUES THROUGHOUT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. WE SAW
FIRSTHAND JUST A LITTLE OVER TWO
WEEKS AGO, THE IMPORTANCE OF
READYING PUBLIC TRANSIT FOR THE
GAMES. UNFORTUNATELY FRANCE'S
REGIONAL RAIL LINES WERE HIT BY
COORDINATED ATTACKS AND
VANDALISM, DISRUPTING THE
OPENING CEREMONIES AND OTHER
COMPETITIONS. THE FIRST COUPLE
OF DAYS, WE CAN IMPROVE
TRANSIT'S RESILIENCE AGAINST
SECURITY THREATS, BUT WE NEED
FEDERAL AND STATE SUPPORT TO
ENSURE OUR SYSTEM OPERATES IN AN
EFFICIENT, SAFE AND RELIABLE
MANNER DURING THE GAMES AND
BEYOND. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR,
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE, FOR
HAVING ME TODAY TO DISCUSS
METROLINK SERVICE IN THE
LAUSANNE CORRIDOR AND BEYOND,
AND I WILL LOOK FORWARD TO
TAKING YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. WELL, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH TO THE THREE OF
YOU. I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
INFORMATION. I'LL JUST ASK A
COUPLE OF PRELIMINARY QUESTIONS
AND THEN TURN IT TO MY
COLLEAGUES IF THEY HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. SO THE FIRST ONE HAS
TO DO WITH REALLY THE CORE OF
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE'S WORK, WHICH
IS TO HAVE THE RAIL CORRIDOR BE
MORE SUCCESSFUL AND THERE ARE
THERE ARE TRACK ISSUES AND THERE
ARE OPERATIONAL ISSUES. SO
BASICALLY THOSE TWO THINGS ARE
WHAT CREATE THE SUCCESS OF THIS
CORRIDOR. AND WE KNOW THAT IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA, THE
MODE SHARE FOR RAIL IS 1%. SO 1%
IS THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO TAKE
RAIL. AND CARB'S GOALS FOR THE
STATE ARE 14%. SO WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT GOAL SETTING, THE
STATE SETS THE VISION FOR THINGS
LIKE FREQUENCIES OF TRAINS AND
SEAMLESS OPERABILITY AND VARIOUS
HIGH LEVEL CONCEPTS, BUT THEY
LEAVE IT UP TO THE OPERATORS TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO OPERATIONALIZE
THAT. AND SO THE STATE RAIL PLAN
I'M I MY QUESTION IS HOW ARE YOU
OPERATIONALIZING THAT TO GO FROM
SOMETHING LIKE 1% TO SOMETHING
LIKE 14%? BECAUSE WHAT I, WHAT I
HEAR FROM THE GOAL SETTING
PROCESS IS THAT WE'RE NOT
STARTING WITH A BIG GOAL. AND
FIGURING OUT HOW TO GET THERE.
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS LOOKING AT
WHERE WE ARE AND SAYING, WELL,
WE'LL GET BACK TO PRE-PANDEMIC
LEVELS IN FIVE YEARS AFTER THE
PANDEMIC, OR MAYBE NEXT TIME OR
AND WE'RE LOOKING AT TRAIN
FREQUENCIES, BUT WE'RE NOT
LOOKING AT RIDERSHIP NUMBERS.
AND SO SAYING WE HAVE THIS
SLOWLY IMPROVING MARKET
CONDITIONS THAT ARE SHOWING US
THAT WE MIGHT BE HERE BY THIS
TIME IS REALLY NOT THE WAY TO
MEET A GOAL. SO MY QUESTION IS,
IN THE BIG PICTURE, YOU KNOW,
WHAT ARE WE DOING TO TRY TO MEET
THESE MUCH MORE AMBITIOUS GOALS,
TO SET THE GOAL FOR THE
INDEPENDENT, FOR THE AGENCIES
THEMSELVES, FOR THE LAUSANNE
CORRIDOR AS A WHOLE, AND THEN
TO, TO ACTUALLY WORK TOWARD
THAT. SO IF YOU COULD ADDRESS
THAT QUESTION AND I'LL ASK IT TO
ALL THREE OF YOU, I'D APPRECIATE
IT. WELL, I'LL GO AHEAD AND TAKE
THE FIRST STAB AT IT. I THINK WE
HAVE A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
FACTORS OUT THERE. THE MEMBERS
OF THIS PANEL HIT ON A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT ISSUES. I'VE ACTUALLY,
MADAM CHAIR, TRIED TO GET AWAY
FROM A CONVERSATION OF
PRE-PANDEMIC NUMBERS. I JUST
THINK WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT HOW
WE GROW RIDERSHIP IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND I LOOK AT OUR
OPPORTUNITY, I THINK RAIL
SYSTEMS MEET EVERY, EVERY
SERIOUS GOAL THAT THIS STATE HAS
HAD AS IT RELATES TO, ECONOMIC
PROSPERITY, PROSPERITY, VEHICLE.
MILES TRAVELED, EQUITY,
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS, IN
OUR SYSTEMS PROVIDE THAT AS AS I
ALLUDED TO IN MY REMARKS, WHAT
WE HEARD FROM OUR FROM PEOPLE
THAT MAY TAKE THE TRAIN IS WE
NEED SERVICE THAT MEETS OUR
NEEDS. AND CURRENTLY WE'RE NOT,
AND WE'RE TRYING TO WITH WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT UNDER
METROLINK REIMAGINED IS THAT
FIRST PHASE. WE PUT MORE TRAINS
OUT THERE THAT OPERATE ON, ON
SCHEDULES THAT ARE MORE
INTUITIVE, THAT PEOPLE CAN USE
AND TAKE THEM TO PLACES THEY
WANT TO GO. SO I THINK THAT'S A
BIG THAT'S A FIRST STEP. WE NEED
TO HAVE CAPACITY THAT OUR TRAINS
CAN OPERATE ON. WE'VE SHARED
WITH THIS COMMITTEE BEFORE OUR
SCORE PROGRAM, WHERE WE'RE
TRYING TO CREATE MORE TRACK
CAPACITY, AND THEN I THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE IT'S GOING TO BE
INCUMBENT ON RAIL AGENCIES
ACROSS THE BOARD TO HAVE FARE
STRUCTURES THAT WORK FOR PEOPLE
THEY KNOW HOW TO USE THEM. AND
WE DO THOSE THOSE THINGS. I
THINK THERE'S GOING TO BE AND I
WILL LEAVE WITH THIS THE NEXT
FOUR YEARS. AND I'VE SAID THIS
SEVERAL DIFFERENT TIMES. THERE
IS NO BETTER TIME FOR US TO HAVE
LASTING, TRANSFORMATIVE, A TRUE
LEGACY IN MOVING PEOPLE INTO
RAIL THAN A SUCCESS IN LÀ 28 AND
MOVING PEOPLE FOR THOSE GAMES
BECAUSE OF THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE GOING TO HAVE TO TAKE
PUBLIC TRANSIT, IT IS OUR TIME
TO SHINE AND WE HAVE TO PUT A
SERVICE OUT THERE THAT DOES
SHINE. AND I THINK IT WILL
COMPLETELY CHANGE THE LANDSCAPE
OF HOW SOUTHERN CALIFORNIANS
LOOK AT BEING ABLE TO USE PUBLIC
TRANSIT AND SPECIFICALLY RAIL.
YEAH. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
I'LL JUST BUILD OFF OF THOSE
COMMENTS. I WOULD SAY THAT, FOR
US SPECIFICALLY, WE DID VERY
MUCH THE SAME THING. WE LOOKED
AT OUR, OUR SERVICE THAT WE HAD
ON, ON THE RAIL WE TRIED TO FIND
AND WE DO THE SAME THING. WE
REALLY DON'T TALK ABOUT PRE
PANDEMIC, POST PANDEMIC. WHAT
WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO DO IS
FIND OUT WHAT THE NEW NORMAL IS
IN TERMS OF RIDERSHIP, PEAK AND
NON PEAK AND BUILD SERVICE THAT
EXISTS AROUND THAT FOR US
BECAUSE WE HAVE SO MANY USERS OF
THE LINE, WE'RE SORT OF TAPPED
OUT ON HOW WE CAN MOVE AROUND
SOME OF OUR SERVICES WITHOUT
GETTING SOME OF THESE OTHER
PROJECTS PUSHED FORWARD ON
DOUBLE TRACKING. SO IT PROVIDES
A LITTLE BIT OF RESILIENCY IN
THE CORRIDOR FOR US TO BE ABLE
TO ADD MORE SERVICES INTO,
REALLY, OUR SCHEDULE MAINLY ON
THE OFF PEAK SIDE, WE'RE SEEING
A HUGE IMPROVEMENT ON WEEKEND
SERVICE, SO THERE MAY BE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR US TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE MORE THERE. I THINK
PART OF IT IS YOU'RE STARTING TO
SEE A LOT MORE SPRAWL,
ESPECIALLY INTO AREAS I THINK,
BETWEEN SOUTHERN LOS ANGELES AND
SORT OF NORTH. THE ACTUAL
NORTHERN END OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY
FOR US. SO HOW DO WE SORT OF
SHORE UP SERVICE IN BETWEEN
ANAHEIM AND OCEANSIDE TRANSIT
CENTER FOR US, I THINK IS A BIG
PIECE OF WHERE WE SEE SOME
OPPORTUNITIES GOING INTO THE
FUTURE, HOW WE MANAGE THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS. I THINK EVERYBODY
SORT OF HAS COMPETING INTERESTS
IN TERMS OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT THEY NEED TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN. AND SO I THINK WE'VE
DONE A GOOD JOB HAVING THE
CONVERSATION. IT'S JUST HOW DO
WE GET TO A SPACE WHERE WE'RE
ABLE TO DO THOSE THINGS WITH THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE CURRENTLY
HAVE AND THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
WE NEED? AND I'M HOPING THAT WE
CAN GET TO A SPACE WHERE THAT'S,
NOT ONLY A PRIORITY, BUT WE'RE
ABLE TO FUND IT AS WELL. YEAH, I
THINK THE COMMENTS THAT I WANTED
TO MAKE ON THIS PARTICULAR TOPIC
INVOLVE THE CAPITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE, AS WELL AS
SPECIFICALLY THE FLEET AND THE
RESOURCES FOR AMTRAK PACIFIC
SURFLINER. AND AS YOU RECALL,
THAT SLIDE THAT I SHOWED WITH
THE MAP OF ALL THE CAPITAL
PROJECTS, AND SEAN HAD MENTIONED
A LOT OF THE CAPITAL INVESTMENTS
THAT NCTD IS LEADING, SUCH AS
THE DOUBLE TRACKING. I THINK
IT'S GOING TO BE REALLY KEY AS
WE WORK TOGETHER, ESPECIALLY IN
OUR REGIONAL STAKEHOLDER GROUPS
AND OUR ONGOING STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS THAT WE DO ON A REGULAR
BASIS TO REALLY FOCUS ON THE
CAPITAL PROJECTS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN THE PIPELINE AND
FOCUS ON GETTING WHAT IS GETTING
DONE, WHAT NEEDS TO GET DONE.
AND THE REASON THAT I SAY THAT
IS BECAUSE FOR AMTRAK PACIFIC
SURFLINER IN PARTICULAR, YOU
KNOW, WE DO HAVE PLANS UNDER THE
UMBRELLA OF THE STATE RAIL PLAN
TO EXPAND BEYOND OUR PRE-COVID
SERVICE LEVELS AND GO UP TO 14
AND 15 ROUND TRIP CAPACITY. BUT
WE NEED THESE CAPITAL PROJECTS
DONE TO DO THAT. SO WE NEED OUR
CENTRAL COAST LAYOVER FACILITY
BUILT ON THE NORTHERN END OF THE
CORRIDOR. WE NEED OUR ORTEGA
SIDING DONE. THOSE THOSE TYPES
OF SIDING PROJECTS, DOUBLE
TRACKING PROJECTS REALLY HELP US
GET THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S
NEEDED TO BE ABLE TO WORK
TOWARDS THAT. THAT LONG TERM
CAPACITY. AND FOR US IN
PARTICULAR, I MENTIONED THE
FLEET WE ARE CURRENTLY WORKING
WITH CALTRANS AND THE OTHER TWO
JPA ON A REGULAR BASIS FOR LONG
TERM FLEET PLANNING. THAT'S
GOING TO BE PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT FOR US AS WE LOOK TO,
YOU KNOW, GET ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES AS FAR AS TRAIN SETS
AVAILABLE FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT CAPACITY IN THE FUTURE.
RIGHT NOW, AS I MENTIONED, WE
ARE VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES THAT HAVE
BEEN PROVIDED FOR ALL THREE JPA
OVER THE NEXT THREE YEARS, BUT
WE ARE STRATEGICALLY FOCUSED ON,
YOU KNOW, HOW DO WE MAXIMIZE
THOSE RESOURCES WITH WHAT WE
HAVE WITHOUT PUTTING TOO MUCH
SERVICE OUT THERE AND THEN
HAVING A FISCAL CLIFF AT THE END
OF THREE YEARS? SO WE NEED TO
ALSO LOOK AT WAYS WE CAN WORK
TOWARDS HOW DO WE GET THAT
ONGOING. THOSE ONGOING FUNDING
RESOURCES AVAILABLE AND NOT JUST
FOR SHORT PERIODS OF TIME. SO WE
DON'T EXPAND TOO QUICKLY AND
THEN HAVE TO SHUT OFF SERVICE
WITHIN THREE YEARS. SO I THINK
THOSE RESOURCES ARE GOING TO BE
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT AS WE
LOOK TOWARDS, YOU KNOW, THE NEXT
2 TO 3 YEARS TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE THAT ONGOING FUNDING
CAPACITY AND RESOURCES AVAILABLE
TO US SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
PLAN FOR THOSE LONGER TERM
CAPACITY INCREASES, SO I THINK I
THINK THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS
ON THAT. MADAM CHAIR, COULD I
PROVIDE ONE QUICK FOLLOW UP? THE
OTHER ELEMENT, THOUGH, THAT
WE'VE JUST BRIEFLY TOUCHED ON,
IS THE FACT THAT WE HAVE OTHER
PARTNERS THAT AREN'T AT THIS
TABLE, AND IT'S THE CLASS ONE
FREIGHT RAILROADS. AND WE ALL
HAVE DIFFERENT AGREEMENTS WITH
THOSE WITH THOSE RAILROADS THAT
LIMIT OUR ABILITY TO ADD, IN
SOME CASES, TRAINS ABSENT NEW
CAPACITY. SO JUST AS ONE EXAMPLE
ON OUR THE LINE THAT GOES FROM
LOS ANGELES TO FULLERTON, WE
HAVE WE'RE WHAT WE CALL SLOT
CAPPED UNDER OUR SHARED USE
AGREEMENT WITH BNSF. WE CAN ONLY
PLAY SO MANY PASSENGER TRAINS ON
THAT LOCATION. SO IF WE WANT TO
GROW SERVICE AND I THINK WE DO,
WE ARE AND IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT BNSF CONTINUE TO
RUN FREIGHT TRAINS, YOU KNOW,
ARGUABLY MOVING FREIGHT THE MOST
EFFICIENTLY IS BY RAIL. SO WE DO
THAT'S WHERE SOME OF THESE OTHER
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT CAPACITY
GOES IS IT'S FOR US. BUT IT ALSO
WORKING WITH THE FREIGHT
RAILROADS CREATES CAPACITY BOTH
FOR THEIR OPERATIONS AS WELL AS
OURS, WHICH ALLOWS US TO GROW
OUR SERVICE. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU. YEAH, I
APPRECIATE THAT. AND I THAT'S A
GOOD SEGUE INTO MY SECOND
QUESTION, BUT I'LL JUST CONCLUDE
THAT FIRST PART WITH SAYING I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE MORE AMBITIOUS
GOAL SETTING AROUND RIDERSHIP.
SO THAT SO THAT WE'RE PUTTING IT
OUT THERE WHERE WE WANT TO GO
AND THEN ALSO YOU WOULD BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE TO US WHAT YOU NEED
TO GET THERE. SO I FEEL LIKE
THAT'S ALL PART OF THE
SUCCESSFUL PLANNING PROCESS. MY
SECOND POINT IS ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY AND BUILDING PUBLIC
TRUST. SO IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
I THINK, THAT WE SPEAK HONESTLY
ABOUT WHAT IS HAPPENING IN THE
CORRIDOR, INCLUDING HOW MUCH
FREIGHT IS BEING CARRIED ON THIS
LINE AND WHEN AND HOW, AS WELL
AS THE MOVEMENT OF FLAMMABLE AND
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS. THERE WAS
JUST AN ARTICLE IN THE UNION
TRIBUNE ABOUT THINGS THAT NEED
TO LEAVE SAN ONOFRE AND HOW
THEY'RE TRAVELING ON RAIL
SAFELY, BUT BUT THE REALITY OF
TONNAGE CARRIED PASSENGER
MOVEMENTS SCHEDULING. YOU KNOW,
THIS IS NOT INFORMATION THAT WE
CAN EASILY ACCESS. WE AS
LEGISLATORS AND MY TEAM, WE HAVE
TO FILE A PUBLIC RECORDS REQUEST
IN ORDER TO GET INFORMATION THAT
SHOULD BE AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC. AND I THINK WHEN WE'RE
HAVING THESE REALLY HOT SPOT
PROBLEMS, LIKE IN SAN CLEMENTE
OR IN DEL MAR, AND THERE IS
DISCUSSION OF MOVING THE RAIL
LINE, THERE IS A SUBGROUP OF
PEOPLE THAT SAYS THIS RAIL LINE
IS NOT IMPORTANT. AND SO IF
WE'RE TRYING TO SAY THERE'S A
BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF GOODS
THAT'S CARRIED ON THIS LINE, WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO BACK THAT UP
WITH THE DATA, AND WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO SHOW PEOPLE WHAT IS
HAPPENING ON THIS LINE. THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT. WE ALSO
FREQUENTLY TALK ABOUT THIS BEING
THE SECOND BUSIEST RAIL LINE IN
THE NATION. YOU KNOW, THAT KIND
OF DATA. WE JUST WE IN REAL
TIME, WE SHOULD BE SHOWING
PEOPLE WHAT'S HAPPENING. BUT WE
ALSO JUST IN GENERAL NEED TO
HAVE A MUCH MORE TRANSPARENT
DATA APPROACH SO THAT WE CAN
BUILD CONFIDENCE AND SHOW THE
VALUE OF THIS LINE. AND IT'S
ALSO IT WOULD ALLOW US TO REALLY
SEE HONESTLY WHERE WE CAN MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS AND WHERE WE NEED
TO BE NEGOTIATING ADDITIONAL
SLOTS AND THESE VARIOUS THINGS
THAT GO TO THE CORE OF YOUR
OPERATIONAL OPERATION OF BEING
ABLE TO OPERATE IT EFFECTIVELY.
SO I'D LIKE TO KNOW, YOU KNOW,
THIS IS IN SOME WAYS MAYBE MORE
OF A LOW SAND QUESTION, BECAUSE
LOW SAND OVERSEES ALL OF THE
AGENCIES THAT OPERATE ON THE
CORRIDOR. SO MAYBE MR. JEWELL,
YOU COULD ANSWER THIS, BUT BUT I
REALLY WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WHAT
IS THE PLAN TO PROVIDE MORE
TRANSPARENT INFORMATION AND
INCLUDING FROM THE FREIGHT, THE
FREIGHT COMPANIES THAT OPERATE
ON THE LINE? YEAH. AND AS I
MENTIONED, DURING MY DISCUSSION,
WE AS AN AGENCY ARE WORKING
TOWARDS INTERNALLY AS A TEAM,
WORKING TOWARDS PROVIDING MORE
TRANSPARENT DATA ON OUR
RIDERSHIP, ON TIME PERFORMANCE,
CORRIDOR TRENDS, SAFETY, SYSTEM
SAFETY AND INCIDENT DATA TO MAKE
IT MORE READILY AVAILABLE ON OUR
WEBSITE. ALTHOUGH THESE ARE ALL
PUBLIC DOCUMENTS THAT GO THROUGH
OUR BOARD OF DIRECTORS AND
THEY'RE ON OUR AGENDAS, IT'S
OBVIOUSLY HARD FOR THE PUBLIC TO
DIG AROUND AND TRY TO FIND THAT
INFORMATION. SO WE DO WANT TO
MAKE THAT MORE READILY AVAILABLE
AND HAVE THAT INFORMATION, YOU
KNOW, AND PORTRAYED IN A WAY
THAT IS UNDERSTANDABLE AND
SUCCINCT AND, AND, AND EASILY
ACCESSIBLE. SO WE ARE WORKING
TOWARDS THAT, AS REGARDS TO THE
FREIGHT INFORMATION, YOU KNOW,
THAT HAS ALWAYS BEEN A, YOU
KNOW, INFORMATION THAT I THINK
THE FREIGHT HOLD DEAR TO THEM.
YOU KNOW, THEY ARE PRIVATELY
HELD COMPANIES, SO THEY DO NOT
HAVE TO PROVIDE A LOT OF THAT
INFORMATION THAT THEY FEEL IS
CONFIDENTIAL, AND SO THAT DOES
OFTENTIMES, YOU KNOW, GETS US
INTO A SPACE WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TRANSPARENCY IS, YOU KNOW,
HOW DO WE ACCURATELY, ACCURATELY
BE ABLE TO ATTAIN AND PROVIDE
THAT INFORMATION? AND, AND WE,
YOU KNOW, WE ACTUALLY THROUGH
OUR OPERATING AGREEMENT WITH
AMTRAK. AMTRAK HAS AGREEMENTS
WITH THE WITH THE FREIGHT
OPERATORS FOR ACCESS RIGHTS.
AND, PAYS THE FEES TO THOSE TO
THOSE FREIGHT ENTITIES DIRECTLY,
WE WERE SUCCESSFUL, THROUGH OUR
AGENCY IN GETTING A AGREEMENT
WITH UNION PACIFIC FOR
CAPITALIZED MAINTENANCE AND ON
TIME PERFORMANCE ACCESS, REALLY
KIND OF THE FIRST AGREEMENT OF
ITS KIND, TO BE DONE FOR OUR
AGENCY, WHICH ALLOWS US TO PAY
UNION PACIFIC DIRECTLY AND WORK
WITH THEM ON REALLY PROVIDING, A
ON TIME PERFORMANCE INITIATIVE,
AND AS WELL AS CAPITALIZED
MAINTENANCE OF THE NORTHERN END
OF OUR, OF OUR CORRIDOR, THAT
REALLY ALLOWS US TO KEEP THE
CORRIDOR ON THE NORTHERN END IN
A TRULY STATE OF GOOD REPAIR, AS
PART OF THAT AGREEMENT, YOU
KNOW, WE HAVE INVESTED
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS WITH
UNION PACIFIC THAT HAVE BEEN
COMPLETED ON THE NORTHERN END OF
THE NORTHERN END OF OUR CORRIDOR
THAT REALLY HAVE HELPED INCREASE
AGING INFRASTRUCTURE AND HAVE
REALLY HELPED US BE ABLE TO
ACHIEVE A LITTLE BIT HIGHER
PERFORMANCE ON THAT END OF THE
CORRIDOR, BUT AGAIN, AS FAR AS
THE DATA AND INFORMATION RELATED
TO FREIGHT, THAT IS, YOU KNOW,
KIND OF A CONTINUAL DISCUSSION
AS FAR AS WHAT IS WHAT IS
CONFIDENTIAL AND, AND WHAT IS
ABLE TO BE PROVIDED AND, AND
PUBLIC INFORMATION, AND THAT'S
SOMETHING WE'LL CONTINUE
CONTINUE TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS
WITH THEM ON TO TRY TO FIGURE
OUT THE BEST WAY TO, YOU KNOW,
TO DEAL WITH THAT, I'M NOT SURE
IF SEAN OR DARREN HAVE SOME HAVE
SOME THOUGHTS ON THAT, IF I
COULD, MADAM CHAIR. SO THE FACT
OF THE MATTER IS, IS NCTD IS, IS
A RAILROAD OF RECORD. METROLINK
IS A RAILROAD OF RECORD. AND
THIS IS NOT ANYTHING ON LAUSANNE.
LAUSANNE OPERATES ON NCTD
TRACKS. THEY OPERATE ON OUR
TRACKS. THEY OPERATE ON UNION
PACIFIC TRACKS, SO WE'RE THE
ARRANGEMENTS WITH THOSE FREIGHT
RAILROADS. IF WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE DATA, WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
DATA BECAUSE WE'RE THE OPERATING
RAILROAD THAT WOULD HAVE ANY OF
THAT INFORMATION REGARDING SOME
OF THE QUESTIONS REGARDING
TRANSPARENCY NOW, BUT BUT I
THINK THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
CRITICAL ELEMENTS OF THIS. AND
TRANSPARENCY IS AND I'M A HUGE
BELIEVER IN IT, I SUSPECT, GIVEN
THE NATURE OF THIS CORRIDOR, WE
MAY HAVE NATIONAL DEFENSE ISSUES
THAT MIGHT BE OF CONCERN GIVEN
WHAT MAY BE BEING HAULED BY
TRAIN, AS WELL AS PROPRIETARY
ELEMENTS THAT THE FREIGHT
RAILROADS MAY HAVE THAT THEY
WOULD PROTECT BECAUSE OF
WHATEVER IT IS THEY'RE HAULING.
SO THERE, MR. JEWELL MENTIONED
THE FACT THAT THEY HOLD THAT
DATA VERY CLOSE TO THE VEST. I'M
NOT ANTICIPATING THIS QUESTION,
MADAM CHAIR. I HAVEN'T DONE THE
HOMEWORK ON HOW WE HANDLE THAT
AND WORKING WITH MAYBE HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS, THOSE TYPES OF
QUESTIONS, WHICH I THINK WAS
PART OF YOUR QUESTION. HAPPY TO
GET BACK TO YOU WITH MORE
INFORMATION ALONG THOSE LINES.
BUT I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT LAUSANNE, THE
SURFLINER IS AN OPERATING
RAILROAD ON MULTIPLE, ON
MULTIPLE RAILROADS OF RECORD
AND, AND, AND, YOU KNOW, WE
APPRECIATE THAT PARTNERSHIP. BUT
WHEN IT WHEN PUSH COMES TO
SHOVE, IT'S THE NCDS OR THE
SCRAS OF THE WORLD WHOSE JOB IT
IS TO RUN THOSE RAILROADS,
DISPATCH, OPERATE, MAINTAIN AND
SO ON. SO, NOT TO SPEAK FOR YOU,
SEAN, BUT I THOUGHT I MIGHT
COVER AT LEAST A LITTLE BIT OF
IT NOW, AND I APPRECIATE THAT
QUESTION, MADAM CHAIR. I WOULD
DEFINITELY AGREE WITH WHAT WAS
SAID. I THINK FOR US,
TRANSPARENCY IS THE KEY. IN
FACT, I THINK IF WE HAD OUR
PREFERENCE, THERE WOULD BE AN
OPEN DASHBOARD TO THE PUBLIC TO
SORT OF SORT OF SHOW THE
DIFFERENCES OF HOW MANY TRIPS WE
RAN A DAY ON AMTRAK, HOW MANY
FREIGHT RUNS WE DID AT NIGHT,
HOW MANY COASTER RUNS WE DID FOR
NCTD, HOW MANY RUNS. PROBABLY
COULDN'T SAY HOW MANY MILITARY
RUNS, BUT I THINK THAT'S ALL
IMPORTANT INFORMATION AND JUST
SORT OF COMES DOWN TO THE
AGREEMENTS THAT WE HAVE WITH THE
CARRIERS AND WHAT THEY ARE
ACTUALLY CARRYING AND WHAT THEIR
AGREEMENTS ARE. THROUGH SOME OF
THOSE THINGS I THINK
TRANSPARENCY FROM A 50,000 FOOT
LEVEL OF THIS IS HOW THE LINE IS
OPERATING FROM A DAY TO DAY
BASIS. IT'S PROBABLY INFORMATION
THAT COULD BE COORDINATED AND
PUT OUT THERE PRETTY QUICKLY
FROM A BUSINESS INTELLIGENCE
STANDPOINT. I THINK WHEN WE
START TO GET INTO THE MINUTIA A
LITTLE BIT, THERE MAY BE SOME
PROPRIETARY ISSUES THAT WE'RE
NOT ALLOWED TO SHARE OR NATIONAL
SECURITY ISSUES THAT WE CANNOT
SHARE WITH THE PUBLIC. YEAH. AND
I JUST LOOKED TO CALTRANS, AS WE
HAVE IN DEPTH LEVELS OF
REPORTING ON WHAT IS ON OUR
HIGHWAYS. AND I MEAN, YOU KNOW,
THERE ARE, OF COURSE, PRIVACY
CONCERNS AND NATIONAL SECURITY
CONCERNS AND BUT BUT IT SEEMS
LIKE WE WOULD STILL BE ABLE TO
AGGREGATE THE DATA AND MAKE IT
TRANSPARENT IN A WAY THAT WE'RE
NOT CURRENTLY DOING. AND I
APPRECIATE THE POINT THAT THIS
ISN'T LIKE A CALTRANS HIGHWAY
NETWORK, BECAUSE THERE ARE THESE
MANAGING OWNERS AND OPERATORS
THAT ARE NOT THE STATE BASICALLY.
AND CALTRANS OF COURSE, IS THE
STATE. BUT BUT YOU'RE
INDEPENDENT. SO BUT THERE IS
THIS COLLABORATIVE WORKING
ARRANGEMENT AND WE HAVE THE
SYSTEM WE HAVE ON THIS RAIL
CORRIDOR. SO MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE ABLE TO HAVE THE
INFORMATION WE NEED TO BOTH
PROVE THE VALUE OF THE CORRIDOR
AND ALSO MAKE IT MORE CLEAR
WHERE THE OPPORTUNITIES ARE FOR
IMPROVEMENT. I JUST THINK THAT
THAT IS REALLY IN THE PUBLIC'S
BEST INTEREST IN EVERY WAY. SO
AND I DON'T WE'RE JUST CLEARLY
NOT DOING THAT RIGHT NOW. SO, SO
I THINK I DO THINK THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT. AND THEN MY THIRD
QUESTION IS, RELATED TO AND WE
HAVE ONE MEMBER HERE WHO'S VERY
INTERESTED IN HYDROGEN. SO I'LL
JUST PREVIEW THAT. THAT'S WHERE
I'M GOING HERE. SO IT'S HOW
QUICKLY ARE WE MOVING TO ZERO
EMISSION TECHNOLOGY. SO YOU
KNOW, THE I APPRECIATE METROLINK
LEANING IN. SO MUCH TO BUYING
NEW NEW LOCOMOTIVES THAT YOU
NEED TO BEAT A DEADLINE. BUT
BASICALLY WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS
INVESTING IN DIRTY TECHNOLOGY
THAT WILL BE AROUND TILL 2060.
AND NOT INVESTING IN HYDROGEN OR
IN CATENARY OR SOME OF THE OTHER
THINGS. AND SO, YOU KNOW,
CATENARY, WHICH IS OVERHEAD
ELECTRIFICATION OF A RAIL LINE.
WE SEE THAT IT JUST, YOU KNOW,
WAS ANNOUNCED OPEN FOR CALTRAIN.
WE ALSO HAVE IT ON HIGH SPEED
RAIL AND ON BRIGHT LINE. AND
THERE'S NO DISCUSSION OF IT ON
THE LO SAN RAIL CORRIDOR THAT
I'VE HEARD ABOUT. BUT, YOU KNOW,
AND I KNOW THERE ARE DISPUTES
WITH FREIGHT AND THERE ARE OTHER
PLACES IN THE WORLD WHERE THEY
DO HAVE BOTH RUNNING ON THE SAME
TRACKS. FREIGHT AND CATENARY.
AND INVESTING IN DIESEL
LOCOMOTIVES. REALLY IS THAT
LEGACY EQUIPMENT. AND I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE LEANING INTO
AND I AND WE HAVE MANDATES, YOU
KNOW, WE NEED TO BE MOVING TO
ZERO EMISSION TECHNOLOGY ON OUR
RAIL AS WELL. SO I WANT TO ASK
BROADLY ABOUT HOW WHAT WHAT IS
THE THOUGHT PROCESS AROUND THAT?
I MEAN, YOU SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN ALL THE RAIL AND THE REST OF
THE STATE HERE. SO WHAT ARE WE
THINKING WE'RE DOING ON THIS
RAIL LINE WHEN IT COMES TO ZERO
EMISSION TECHNOLOGY? YEAH. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. I WOULD SAY,
YOU KNOW, WE'RE ALL IN ON ZERO
EMISSION. THE BIGGEST PROBLEM
THAT I THINK WE'VE HAD AND I'VE
HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH THIS IN
PREVIOUS JOBS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION IS
THERE'S VERY LITTLE COORDINATION
BETWEEN THOSE THREE DEPARTMENTS
ABOUT HOW TO MANAGE THAT ENERGY
EXPECTATION. AND I THINK I CAN
SPEAK FROM A CALIFORNIA
PERSPECTIVE THAT WE SORT OF
JUMPED ALL IN ON HYDROGEN. AND
THE REALITY IS, IS THERE'S VERY
LITTLE HYDROGEN PROCESSING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND WE
HAVE ONE TRAIN THAT'S IN A TEST
PHASE, RIGHT NOW ON THE HYDROGEN
FRONT. SO FOR US TO REALLY MAKE
THAT LEAP BY 2035 WAS SORT OF AN
UNKNOWN PIECE OF EQUIPMENT IS
DIFFICULT FOR US TO FINANCIALLY
SORT OF MANAGE AND GET BEHIND IN
REAL TIME. I DON'T THINK IT'S A
SITUATION WHERE THE AGENCIES
DON'T WANT TO GET BEHIND THAT
TECHNOLOGY. I THINK IT'S A
MATTER OF IT'S SIGNIFICANTLY
SHIFTS THE MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATING COST OF THE FACILITY.
IF IT'S A WHOLESALE CHANGE FROM
A DIESEL FACILITY TO A CATENARY
OR TO A HYDROGEN. YES, THE
CATENARY IS THERE DOES AN
EXCELLENT JOB, THERE ARE JUST
SOME SPACES ALONG THE CORRIDOR
WHERE THAT IS NOT, FEASIBLE FOR
US TO RUN OVERHEAD CATENARY.
WE'VE LOOKED AT OPTIONS SUCH AS,
SORT OF A HYBRID ELECTRIC WHERE
THERE'S BATTERY STORAGE AND THAT
IT RUNS INDEPENDENT ON SOME
PORTIONS OF THE LINE. AND LONG
TERM, IF WE WANT TO TAKE SERVICE
ALL THE WAY TO ANAHEIM OR HAVE
SOME TYPE OF A SORT OF A BACK
AND FORTH BETWEEN METROLINK AND
NCTD ON INCREASING FREQUENCY
ALONG THAT PORTION OF THE
CORRIDOR THAT DOES CREATE SOME
CHALLENGES FOR US, ESPECIALLY
THROUGH CERTAIN PARTS OF ORANGE
COUNTY. I THINK, YOU KNOW, FROM
THE BEST EXAMPLE I CAN GIVE YOU
FROM THE HYDROGEN PERSPECTIVE IS
WE HAVE HYDROGEN BUSSES SITTING
IN OUR LOT RIGHT NOW THAT WE'VE
HAD FOR MONTHS THAT WE CAN'T PUT
INTO SERVICE, BECAUSE TO HAVE
HYDROGEN TRUCKED INTO OUR
FACILITY IS ABOUT $70 A
KILOGRAM. AND TO GET IT IN
LIQUID FORM AT A BASE IS
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN 5 AND $7,
DEPENDING ON THE DAY. SO WE HAD
TO MAKE THE BUSINESS DECISION
THAT IT WASN'T WORTH THE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS JUST TO HAVE
HYDROGEN TRUCKED IN FOR THE 15
TO 20 BUSSES WE HAVE ON OUR LOT.
AND I THINK WE'RE A LITTLE
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT THAT MEANS.
LONG TERM. FROM A TRAIN
PERSPECTIVE. YOU KNOW, FEELING A
HYDROGEN TRAIN IS A LOT
DIFFERENT THAN FUELING A DIESEL
TRAIN. AND IT REQUIRES SOME VERY
SPECIALTY MECHANICAL WORK AND
THINGS THAT WOULD TAKE SEVERAL
YEARS FOR US TO MANAGE AND PUT
TOGETHER FROM A FACILITY
PERSPECTIVE, YOU KNOW, I SAY ALL
THAT TO SAY THAT, YES, IT IS
DIFFICULT, BUT I THINK THERE'S
100% AGREEMENT FROM THE AGENCIES
THAT WE WANT TO MOVE THAT
DIRECTION. WE JUST NEED THE
TECHNOLOGY AND THE AVAILABLE
FUEL RESOURCES TO CATCH UP TO US
SO THAT WE CAN PUT THAT IN FRONT
OF OUR BOARDS AND MAKE THE
DECISION TO MOVE INTO THOSE
TYPES OF EQUIPMENT. THANK YOU,
MR. KETTLE. AND WHEN I, WHEN I,
WHEN I WAS TALKING ABOUT
METROLINK ADOPTING ITS CLIMATE
ACTION PLAN BACK IN 2021, IT
INCLUDES AN ELEMENT OF MOVING TO
ZERO EMISSION. AND OF COURSE, AS
MR. DONAGHY WAS MENTIONING, WE
HAVE EXACTLY ONE HYDROGEN FUEL
CELL LOCOMOTIVE, PIECE OF
EQUIPMENT IN THE UNITED STATES
RIGHT NOW, AND IT'S IN THE
METROLINK SERVICE AREA. IT'S NOT
YET IN OPERATION, BUT IT WILL BE
IN THE NOT TOO DISTANT FUTURE.
WE DON'T HAVE A TIMELINE YET, SO
WE SEE THAT AS AN AS AN
OPPORTUNITY, NO DOUBT, METROLINK
HAS ALSO BEEN THE RECIPIENT OF I
BELIEVE IT'S ABOUT AN $80
MILLION GRANT FROM THE SOUTH
COAST AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT THROUGH CARB TO EXPLORE
ZERO EMISSION, PUSH PULL
LOCOMOTIVE TECHNOLOGY. SO LIKE
THE LOCOMOTIVES WE OPERATE
TODAY, THE FACT OF THE MATTER
IS, IS THAT RIGHT NOW, THE
TECHNOLOGY FLAT OUT DOESN'T
EXIST. SO WE'RE GOING TO THE
INDUSTRY AND WE'RE ACTUALLY
BEING, FUEL PATH AGNOSTIC,
WHETHER IT'S BATTERY ELECTRIC OR
WHETHER IT'S HYDROGEN ABOUT
INDUSTRY. TELL US WHAT WE CAN
MAKE WORK IN OUR SYSTEM, AND SO
THAT IS OUR PLAN WE ARE STILL
LOOKING FOR I MENTIONED THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING WE NEED FOR
THE TIER FOUR AS WELL. I NEED
PROBABLY DOUBLE THAT 80 MILLION
TO FULLY EXPLORE TWO TENDER TYPE
VEHICLES THAT WOULD FOLLOW, THAT
WOULD FOLLOW A LOCOMOTIVE THAT
WOULD PROVIDE THAT ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGY, WHETHER IT'S BATTERY
OR BATTERY OR HYDROGEN BATTERY,
THAT WE COULD DO. SO WE'RE IN
THAT. WE ABSOLUTELY WANT TO GO
THAT WAY. I THINK THE CHALLENGE,
OF COURSE, IS THAT THE
MANUFACTURING SECTOR IS SIMPLY
NOT THERE. AND EVEN WITH THE,
THE VEHICLE THAT WE'RE GOING TO
BE OPERATING LATER THIS YEAR OR
EARLY NEXT IS GOING TO BE IT IS
A PILOT. IT'S RECOGNIZED AS A
PILOT. WE'VE HAD ONE OTHER
HYDROGEN VEHICLE OPERATE IN THE
NORTH AMERICA, AND IT WAS NOT A
SUCCESS IN CANADA ABOUT A YEAR
AGO. SO AND IS NOW OUT OF
SERVICE. SO WE ARE ALL LEARNING
IN THIS. BUT IN THE MEANTIME WE
HAVE A RAILROAD SYSTEM TO RUN TO
MOVE PASSENGERS. AND WE HAD
VERY, VERY DIRTY, VERY DIRTY
LOCOMOTIVES THAT WERE HAULING
THOSE. AND SO I GUESS IT MAYBE
FALLS UNDER THE CATEGORY OF NO
GOOD DEED GOES UNPUNISHED. WE
DID EVERYTHING WE CAN TO GET TO
THE CLEANEST BURNING LOCOMOTIVES
THAT OPERATE ON RENEWABLE FUEL,
NOT PETROLEUM DIESEL, BUT
RENEWABLE DIESEL. DOING OUR PART
TO TRY TO MEET ALL OF THE
CONDITIONS IN CALIFORNIA. WE
THINK WE'VE BEEN PRETTY
SUCCESSFUL, BUT CAN WE BE
BETTER? SURE. BUT WE NEED THE
TECHNOLOGY TO BE THERE. OKAY.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO SAY ANYTHING,
MR. JOEL? SURE. I'LL MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS AND I'M SURE KYLE
GRADINGER ON THE SECOND PANEL
WILL PROBABLY TALK TO THIS TOPIC
AS WELL, BECAUSE THE STATE IS
THE LEAD IN TAKING THE LEAD ON
THE FUTURE OF OUR EQUIPMENT FOR
THE RAIL FLEET FOR PACIFIC
SURFLINER IN THE FUTURE. THE
STATE OWNS OUR RAILCARS THAT WE
UTILIZE FOR THE SURFLINER, AND
SO WE DO COORDINATE WITH THEM.
AND LIKE I MENTIONED ON ON FLEET
PLANNING, HOWEVER, THERE IS AN
AGREEMENT, I BELIEVE, BETWEEN US
AND THE JPA AND CALTRANS FOR A
VERY LONGER TERM, YOU KNOW,
FLEET PLANNING STRATEGY AND
NEED, CURRENTLY THE STATE, IS
MOVING FORWARD WITH ZERO
EMISSION TECHNOLOGY, BUT IS
GOING TO BE UTILIZING ITS PLAN
TO BE UTILIZING, UTILIZED ON ONE
OF OUR NORTHERN JPA CORRIDORS TO
PILOT THAT OUT. AND WE HAVE HAD
DISCUSSIONS WITH THEM ON THE
POTENTIAL FOR PILING UP, PILING
ONE OF THOSE, SETS ON OUR LINE
JUST DEPENDING ON WHAT, YOU
KNOW, WHAT PORTIONS OF OUR
CORRIDOR WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
UTILIZE IT IN. HOWEVER, THERE'S
ALSO SOME CURRENTLY CAPACITY
CONSTRAINTS WITH THAT TYPE OF
EQUIPMENT. I THINK THOSE THOSE
PARTICULAR PIECES OF EQUIPMENT
TYPICALLY HOUSE BETWEEN 2 TO 300
SEATING CAPACITY. YOU KNOW,
WHERE OUR NEEDS ARE UPWARDS IN
THE 480 RANGE, AND THEN ALSO
JUST DESIGNING THE CURRENT
EQUIPMENT FOR THE AMENITIES THAT
OUR CUSTOMERS ARE USED TO,
INCLUDING CAFE CAR, YOU KNOW,
WI-FI, THOSE TYPES OF THINGS.
NOT TO SAY THAT IT CAN'T BE
DONE, BUT WE DO HAVE TO EXPLORE
ALL OF THOSE POSSIBILITIES. SO I
JUST WANTED TO MENTION A COUPLE
OF THOSE POINTS. AND AGAIN, WE
DO LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE STATE KIND OF ON THE LONG
TERM STRATEGIC VISION AND PLAN
FOR FLEET PLANNING, MOVING,
MOVING INTO THE FUTURE. AND
AGAIN, I'M SURE KYLE GRADINGER
WILL PROBABLY PROVIDE SOME SOME
COMMENTS ON ON THE NEXT
GENERATION ZERO EMISSION
EQUIPMENT PLANS FOR CALIFORNIA.
YES. THANK YOU. I KNOW IT MIGHT
BE. REALLY IT'S CALTRANS THAT
SHOULD ANSWER THE QUESTION ABOUT
WHETHER CATENARY IS BEING
EVALUATED OR NOT, BUT I DIDN'T
HEAR A LOT OF ANSWER ON THAT
PART. BUT IT SOUNDS LIKE NOT NOT
A LOT. I'D LIKE TO TURN TO MY
COLLEAGUES. DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS? YES, YES. GO AHEAD,
MR. ARCHULETA. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR, FOR BRINGING
US TOGETHER. AND AS YOU CAN SEE,
WE HAVE TO GO IN AND OUT IN AND
OUT. SO MY COLLEAGUES RUNNING IN
AND RUNNING OUT BECAUSE OF OUR
SCHEDULES AND SO ON, BUT I'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE, OBVIOUSLY, IN MY DISTRICT,
I HAVE ORANGE COUNTY, L.A.
COUNTY. AND SO I, THE OTHERS
THAT WERE HERE HAVE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY, ORANGE COUNTY, BUT I RUN
INTO L.A, SO, AND I'M GOING TO
KIND OF GO BACK A LITTLE BIT,
BUT I'M IMPRESSED WITH THE
RIDERSHIP THERE OUT OF, RIGHT,
RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF MY
DISTRICT, NORWALK, SANTA FE
SPRINGS, THAT RIDERSHIP IS UP TO
94,900. THAT'S IMPRESSIVE, I WAS
THERE, JUST RECENTLY AS, THERE
AT THE SITE, THEY'RE CUTTING
SOME RIBBONS AND EXPANDING AND
DOING SOME OTHER THINGS. SO
WE'RE ALL LOOKING FORWARD TO,
THE OLYMPICS DOWN THE ROAD, DOWN
THE TRACK AND I'M REALLY
IMPRESSED ABOUT YOUR
PRESENTATION ON HYDROGEN,
BECAUSE YOU'RE. WELL AWARE THAT
WE'RE ALL TRYING TO FIND,
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO CLEAN
OUR AIR AND OUR ENVIRONMENT AND
SO ON, AND WE'RE UNDER THE
CLOCK. WE'RE UNDER THE CALENDAR.
2028 IS GOING TO BE HERE BEFORE
WE KNOW IT, BUT I KNOW YOU
UNDERSTAND THE PROBLEMS, AND I
KNOW THAT FROM MY TRAVELS TO
JAPAN, AND I'VE SEEN THEIR
HYDROGEN TRAINS A COUPLE OF
TIMES THAT I'VE BEEN THERE. SO
THEY'RE REALLY AHEAD OF US WHEN
IT COMES TO THEIR SIDE OF
HYDROGEN. AND THEIR
TRANSPORTATION. BUT I THINK
WE'RE I THINK WE'RE ON THE, ON
THE RADAR. WE'RE WE'RE COMING IN
THAT DIRECTION. AND MAYBE A
LITTLE LATE FOR SOME TOO SOON
FOR OTHERS, BUT IT'S DEFINITELY
ON OUR RADAR. IT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN. I GAVE A SPEECH TODAY
TO, A GOOD NUMBER OF EDUCATORS,
OVER 700 EDUCATORS, AND I'VE
TOLD THEM THE FUTURE IS
HYDROGEN. IT IS COMING. YOU
EDUCATORS NEED TO START
PREPARING OUR YOUNG MEN AND
WOMEN FOR THAT TECHNOLOGY. IT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN. AND I THINK THE
HUB AND ARCHES THAT YOU NEED TO
PARTNER WITH TO GO AHEAD AND
GRANT, SOME OF THE FUNDING
YOU'RE GOING TO NEED FOR THE
FUTURE. FUEL CELL, BATTERY
TRANSPORTATION, FUEL CELL
BATTERIES. IT'S GOT TO HAPPEN.
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT. WE'VE GOT TO
PRODUCE IT. WE'VE GOT TO
TRANSPORT IT. YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE
IT READILY AVAILABLE TO YOU. AND
IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
CORRIDOR THAT GOES FROM SAN
DIEGO TO LOS ANGELES AND BEYOND,
WELL THEN THAT'S DEFINITELY THE
FUTURE. BUT I'D LIKE TO THANK
YOU FOR WHAT YOU'RE DOING NOW,
BECAUSE COMING BEFORE US SAYS A
LOT JUST IN ITSELF. YOU'RE VERY
WELL AWARE OF WHAT THIS
COMMITTEE IS ALL ABOUT, PUBLIC
SAFETY. I THINK THAT'S NUMBER
ONE. AND OUR CHAIR HAS EXPRESSED
IT TIME AND TIME AGAIN. PUBLIC
SAFETY. AND THEN, OF COURSE, AS
WE GO INTO RIDERSHIP, THE
IMPORTANCE OF MOVING PEOPLE THAT
WANT TO SEE THE BEAUTIFUL
COASTLINE IN SAN DIEGO GO TO
VARIOUS PARTS. AND NOW WE'RE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND GO INTO
LOS ANGELES WITH THE OLYMPICS.
SO WE'RE TALKING MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE. YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
3 MILLION PEOPLE. HOW DO WE MOVE
THEM? HOW DO WE GET THEM THERE?
SO IT'S GOING TO BE A JOB FOR
ALL OF US WORKING TOGETHER. SO I
THINK THIS MEETING THAT WE'RE
HAVING TODAY, OPENED SOME DOORS
FOR ALL OF US TO COME TOGETHER,
BECAUSE WHETHER WE'RE TALKING
THE CENTRAL PORT PORTION OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, WHICH OUR
COLLEAGUES JUST WALKED IN, THAT
REPRESENTS THE WAY DOWN IN THAT
BEAUTIFUL AREA OF SAN DIEGO OR
RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF THE HUB
OF LOS ANGELES, L.A. COUNTY,
THAT I DO. BUT WE'RE ALL GOING
TO HAVE TO WORK TOGETHER. WE
HAVE TO FIND A WAY OF GETTING
PEOPLE FROM POINT A TO POINT B
EFFICIENTLY, SAFELY, AND SO ON.
SO LET ME JUST FINISH UP WITH MY
COMMENTS THAT ALL THREE OF YOU
SEEM TO MENTION, AND THAT IS
VANDALISM THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO SEEMS TO ME THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO BEEF UP YOUR
SECURITY, BECAUSE IF AN ENTIRE
SYSTEM IS SHUT DOWN BECAUSE OF
THE REMOVAL OF COPPER LINES AND
SO ON, BECAUSE OF VANDALISM,
THINK OF THE RIDERSHIP THAT
SUFFERS. SO I THINK YOU NEED TO
TAKE RIGHT NOW, RIGHT NOW YOU
HAVE TO TAKE A GOOD LOOK AT YOUR
INVESTMENT WHEN IT COMES TO
SECURITY AND WORKING WITH THE
MUNICIPALITIES, WORKING WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, WORKING WITH
THE STATE, WE NEED TO TAKE CARE
OF YOU SO YOU CAN TAKE CARE OF
US. SO I THINK YOU NEED TO COME
UP WITH A PLAN THAT WILL UPLIFT
YOUR PUBLIC SAFETY. WHEN IT
COMES TO, WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
YOUR YARDS, WHAT IS HAPPENING
BECAUSE IT'S DETRIMENTAL TO THE
FUTURE OF MOVEMENT. SO I THINK
THAT'S A PRIORITY. WE TALK ABOUT
PUBLIC SAFETY, BUT LET'S TALK
ABOUT YOUR OPERATION. THAT NEEDS
TO BE SECURED. SO I'M HOPING
YOU'RE HAVING A TOUGH LOOK AT
THAT. AND I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
THE NEXT MEETING. WE HAVE WHEN
YOU CAN COME BACK AND SEE WHAT
YOU'VE DONE. AND SUMMER OF 2024
VERSUS NEXT SUMMER OF 2025. AND
I THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU, SENATOR ARCHULETA, AND
YOU'LL BE HAPPY TO KNOW THAT THE
VERY NEXT PANEL IS TALKING ABOUT
SAFETY. OKAY. SO THAT WILL BE
RIGHT UP YOUR ALLEY. YES.
SENATOR NILO, THANK YOU, A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS. FIRST OF
ALL, THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD HAS COME UP IN
THIS DISCUSSION, WHICH IT DOES
IN EVERY DISCUSSION WE HAVE WITH
REGARD TO, MOBILE POWER PLANTS,
BECAUSE THEY ARE ABLE THEY'VE
BEEN ENABLED BY THIS LEGISLATURE
TO UNILATERALLY DEVELOP
REQUIREMENTS AND ALSO
UNILATERALLY DEVELOP ANY,
ALLOWANCES FOR EXCEPTIONS TO
THOSE REQUIREMENTS WITHOUT
REALLY ANY REVIEW BY ANYTHING
OTHER THAN THEIR BOARD. NONE OF
WHOM ARE ELECTED. I HAVE
REPEATEDLY SPOKEN ABOUT THIS.
I'VE MET WITH ARB LOOKING FOR
FLEXIBILITY THAT CAN PROVIDE FOR
INDUSTRY INPUT, NOT JUST RAIL,
BUT I MEAN, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
RAIL, ROAD AND MARINE
APPLICATIONS AND, IT IS
TROUBLING TO ME ANYWAY THAT
DEADLINES ARE ARBITRARY. YOU
KNOW, WHAT'S BETTER ABOUT 2028
THAN IT IS THAN 2035 OR WHATEVER
ELSE I REALIZE THAT IT'S AN
ISSUE OF CLEANER AIR, BUT, BUT
BUT IT'S STILL AN ARBITRARY DATE
AND THERE REALLY ISN'T MUCH
INPUT TO THAT OTHER THAN, THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD, WHICH, AS I
SAID, HAS BEEN AUTHORIZED BY
THIS LEGISLATURE TO OPERATE,
PRETTY MUCH UNILATERALLY. SO
THAT'S A CONCERN. AND OBVIOUSLY,
FOR YOU AND, AND I HERE IN THE
CASE OF SOME DIESEL LOCOMOTIVE
LOCOMOTIVES THAT YOU HAVE THAT
WILL NO LONGER, UNDER CURRENT
RULES, WILL NO LONGER BE ABLE TO
BE USED BEYOND A PARTICULAR
DATE. AND YOU CAN'T REPLACE THEM
BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES. AND SO THEREFORE YOU
HAVE TO TAKE THOSE OFF LINE,
POTENTIALLY WITHOUT REPLACING
THEM CONSIDERABLY COMPROMISING
YOUR RIDERSHIP. AND
SERVICEABILITY. AND WHERE ELSE
ARE THOSE PEOPLE GOING TO GO?
THEY'RE PROBABLY GOING TO BE
DRIVING CARS. AND THE OBJECTIVE
IS TO REDUCE CONGESTION AND AIR
POLLUTION. AND ARE THOSE
LOCOMOTIVES EVEN THOUGH THEY'RE
DIRTIER THAN ARB SAYS THEY
SHOULD BE, WHAT'S THE COMPARISON
BETWEEN THOSE EMISSIONS AND THE
EQUIVALENT NUMBER OF CARS? I'M
SAYING THAT AS A CAR DEALER, BY
THE WAY, BUT IT JUST SEEMS
ILLOGICAL. NOW. THEY'RE PROBABLY
GOING TO PROVIDE AN EXCEPTION, I
WOULD THINK, IF THEIR LOGICAL
ONCE YOU GET TO THAT POINT AND
YOU AIN'T GOT THE MONEY, BUT
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO KNOW THAT
UNTIL THEN. AND SO THE
UNILATERAL, UNILATERAL,
UNILATERAL ABILITY OF THAT I
FIND TROUBLING, THE OTHER POINT
IS WE HAVE A TREMENDOUS
COMPETITION OF RESOURCES FOR
RAIL TRAVEL, HIGH SPEED RAIL.
NOW, I PROPOSED A BILL WHICH
CAME DIRECTLY OUT OF A
INFORMATIONAL HEARING, TO WHICH
A PEER GROUP SUGGESTED THAT
SINCE, TO COMPLETE HIGH SPEED
RAIL, WHICH, BY THE WAY, HASN'T
CARRIED A PASSENGER, YOU'RE
CARRYING PASSENGERS. THERE IS
DEFINITELY A COMPETITION OF
FUNDING HERE, THAT TO COMPLETE
HIGH SPEED RAIL WILL TAKE
SOMEWHERE AROUND $100 BILLION.
AND WE HAVE NO IDEA WHERE THE
MONEY IS COMING FROM. AND I
PROPOSED A BILL THAT BASED UPON
A SUGGESTION OF A OF A PEER
GROUP AT THAT HEARING, THAT
MAYBE WE CALL A TIMEOUT AND
ASSESS WHERE WE ARE AND WHERE
WE'RE GOING. AND IT WAS DEFEATED,
RESOUNDINGLY DEFEATED. WE DON'T
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
COMPETITION OF HIGH SPEED RAIL.
AND I WAS JUST TALKING ABOUT THE
POINT BROUGHT UP, BROUGHT UP IN
THAT INFORMATIONAL HEARING. BUT
ALL OF THE MONEY THAT WE'VE PUT
INTO HIGH SPEED RAIL POTENTIALLY
COULD BE ADDED TO REGIONAL, RAIL
DEMAND. YOU'RE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. I REPRESENT THE
SACRAMENTO AND PLACER COUNTY
AREA. SO WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS
WAY FAR OUT OF MY DISTRICT. BUT
WE HAVE RAIL SYSTEMS REGIONALLY
AROUND THE STATE, AND THERE ARE
A LOT OF PEOPLE FROM MY AREA
THAT COMMUTE, COMMUTE TO THE BAY
AREA VIA RAIL, AND THEY NEED
RESOURCES TOO. THERE ARE LOTS OF
RAIL SYSTEMS AROUND THE STATE,
AND THERE'S A TREMENDOUS
COMPETITION OF RESOURCES WITH A
SYSTEM THAT HASN'T CARRIED A
PASSENGER AND PROBABLY WILL NOT
FOR YEARS TO COME. THERE'S NOT A
QUESTION IN THERE. IT'S A
COMMENT. I'M TROUBLED BY BOTH OF
THOSE THINGS. WELL, THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS. TO MY
COLLEAGUES. AND WE THANK THE
THREE OF YOU. SO THANK YOU, MR.
JEWELL. MR. DONAGHY, AND MR.
KETTLE. THANK YOU. WE WILL MOVE
ON TO OUR SECOND PANEL. AND OUR
SECOND PANEL, WE HAVE ROGER
CLUGSTON, RAIL SAFETY DIVISION
FOR CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. WE HAVE KYLE
GRADINGER, CHIEF, DIVISION OF
RAIL AND MASS TRANSPORTATION
FROM CALTRANS. AND WE ALSO HAVE
CARL SCHWING, DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL
COMMISSION. SO WELCOME TO THE
THREE OF YOU. AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IN ADVANCE FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. WE WILL BEGIN WITH
MR. CLUGSTON WHEN HE IS READY
WITH HIS POWERPOINT.
THAT'S HOW IT EVER WORKS. GOOD
AFTERNOON. I MAY NEED SOME
ASSISTANCE. I'M A 19TH CENTURY
INDIVIDUAL THAT'S BEEN DRUG INTO
THE 21ST CENTURY. WE HAVE PEOPLE
FOR THAT, SO THEY WILL COME
FORWARD AND HELP YOU OUT RIGHT
NOW. THANK YOU. MY APOLOGIES.
WHAT DOES IT SAY ON YOUR HAT? I
CAN BARELY READ IT. DOES IT SAY
RAIL SAFETY, RAIL SAFETY? ESTÁ
RAIL SAFETY DIVISION. RAIL
SAFETY DIVISION? YES. SORRY.
THERE'S A.
SORRY FOR THE DELAY, OKAY. GOOD
AFTERNOON. I'M ROGER CLUGSTON.
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE RAIL
SAFETY DIVISION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. I'VE BEEN WITH THE
CPUC FOR 23.5 YEARS, BUT I
STARTED MY RAILROAD CAREER 51
YEARS AGO. IN 1973, ON THE
ATCHISON, TOPEKA AND SANTA FE
RAILWAY. I WENT TO WORK. MY
PROFESSION IS TRACK CONSTRUCTION
AND TRACK MAINTENANCE. I CAME TO
THE PUC AS A RAILROAD TRACK
INSPECTOR IN 2001, AND I WORKED
MY WAY UP TO DIRECTOR, THE
SECOND SLIDE HERE, THE MY RAIL
SAFETY DIVISION, COMPRISES OF
THREE BRANCHES. I HAVE A RAIL
CROSSING ENGINEERING BRANCH
WHICH HANDLES ALL OF THE AT
GRADE CROSSINGS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. WE ALSO DO ALL OF THE
GRADE SEPARATIONS FOR HIGH SPEED
RAIL FOR THE CALIFORNIA
HIGH-SPEED RAIL PROJECT AND
BRIGHTLINE WEST AND MY RAIL
TRANSIT SAFETY BRANCH HAS THE
OVERSIGHT OF THE 15 RAIL TRANSIT
ENTITIES IN CALIFORNIA, SUCH AS
BART'S, THE SACRAMENTO REGIONAL
TRANSIT, LA METRO, AND EVEN THE
ANGELS FLIGHT FUNICULAR IN LOS
ANGELES. THE THIRD BRANCH IS THE
LARGEST BRANCH, WHICH IS THE
RAILROAD OPERATIONS AND SAFETY
BRANCH. WE HAVE OVERSIGHT OF
9885 MILES OF MAINLINE TRACK.
NOW, YOU MAY SEE WHERE THERE ARE
ROUTE MILES. WELL, THAT ROUTE
MILE MAY HAVE THREE MAIN LINES.
SO THAT MAKES IT THREE MILES. SO
THERE'S A LOT MORE TRACKS OUT
THERE. AND YOU THINK THAT ALSO
IS NOT JUST, THE CLASS ONES SUCH
AS UNION PACIFIC. BNSF AND SO
ON, BUT WE ALSO HAVE 28
SHORTLINE RAILROADS OPERATING IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS WELL.
THE NEXT SLIDE ROB THE RAILROAD
OPERATIONS SAFETY BRANCH. WE'RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR STATE AND
FEDERAL OVERSIGHT OF ALL CODE OF
FEDERAL REGULATIONS APPLICABLE
TO FREIGHT AND PASSENGER
RAILROAD SYSTEMS. ALL OF MY
STAFF ARE CERTIFIED IN THE
VARIOUS DISCIPLINES THAT YOU SEE
ON THE SLIDE HERE. TRACKS
OPERATIONS. RAIL. RAIL CARS AND
EQUIPMENT, WHICH IS USUALLY JUST
CALLED EQUIPMENT, SIGNALS AND
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS. WE RECEIVED
OUR CERTIFICATION PROCESS IN
1991 AFTER THE CANTALOUPE
INCIDENT UP IN IN NORTH OF
SACRAMENTO. HERE, BACK IN 1991,
EACH AND EVERY ONE OF THE MY
FIELD INSPECTORS AND THIS IS
REALLY A BOOTS ON THE GROUND
NUTS AND BOLTS, WORK THAT WE DO,
OUR, OUR JOB IS TO GO OUT AND
WHATEVER THE RAILROADS ARE
RUNNING, WHATEVER EQUIPMENT THEY
HAVE, WHATEVER TYPE OF RAIL
THEY'RE USING, WHATEVER TYPE OF
CROSSTIES THEY'RE USING,
WHATEVER SIGNALING SYSTEMS
THEY'RE USING. OUR JOB IS TO GO
OUT AND INSPECT THEIR INSPECTORS.
WE RIDE WITH THEIR TRACK
INSPECTORS, WHICH IS BEING A
FORMER TRACK INSPECTOR. I HAVE
EXPERIENCE WITH WE RIDE ALONG
WITH THEM BY RAIL WITH THEM, WE
WALK TRACKS WITH THEM. AND OUR
JOB IS TO OBSERVE AND MAKE SURE
THAT THEY DEMONSTRATE A
COMPETENCY LEVEL OF THEIR
ABILITY TO IDENTIFY AND
REMEDIATE DEFECTIVE CONDITIONS
AS THEY EXIST IN THE FIELD. AND
THAT GOES FOR EACH ONE OF THESE
SPECIFIC DISCIPLINES FOR
OPERATIONS, STAFF WILL GO OUT
AND THEY WILL OBSERVE LOCOMOTIVE
ENGINEERS AND CONDUCTORS AND
CONDUCTORS AS THEY'RE OPERATING
TRAINS CHECK TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE THEIR PROPER
CERTIFICATION. WE ALSO OBSERVE
THEM IN RAIL YARDS DOING
SWITCHING OF, OPERATIONS THAT
THEY'RE GETTING ON. AND OFF
EQUIPMENT SAFELY, THAT THEY'RE
COMPLYING WITH EVERY ASPECT OF
THE CODE OF FEDERAL REGULATIONS
REQUIRED TO PERFORM THOSE THOSE
JOBS, RAIL CARS AND LOCOMOTIVES,
WHICH IS A REAL IMPORTANT PART
HERE. OUR EQUIPMENT INSPECTORS,
WE GO OUT TO RAIL YARDS,
ESPECIALLY RAIL YARDS, WHERE YOU
HAVE A HIGH CONCENTRATION OF
CARS COMING IN AND LEAVING THE
STATE. WE GO IN AND WHERE THE
RAILROAD HAS BEEN REQUIRED TO
PERFORM AN INSPECTION ON A ON A
DEPARTING TRAIN, WE'LL GO BEHIND
THEIR INSPECTORS AND WE'LL SEE
IF THEY WERE, ACTUALLY PROVIDING
A COMPETENT LEVEL OF OVERSIGHT
ON THE TRAIN, PERFORMING AIR
TESTS, MAKING SURE THAT THEY
THAT THE BRAKE SHOES ARE IN
PLACE IN ANY OF THE COMPONENTS
OF A RAIL CAR THAT ARE REQUIRED
TO HAVE A GOOD THOROUGH
INSPECTION. WE'RE MAKING SURE
THAT THEY DO THAT. WE VISIT THE
RIP TRACKS OR REPAIR FACILITIES
AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE DOING
THE JOBS THERE. WE ALSO LOOK FOR
OUTLYING AREAS. WE FOLLOW THE
RAILROADS ALONG. WHEREVER THEIR
OPERATIONS MAY CHANGE. THEY MAY
DO CAR INSPECTIONS AT ONE
LOCATION, AND IT CHANGES TO A
DIFFERENT LOCATION DOWN THE
ROAD. SO WE'RE GOING TO FOLLOW
ALONG WHEREVER THEY MOVE THEIR
OPERATION. THE SAME GOES FOR
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS. IT IS THE
SHIPPERS RESPONSIBILITY TO
PACKAGE AND TO BE ABLE TO PUT
INTO TRANSPORTATION REVENUE
SERVICE OF A HAZMAT COMMODITY.
THOSE THOSE SHIPPERS, WE
ACTUALLY GO INTO THEIR
FACILITIES, WE INSPECT THE
PROCESSES THAT THEY GO THROUGH,
THEIR PROCEDURES, MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE PROVIDING ALL OF THE
ADEQUATE PAPERWORK FOR ALL OF
THE HAZMAT BEING SHIPPED. AND IF
IT'S PROPERLY PACKAGED IN THE
SHIP, THEN IT GOES INTO INTO
TRANSPORTATION. THESE ARE ALL
THINGS THAT THE RAILROADS ARE
REQUIRED TO DO. THESE WE'RE
FOLLOWING UP BEHIND THEM AND THE
WORK THAT WE DO TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY ARE COMPLYING WITH ALL
STATE AND FEDERAL REGULATIONS
APPLICABLE TO, FREIGHT AND
PASSENGER SERVICE. THIS IS OUR
MISSION STATEMENT. BASICALLY,
FOR US, IT'S A MATTER OF TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE PROTECT THE
PUBLIC FROM ANY UNSAFE ACTS,
CONDITIONS OR SITUATIONS ON ON A
RAILROAD'S PROPERTY. ANYTHING
THAT WE RUN ACROSS. THESE ARE
SOME OF THE SAFETY CONCERNS THAT
WE DO HAVE, THINGS THAT, YOU SEE
IN THE NEWS, A LOT, EVERYTHING
FROM HOMELESS COMMUNITIES TO,
VEHICLE QUEUING AT GRADE
CROSSINGS. THERE'S A NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT WE DO TO TRY TO,
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE, RISKY
EVENTS, PERCEIVED RISKS AND REAL
RISKS. FOR EXAMPLE, I STARTED
THE ONLY STATE RAILROAD BRIDGE
PROGRAM IN 2012. WE CALIFORNIA
HAS TWO RAILROAD BRIDGE
INSPECTORS. I STARTED A TUNNEL
PROJECT WHERE WE'RE ACTUALLY
ANALYZING RAILROAD TUNNELS,
LOOKING AT APPROACHES AND
LOOKING AT THE INTEGRITY OF THE
TUNNELS THROUGHOUT FROM ONE END
TO THE OTHER. WE HAVE A SPECIAL
PROGRAM REGARDING RAIL HEADWEAR
LOSS, WHERE THE ACTUAL METAL OF
THE RAIL IS ACTUALLY REDUCED
FROM WEAR AND TEAR, AND THEY
HAVE CONDEMNABLE LEVELS. AND WE
LOOK AT THOSE TO TRY TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE RAILROAD IS
ACTUALLY WATCHING THEM. THERE'S
ANOTHER DIFFERENT, OF DIFFERENT
INITIATIVES LIKE THAT THAT, THAT
WE UTILIZE AS SPECIAL TOOLS TO
TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR THE
RAILROADS ARE BEING COMPLIANT
WITH ALL OF THE STATE AND
FEDERAL REGULATIONS, BUT ALSO
LOOKING BEYOND THE REGULATIONS,
LOOKING A LITTLE DEEPER INTO
CERTAIN ASPECTS OF RAILROAD
SAFETY THAT MAY NOT BE FOCUSED
ON BY THE RAILROADS THEMSELVES,
THESE ARE THE POSITIONS THAT I
CURRENTLY HAVE FOR THIS ONE
BRANCH. I HAVE APPROXIMATELY 130
POSITIONS IN THE RAIL SAFETY
DIVISION. THE, THE MAJORITY OF
THEM, ABOUT 53 OF THESE
POSITIONS ARE WITH THE RAILROAD
OPERATIONS AND SAFETY BRANCH.
THE MAJORITY OF MY PEOPLE ARE
BOOTS ON THE GROUND PEOPLE.
THEY'RE ENGINEERS AND
EXPERIENCED INSPECTORS THAT
UNDERSTAND, RAILROAD OPERATIONS,
UNDERSTANDS THEIR THEIR SPECIFIC
DISCIPLINE. THEY ARE EXPERTS IN
THE FIELD. HOWEVER, THESE ARE
JUST THE ACTUAL POSITIONS. IF
YOU ACTUALLY LOOK AT IT, WHAT I
HAVE WITH MY LEADERSHIP TEAM, WE
HAVE APPROXIMATELY 1300 YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE AMONGST ALL OF US. SO
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT KNOW THIS
BUSINESS. THESE ARE PEOPLE,
THESE THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
LIVED AND BREATHED THIS FOR MANY
YEARS. I HAVE ONE INDIVIDUAL
STILL WORKING WHO'S 78 YEARS
OLD, AND HE'S ONE OF THE FINEST
INSPECTORS THAT I HAVE, WE THESE
ARE GOOD, DEDICATED MEN AND
WOMEN THAT SPEND A LOT OF TIME
OUT IN THE FIELD, AND THE
MAJORITY OF THE TIME OUT IN THE
FIELD TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC. THESE ARE
OUR STATEWIDE FIELD INSPECTION
DAYS, JUST AS BASED FROM JANUARY
2022 TO JULY 24TH, WHICH IS WHEN
I RAN THE QUERY, BASICALLY, YOU
CAN SEE WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY
9200 DAYS INSPECTION DAYS IN THE
FIELD OVER THAT PERIOD OF TIME.
THAT'S FOR ALL. ALL OF
CALIFORNIA. AND AGAIN, WE HAVE
ALMOST 10,000, 10,000 MILES OF
RAILROAD. AND WE HAVE ALL OF THE
FACILITIES WHERE RAIL CARS GO
INTO RAIL YARDS AND SO ON. WE
HAVE TO INSPECT THOSE ONCE EVERY
100 DAYS. THOSE ARE THOSE ARE
LEGISLATIVE MANDATES. EVERY MILE
OF TRACK ANNUALLY IN THE STATE
OF KANSAS, WHICH I'M SURE YOU'RE
AWARE OF. THIS IN PARTICULAR IS
FOR THE LUCENT CORRIDOR. THESE
ARE THE INSPECTION DAYS THAT
ARE, SPECIFIC TO THE LAUSANNE,
BUT I WANTED TO SAY THAT, 294
INSPECTION DAYS. WHILE THESE
NUMBERS SEEM LOW COMPARED TO
WHAT WE HAVE WITH THIS, THIS IS
350 MILES OF 9885 MILES. I
GUARANTEE YOU, THEY'RE NOT, THE
INSPECTIONS THAT WE DO IN ALL OF
THE OUTLYING AREAS, WHETHER RAIL
YARDS OR OTHER, ALL OF THAT WORK
AFFECTS TRANSPORTATION OVER THE
LAUSANNE CORRIDOR. ANYTHING
THAT'S GOING OVER IT IS GOING TO
BE, COMING OUT OF A RAIL YARD
SUCH AS WEST COLTON YARD, ICTF
YARD, MAYBE ROSEVILLE, LOTS OF
SMALLER YARDS, SATELLITE YARDS
ALL OVER THE PLACE, EVEN COMING
UP THROUGH SAN YSIDRO FROM
MEXICO. SO ALL OF THE ALL OF
THIS, THESE INSPECTIONS, THAT
ARE OUTSIDE OF THOSE AREAS,
ACTUALLY HAVE AN EFFECT ON IT.
THESE NUMBERS HERE, THOSE 294 IS
WHAT'S ACTUALLY PHYSICALLY
TAKING PLACE ON THE LAWCENTER ON
THAT 351 MILE STRETCH. ALSO TO I
WOULD SAY THAT IT'S NOT JUST THE
PUC, NOT JUST US THAT ARE
PERFORMING THESE INSPECTIONS,
BUT THE FEDERAL RAILROAD
ADMINISTRATION HAS THEIR OWN
STAFF OUT THERE. WE OFTEN WORK
IN CONCERT WITH THE FRA. WE ALSO
WORK IN CONCERT WITH OTHER
ENTITIES, SUCH AS THE CALIFORNIA
COAST GUARD, AND THAT BRINGS ME
INTO THE HAZMAT TRANSPORTATION,
THE MAJORITY OF THE HAZMAT OVER
THE LAUSANNE IS, IS LPG, WE DO
HAVE THE DIRTY DIRT COMING OUT
OF SAN ONOFRE, THIS IS ALL YOU
KNOW, THE COMMODITIES AND THAT
ARE THAT ARE INSPECTED BY OUR,
MY, MY STAFF TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE PROPERLY PACKAGED.
THEY'RE IN THE PROPER CONTAINER,
WHICH IS EITHER A RAIL CAR OR
THEY MIGHT BE IN BARRELS ON A ON
BOARD A BOXCAR, WHATEVER IT IS,
WHATEVER IT IS, WE INSPECT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE, PROPERLY
PACKED AND SAFE AND THAT THE
PAPERWORK FOR ALL OF THEM IS UP
TO DATE. EVERY WEEK WE GO OUT
WITH THE US COAST GUARD DOWN TO
THE PORTS PORT OF LOS ANGELES
AND SAN PEDRO AND OTHER
LOCATIONS LIKE SAN DIEGO,
OAKLAND AND CONTAINERS THAT ARE
COMING IN OFF OF SHIPS. IF
THERE'S SOMETHING BOGUS ABOUT
THEM, IF THEY'RE MULTI
PLACARDED, MAYBE THEY'RE LEAKING,
MAYBE THERE'S SOME SOMETHING
ELSE GOING ON WITH THE CAR THAT
IS SUSPICIOUS. WE'LL CUT THEM
OPEN. WE'LL CUT OPEN THE BACK.
THE SEALS ON THE BACK. WE'LL
OPEN IT UP. WE'LL INSPECT IT.
MAKE SURE THE SHIPPING PAPERS
ARE CORRECT AND, AND THEN
THERE'S ALWAYS A HAZMAT TEAM
THAT'S ON STANDBY THAT CAN
ADDRESS ANY ISSUES. IF WE FIND
THEM. THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
CONTAINERS COME IN EVERY DAY IN
THE PORTS. SO THERE'S LOTS OF
HAZMAT THAT COME IN IN OTHER
WAYS. THEY'LL COME IN FROM THE
EAST, THEY'LL COME IN FROM THE
NORTH THROUGH THE STATE, DOWN
THROUGH, ROSEVILLE, ALL THE WAY
DOWN THROUGH THE STRAT NECK
QUARTER OF THE VALLEY, THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AND THE NECK
QUARTER OF THE COAST, THERE'S AN
INORDINATE AMOUNT OF TRAFFIC
THAT COMES INTO CALIFORNIA. FOR
EXAMPLE, THERE'S APPROXIMATELY
1.6 MILLION RAIL CARS IN
NORTHERN NORTH AMERICA. WELL
THOSE CAN MAKE 3 OR 4 TRIPS IN
AND OUT OF CALIFORNIA HERE
EASILY, MAYBE EVEN MORE SO. WE
GOT BASICALLY MILLIONS OF CARS
COMING IN AND OUT OF THE STATE
CARRYING ALL KINDS OF
COMMODITIES. NOW, WE DO FOLLOW
ALONG AFTER UNIT TRAINS SUCH AS
CRUDE OIL TRAINS. NOW, I WAS
FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO WORK ON THE
GOVERNOR'S WORKING GROUP ON
CRUDE OIL TRANSPORTATION SOME
YEARS BACK, AND WE MADE SOME
GREAT HEADWAY THERE. I STARTED A
CRUDE OIL RECON TEAM IN 2014 SO
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY MONITOR
CRUDE OIL UNIT TRAINS COMING IN
AND OUT OF THE STATE, BUT THEY
DON'T ALL COME IN ON UNIT
TRAINS. THEY COME IN BY OTHER
MEANS ON ON MANIFEST TRAINS OR
WHAT WE CALL MIXED FREIGHT
TRAINS. SO REGARDLESS,
REGARDLESS, SEVEN DAYS A WEEK I
HAVE STAFF THAT ARE OUT AND
WE'RE GOING INTO RAIL YARDS.
WE'RE GOING INTO ALL THESE
FACILITIES AND WE'RE DOING
INSPECTIONS ON ALL OF THESE
TRAINS TO ENSURE THAT THEY ARE
COMPLIANT WITH ALL STATE AND
FEDERAL REGULATIONS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT, AT WHEELS, AT SHARP
FLANGES, AT SIDE BEARINGS, EVERY
ASPECT OF IT. ALSO, WHEN IT
COMES TO THEY MENTIONED BEFORE
ABOUT SLAUGHTER'S OUT THERE,
WHILE WHILE IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
AND I UNDERSTAND YOUR CONCERN
REGARDING ON TIME PERFORMANCE
AND SO ON. WELL THAT'S IMPORTANT
WHENEVER THE TRACK IS UNSAFE
THEN THE SLAUGHTER'S A
REQUIREMENT. YOU KNOW IF IT IF
IT'S A TRACK THAT'S GOOD FOR 60
MPH AND THEY FIND A DEGRADED
CONDITION THAT REQUIRES THE
TRACK TO BE REDUCED TO A LOWER
SPEED, THAT IT CAN SAFELY
TRANSVERSE OVER, THEN THAT'S
WHAT HAS TO HAPPEN. THAT'S WHAT
WE DO. WE'RE THE ONES THAT ARE
OUT THERE, AND WE MAKE SURE THAT
THE RAILROAD IS DOING THIS.
THAT'S WHY WE GO WITH THEM ON
ANY GIVEN DAY. IT'S THE RAILROAD
INSPECTOR ITSELF, THE ONE THAT
WORKS FOR THE RAILROAD COMPANY
THAT HAS TO, ON A DAILY BASIS,
24 OVER SEVEN, BE ABLE TO GO OUT
THERE AND PROPERLY IDENTIFY
EGREGIOUS CONDITIONS AND A
DEFECTIVE CONDITIONS THAT
REQUIRE AN IMMEDIATE REMEDIAL
ACTION TO BE ABLE TO GET THAT
TRAIN OVER, OVER IT FROM POINT A
TO POINT B. MR. CLARKSON, WE
APPRECIATE ALL THIS, BUT COULD I
ASK YOU TO WRAP IT UP BECAUSE
EACH PERSON IS SUPPOSED TO SPEAK
FOR TEN MINUTES? CERTAINLY.
THANK YOU, I'M SORRY I'M LONG
WINDED IN MY OLD AGE. I
APOLOGIZE REAL QUICKLY ON
BRIDGES. AS I SAID, WE STARTED A
BRIDGE PROGRAM AND THIS WILL
JUST GIVE YOU AN IDEA OF SOME OF
THE, BRIDGES THAT ARE OUT THERE
ON THESE PARTICULAR PROPERTIES
FOR BNSF, METROLINK, NORTH
COUNTY TRANSIT, AND SO ON. BUT
THIS IS THE NORTH, NORTH AND
SOUTH PART OF THE OF THE LOS.
AND WE DO INCIDENT
INVESTIGATIONS FOR DERAILMENTS
OF ALL OF THESE ACTIVITIES. WE
TRY TO GET OUR PEOPLE OUT THERE
IN A TIMELY MANNER TO BE ABLE TO
COLLECT EVIDENCE. LOOK, TAKE
PHOTOGRAPHS, TAKE MEASUREMENTS,
DO ALL OF THESE THINGS. WE LOOK
AT TRESPASSER VERSUS TRAIN
INCIDENTS, TRESPASSER VERSUS
VEHICLE. WE HAVE QUITE A FEW OF
THOSE, UNFORTUNATELY, IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BUT WE THAT
IS PART OF OUR OUR WORK TOO. AND
OF COURSE THE INTENT IS TO TRY
TO MAKE SURE THAT WHATEVER WE DO
FIND OUT THERE, THAT WE CAN HELP
THE RAILROAD UNDERSTAND WHAT
THEY NEED TO DO TO TRY TO KEEP
IT FROM HAPPENING AGAIN. AND
THAT'S IT. THANK YOU. THAT'S A
TERRIBLE SLIDE TO END WITH THE
TRAIN COMING OFF THE TRACKS.
HOPEFULLY THAT'S NOT ON THE LOW
SAN CORRIDOR. NO IT WASN'T. I
TOOK THAT MYSELF SOME YEARS BACK
OKAY. WELL THANK YOU MR.
CLUGSTON. WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE IT. AND WE WILL MOVE
NOW TO MR. GRADINGER. CAN YOU
TAKE A SECOND? OKAY. FOR THAT,
DO YOU WANT TO SWITCH? YES,
MAYBE. MAYBE SWITCHING SEATS IS
A GOOD PLAN. YEAH THANK YOU.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT. EVERY MOUSE IS
DIFFERENT. OKAY. THANK YOU. OKAY
GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR. AND
SENATOR ARCHULETA, THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
TODAY. MY NAME IS KYLE
GRADINGER, AND I AM THE DIVISION
CHIEF FOR THE CALTRANS DIVISION
OF RAIL. THE CALTRANS DIVISION
OF RAIL HAS THREE PRIMARY
RESPONSIBILITIES. THE FIRST IS
TO LEAD STATEWIDE RAIL PLANNING.
THE SECOND IS THAT WE OVERSEE
CALIFORNIA'S BEST IN THE NATION,
STATE SUPPORTED INTERCITY
PASSENGER RAIL PROGRAM AND
THIRD, WE OAN MANAGE AND
PROCURE THE STATE'S PASSENGER
RAIL FLEET, INCLUDING LEADING
THE TRANSITION TO ZERO
EMISSIONS. WE COULDN'T DO THIS
WORK WITHOUT OUR KEY PARTNERS,
MANY OF WHOM YOU'VE HEARD FROM
ALREADY, AND THEY INCLUDE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY, THE INTERCITY PASSENGER
RAIL JOINT POWERS AUTHORITIES,
AMTRAK, HOST FREIGHT RAILROADS,
COMMUTER RAILROADS, THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY, AND THEN
OTHER REGIONAL AGENCIES WITH
RAIL ACTIVITIES AND INTERESTS.
I'LL START BY JUST MENTIONING
THAT CALTRANS RECOGNIZES THE
CLIMATE RESILIENCY IS AN URGENT
CHALLENGE FOR THIS CORRIDOR, AND
CALTRANS IS PROACTIVELY LEADING
CORRIDOR RESILIENCY EFFORTS AND
PARTNERING WITH OTHERS THROUGH
SUPPORT AND INVESTMENT.
PREVIOUSLY, WE WORKED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION TO DEVELOP A PROCESS
TO REQUEST EMERGENCY FUNDING FOR
LANDSLIDE MITIGATIONS, WHICH HAS
BEEN UNFORTUNATELY TAPPED INTO
QUITE A FEW TIMES SINCE THAT
PROCESS WAS PUT IN PLACE JUST A
YEAR OR SO AGO. WE ARE ALSO
COMMITTED TO GUIDING A CONCERTED
EFFORT WITH LOCAL ENTITIES AND
PARTNERS IN EACH OF THE
CORRIDORS AROUND THE STATE TO
ADDRESS AND OVERCOME THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES TO BRING THE STATE
RAIL PLAN VISION TO FRUITION.
AND FINALLY, I JUST WANT TO SAY
I APPRECIATE YOU, SENATOR BLAKE
SPEER, AND THIS COMMITTEE FOR
CREATING THIS SUBCOMMITTEE AND
BRINGING THIS ISSUE TO THE
FOREFRONT. TRANSPORTING
CALIFORNIANS AND GOODS VIA RAIL
ADVANCES CALTRANS CORE FOUR
PRIORITIES. FIRST OF ALL, RAIL
IS THE SAFEST MODE OF SURFACE
TRANSPORTATION AND SHIFTING
PASSENGER AND GOODS MOVEMENT
FROM HIGHWAYS TO RAIL
FUNDAMENTALLY IMPROVES SAFETY
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS IN TERMS OF
EQUITY AND INTERCONNECTED RAIL
AND TRANSIT SYSTEM THAT IS
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE FOR
ALL. PROVIDES ECONOMIC BENEFITS
AND OPPORTUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE. IN TERMS OF CLIMATE
ACTION, THE 2050 RAIL PLAN
VISION ANTICIPATES A SHIFT OF
ABOUT 178 MILLION DAILY
PASSENGER MILES TO CLEAN AND
EFFICIENT TRAINS BY 2050. MODE
SHIFT IS A VITAL STRATEGY FOR
ACHIEVING THE AMBITIOUS
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
REDUCTION GOALS THAT WERE SET
OUT IN THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD'S SCOPING PLAN
AND FINALLY, IMPROVEMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA'S RAIL SYSTEM ARE
INVESTMENTS THAT WILL PAY OFF
THE ECONOMIC BENEFIT OF BUILDING
THE RAIL PLAN. VISION WILL BE
NEARLY $1.75 FOR EVERY DOLLAR
INVESTED. CALTRANS LEADS
STATEWIDE RAIL PLANNING EFFORTS
IN COLLABORATION WITH OUR INNER
CITY COMMUTER AND FREIGHT RAIL
PARTNERS, AS WELL AS OTHER LOCAL
AGENCIES WHO OWN FUND OR PLAN TO
OPERATE RAIL SERVICES. THE STATE
HAS ESTABLISHED A BLUEPRINT FOR
HOW WE BUILD THE NETWORK FOR THE
FUTURE, WITH THE STATE RAIL
PLAN. THE STATE RAIL PLAN
ESTABLISHES THE LONG TERM VISION
FOR AN INTEGRATED STATEWIDE
NETWORK OF RAIL AND TRANSIT THAT
WILL ENABLE US TO ENABLE US TO
SHIFT A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
TRAVEL FROM HIGHWAYS TO RAIL BY
2050. THE RAIL PLAN BRINGS
TOGETHER LOCAL, REGIONAL AND
STATEWIDE GOALS INTO ONE COMMON
OVERARCHING VISION. SO WHAT ARE
SOME OF THE KEY FEATURES OF THE
STATE RAIL PLAN? WELL, THE FIRST
IS, AS I MENTIONED, AN
INTEGRATED STATEWIDE NETWORK
WITH TIMED CONNECTIONS AND PULSE
SCHEDULES, AS MR. KETTLE TALKED
ABOUT, WHICH WILL MAKE IT EASIER
FOR CALIFORNIANS TO CHOOSE TO
MOVE AROUND BY RAIL AND TRANSIT.
FREQUENT SERVICE WILL INCREASE
MOBILITY AND MAKE RAIL AN OPTION
FOR ALL KINDS OF TRIPS. THE
STATE RAIL PLAN ENVISIONS
SERVICES THAT OPERATE AT REGULAR
INTERVALS THROUGHOUT THE DAY
HOURLY, HALF HOURLY OR BETTER.
IN SOME CORRIDORS, SUCH
SCHEDULES MAKE RAIL A VIABLE
OPTION FOR ALL TYPES OF TRIPS,
NOT JUST PEAK HOUR COMMUTES OR
LONG DISTANCE TRAVEL. AND I JUST
WANT TO APPLAUD MR. KETTLE. I
THINK THAT METROLINK REIMAGINED
IS REALLY A FANTASTIC FIRST
STEP. MOVING TOWARD TOWARD THAT
COMMON VISION FOR THE STATE RAIL
PLAN. ADDITIONALLY, THE RAIL
PLAN FORESEES A COMMON TRIP
PLANNING AND FARE PAYMENT
PLATFORM, WHICH WILL PROVIDE
REAL TIME INFORMATION, EQUITABLE
FARES, AND SIMPLICITY FOR
TRAVELERS. AND FINALLY, THE
OUTCOME OF THIS APPROACH WILL BE
TO DELIVER A NETWORK THAT IS
COST EFFECTIVE NOT ONLY TO
BUILD, BUT ALSO TO OPERATE. LAST
YEAR, WE WERE GAINED. WE GAINED
A POWERFUL NEW TOOL TO IMPLEMENT
THE STATE RAIL PLAN VISION IN
THE FORM OF THE CORRIDOR
IDENTIFICATION AND DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM, THE FEDERAL RAILROAD
ADMINISTRATION PROCESS TO
DEVELOP A SUSTAINED
COMPREHENSIVE PASSENGER RAIL
PROJECT PIPELINE. THIS IS MUCH
LIKE THE FEDERAL TRANSIT
ADMINISTRATIONS CAPITAL
INVESTMENT GRANT PROGRAM, WHICH
ESTABLISHES DEVELOPMENT
MILESTONES AND THEN COMMITS
FUNDING FOR SUBWAY, LIGHT RAIL
AND BUS RAPID TRANSIT PROJECTS.
EACH YEAR, THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION OR THE FRA WILL
SUBMIT TO CONGRESS A LIST OF
CAPITAL PROJECTS THAT HAVE BEEN
APPROVED THROUGH THE CORRIDOR ID
PROGRAM, AND THAT WILL FORM A
PIPELINE OF PROJECTS READY FOR
SUSTAINED FEDERAL FUNDING. TO
QUOTE THE FEDERAL RAILROAD
ADMINISTRATION, THE CORRIDOR ID
PROGRAM IS INTENDED TO BECOME
THE PRIMARY MEANS FOR DIRECTING
FEDERAL FINANCIAL SUPPORT AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE, ASSISTANCE
TOWARD THE DEVELOPMENT OF
INTERCITY PASSENGER RAIL
SERVICES THROUGHOUT THE UNITED
STATES. PARTNERING WITH OUR
CONGRESSIONAL DELEGATION, THE
LARGEST IN THE NATION, THE
CORRIDOR ID PROGRAM WILL HELP US
LAND SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL
INVESTMENTS IN CALIFORNIA'S RAIL
SYSTEM, FURTHER LEVERAGING THIS
STATE'S HISTORIC INVESTMENT IN
PASSENGER RAIL TO ACHIEVE OUR
SAFETY, EQUITY, CLIMATE, AND
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY. GOALS
CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY MADE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN
PASSENGER RAIL AND WORKING
TOGETHER THROUGH THE FEDERAL
CORRIDOR ID PROCESS, WILL ALLOW
US TO TAP INTO 80 AND 90%
FEDERAL MATCH PROGRAMS FOR
PROJECTS ON ALL OF OUR INTERCITY
CORRIDORS, JUST AS WE HAVE LED
THE STATE RAIL PLAN, CALTRANS IS
LEADING CORRIDOR ID PROGRAMS IN
FIVE KEY CORRIDORS ACROSS THE
STATE. THOSE SHOWN HERE IN BLUE.
AND THAT INCLUDES, OF COURSE,
THE LOWSTAND CORRIDOR. WE INTEND
TO FOLLOW THE FEDERAL PROCESS
FROM HERE ON OUT WITH THE STATE
RAIL PLAN AS THE STATE'S VISION
TO PLAN, FUND, PERMIT AND
IMPLEMENT PROJECTS. PROJECT
PIPELINES IN EACH CORRIDOR TO
ACHIEVE THE STATE RAIL PLAN.
VISION FOR ALL FIVE CORRIDORS.
WE ARE CURRENTLY WRAPPING UP
STEP ONE, SHOWN ON THE SLIDE
HERE WHERE WE ARE DEFINING A
SCOPE, SCHEDULE AND BUDGET FOR A
SERVICE DEVELOPMENT PLAN OR AN
STP STEP TWO IS TO DEVELOP AN
STP FOR EACH OF THOSE CORRIDORS
AND AN STP ENTAILS A MULTI-YEAR
PLANNING EFFORT TO ESTABLISH A
SERVICE CONCEPT FOR A CORRIDOR,
SORT OF A BIG VISION AND WHAT
THAT SERVICE IS GOING TO LOOK
LIKE, AND THEN DERIVE THE
NECESSARY CAPITAL PROJECTS TO
OPERATE THAT SERVICE. THESE
PLANS CAN BE DEVELOPED ALONGSIDE
TIERED TIER ONE CORRIDOR WIDE
NEPA DOCUMENTS, AND THEY RANGE
FROM 5 TO $15 MILLION TO
COMPLETE, DEPENDING ON CORRIDOR
COMPLEXITY. AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WILL PROVIDE 90% OF
THE FUNDING FOR THE FIVE
CORRIDORS. WE HAVE IDENTIFIED IN
STEP TWO, CAPITAL PROJECTS THAT
ARE IDENTIFIED IN STEP TWO OF
CIDP WILL ADVANCE INTO STEP
THREE. PROJECT DEVELOPMENT.
PROJECT DEVELOPMENT INCLUDES
PROJECT LEVEL NEPA AND
PRELIMINARY ENGINEERING FOR
PROJECTS IN THE CORRIDOR, AND
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL
PROVIDE 80% OF THE PROJECT
DEVELOPMENT FUNDING FOR STEP
THREE PROJECTS. THIS FUNDING IN
THE CONVERSATIONS I'VE HAD AND
WORKSHOPS I'VE PARTICIPATED IN
WITH THE FRA IS AVAILABLE
THROUGH AN ADVANCE APPROPRIATION
UNDER IIJA. AND SO THE MONEY
THAT I'M TALKING ABOUT FOR R-5
CORRIDORS THROUGH STEP THREE
EXISTS AND IS AVAILABLE AT THE
FRA TODAY. AND THEN FINALLY
AFTER STEP THREE, CAPITAL
PROJECTS WILL ENTER THE PIPELINE
FOR FEDERAL FUNDING UNDER THE
FRA, FED STATE PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM, WHICH WAS FUNDED AT A
LEVEL OF ABOUT $60 BILLION FOR
NON NORTHEAST CORRIDOR
ACTIVITIES UNDER IDEA FOR THE
LAUSANNE CORRIDOR, WE HAVE
SUBMITTED REVIEW MATERIALS TO
THE FEDERAL RAILROAD
ADMINISTRATION AND WE ARE
WORKING ACTIVELY WITH LAUSANNE
AGENCY AND OUR OTHER LOCAL
PARTNERS TO FINALIZE THE SCOPE,
SCHEDULE AND BUDGET FOR THE
LAUSANNE SERVICE DEVELOPMENT
PLAN AND THAT WILL TAKE PLACE
OVER THE REMAINDER OF 2024, ONCE
IT'S APPROVED BY THE FRA, THEN
WE WILL ENTER STEP TWO AND WE
WILL COMMENCE THAT WORK IN EARLY
2025. WHERE IN THAT EFFORT, WE
WILL NEED TO GRAPPLE WITH THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE CORRIDOR IN
TERMS OF OWNERSHIP OPERATIONS
AND SUSCEPTIBILITY TO CLIMATE
CHANGE. SO IN TERMS OF THE
CALIFORNIA INTERCITY PASSENGER
RAIL PROGRAM, MR. JEWELL TALKED
ABOUT THIS EARLIER. I'LL TALK
ABOUT IT A LITTLE BIT MORE FROM
THE STATE SIDE. CALTRANS
ADMINISTERS CALIFORNIA'S
INTERCITY PASSENGER RAIL
PROGRAM, WHICH IS FUNDED BY THE
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION ACCOUNT.
THE JPAS CONTRACT WITH AMTRAK TO
OPERATE THE PACIFIC SURFLINER,
THE SAN JOAQUINS AND THE CAPITOL
CORRIDOR SERVICES, AND THEY ALSO
CONTRACT WITH AMTRAK TO OPERATE
AND MAINTAIN THE STATE OWNED
FLEET. EACH YEAR, EACH OF THE
JPAS SUBMITS A DRAFT ANNUAL
BUSINESS PLAN TO CALTRANS FOR
REVIEW, AND THE ANNUAL BUSINESS
PLAN DESCRIBES HOW THE JPAS PLAN
TO USE STATE FUNDING TO OPERATE,
ADMINISTER, AND MARKET PASSENGER
RAIL SERVICES. THOSE BUSINESS
PLANS ALSO OUTLINE PROJECTS AND
SERVICE EXPANSIONS AND CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENTS WITHIN THE CORRIDOR
AND THEN FINALLY, THE FINAL STEP
EACH YEAR IS WHEN THE ESTÁ
SECRETARY SIGNS THE BUSINESS
PLAN APPROVAL LETTER FOR THE
JPA, RELEASING THE FUNDING FOR
THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR. IN TERMS
OF FLEET PLANNING AND ZERO
EMISSION, CALTRANS HAS A FEW KEY
ROLES AS WELL. WE PROCURE AND
OAN FLEET FOR THE INTERCITY
PASSENGER RAIL PROGRAM. CALTRANS
LEADS FLEET PLANNING AND
COORDINATION WITH OUR INTERCITY
PASSENGER RAIL JPAS AND THE
DIVISION OF RAIL PRODUCES A
FLEET MANAGEMENT PLAN, AND WE'VE
PRODUCED A ZERO EMISSION
STRATEGY FOR INTERCITY PASSENGER
RAIL, WHICH SUPPLEMENTS THE
STATE RAIL PLAN. OTHER CALTRANS
FLEET RESPONSIBILITIES. IN
COORDINATION WITH OUR JPA
PARTNERS INCLUDE. FLEET
DEPLOYMENT PLANNING. HOW ARE WE
GOING TO USE CAR NUMBER 8305
NEXT WEEK VERSUS THE LONG TERM
PROCUREMENT PLAN? WE ALSO DO
STATE OF GOOD REPAIR EFFORTS FOR
THE LEGACY FLEET, AND WE MANAGE
CURRENT AND FUTURE PROCUREMENTS,
AS WELL AS GRANT APPLICATIONS TO
FUND PROJECTS TO ACCOMPLISH
THESE RESPONSIBILITIES AND
ENSURE EFFECTIVE COMMUNICATION
WITH OUR PARTNERS, CALTRANS
LEADS WEEKLY FLEET PLANNING
WORKING GROUPS WITH THE JPAS AND
FLEET PLANNING OF COURSE, WILL
BE A CRITICAL COMPONENT OF THE
CORRIDOR ID PROGRAM TO ENSURE
THAT FUTURE FLEET MEETS OUR
FUTURE NEEDS. I WANT TO TALK FOR
A MOMENT ABOUT SOME OF THE
INNOVATION AND LEADERSHIP THAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, AND AT CALTRANS,
SPECIFICALLY IN TERMS OF FLEET.
WE LEAD SEVERAL INDUSTRY WIDE
WORKING GROUPS, AND WE SERVE AS
A CENTER OF EXCELLENCE FOR
INNOVATION IN PASSENGER RAIL,
ROLLING STOCK TECHNOLOGY. THE
RAIL FLEET CONSORTIUM BEGAN IN
2020 AND BRINGS TOGETHER OVER 25
AGENCIES ACROSS THE US AND
CANADA TO FOSTER COLLABORATION
AND KNOWLEDGE SHARING ON FLEET
RELATED TOPICS. THE ZERO
EMISSION WORKING GROUP GREW OUT
OF THE RAIL FLEET, GREW OUT OF
THE RAIL FLEET CONSORTIUM, AND
FOCUSES ON ZERO EMISSION
PASSENGER RAIL TRANSITION
EFFORTS ACROSS NORTH AMERICA. WE
ALSO LEAD THE PLATFORM TRAIN
INTERFACE WORKING GROUP, WHICH
WAS ESTABLISHED TO DEVELOP A
PLAN FOR THE FUTURE OF LEVEL
BOARDING IN CALIFORNIA, WHICH IS
KEY TO IMPROVING NOT ONLY ON
TIME PERFORMANCE BECAUSE OF
SHORT DWELL TIMES, BUT TO ENSURE
THAT THE RAIL SYSTEM IS
ACCESSIBLE TO ALL. WE'VE
DEVELOPED A ZERO EMISSION
STRATEGY AS WELL, BUILDING OFF
OF THE WORK DONE IN THE ZERO
EMISSION WORKING GROUP, CALTRANS
PUBLISHED OUR INTERCITY
PASSENGER RAIL ZERO EMISSION
STRATEGY IN 2022. THE STRATEGY
IS A RESPONSE TO EXECUTIVE ORDER
IN 7920, AND OUTLINES A PLAN TO
TRANSITION THE INTERCITY RAIL
FLEET FROM DIESEL TO 100% ZERO
EMISSIONS BY 2035. GUIDED BY THE
STRATEGY, CALTRANS IS PROCURING
THE FIRST ZERO EMISSION TRAIN
SETS FOR LONGER DISTANCE
SERVICES, WHICH WILL ENTER
SERVICE IN THE NORTHERN, CENTRAL
VALLEY IN 2029. WE ARE ALSO
SUPPORTING CALTRANS PROJECT TO
DEVELOP A HYBRID BATTERY
OVERHEAD ELECTRIC TRAIN, WHICH
WILL EXTEND THE BENEFITS OF
CALTRANS ZERO EMISSION SERVICE
SOUTH OF SAN JOSE TO GILROY. AND
THROUGH THESE INVESTMENTS IN
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT,
CALIFORNIA IS LEADING THE RAIL
INDUSTRY TO AN EVEN CLEANER
FUTURE. AND FINALLY, A FEW
RECENT ACTIVITIES. WE HAVE
DEPLOYED 24 TIER FOUR CHARGER
LOCOMOTIVES SINCE 2017, AND AS
OF 2023, OUR ENTIRE FLEET FLEET
HAS BEEN CONVERTED TO RENEWABLE
DIESEL AND WE ARE CURRENTLY IN
THE PROCESS OF PROCURING 49
SIEMENS VENTURE RAIL CARS MADE
HERE IN SACRAMENTO THAT WILL
OPERATE IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
FULL DEPLOYMENT OF THE VENTURE
RAIL CAR FLEET WILL ALLOW US TO
MOVE ADDITIONAL EQUIPMENT TO THE
PACIFIC SURFLINER AND CAPITOL
CORRIDOR TO ACCOMMODATE
RIDERSHIP GROWTH ON THOSE
SERVICES, AND WE'LL BEGIN
REDEPLOYING COACHES TO THE
CAPITOL CORRIDOR AND PACIFIC
SURFLINER THIS YEAR. AND BY NEXT
SUMMER, THE PACIFIC SURFLINER
FLEET WILL INCREASE FROM 8 TO
10. TRAIN CONSISTS FOR PACIFIC
SURFLINER, AS WELL AS AN
ADDITIONAL CONCEPT WE'VE MADE
AVAILABLE FOR EMERGENCIES AND
SPECIAL EVENTS, SUCH AS THE 2028
OLYMPICS, THE SUPER BOWL, THE
WORLD CUP AND COMIC-CON. THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS, AND I
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NOW WE HAVE
MR. SHUANG.
THIS IS WIENER. OKAY.
SO THERE IT IS ON THE BOTTOM.
YEAH GREAT. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. SO GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
AND SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS. I'M
CARL SHUANG. I'M THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION. I
SERVE AS THE DISTRICT DIRECTOR
OVERSEEING THE COMMISSION. SAN
DIEGO COAST DISTRICT OFFICE AND
THE ORANGE COUNTY PORTION OF OUR
LONG BEACH OFFICE, THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN THIS
PANEL TODAY AND SPEAK ABOUT THE
COASTAL COMMISSION'S WORK IN SAN
DIEGO AND ORANGE COUNTY,
PORTIONS OF THE LOW SAN CORRIDOR.
AT YOUR APRIL HEARING, OUR
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR, KATE
HUCKLEBERRY, PROVIDED THE
SUBCOMMITTEE WITH AN OVERVIEW OF
OUR AGENCY'S OPERATIONS, IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME AND GETTING
INTO DETAILS, I'LL JUST BRIEFLY
RECAP THAT THE COASTAL
COMMISSION IS CHARGED WITH
PROTECTING AND ENHANCING
CALIFORNIA'S COAST FOR PRESENT
AND FUTURE GENERATIONS. THE
COMMISSION IMPLEMENTS THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL ACT, WHICH
CONTAINS BROAD POLICIES INTENDED
TO GUIDE PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT ALONG CALIFORNIA'S
COASTAL ZONE, WHICH YOU CAN SEE
ON THE MAP IN RED. THE COASTAL
ACT CONTAINS POLICIES FOR A WIDE
ARRAY OF TOPICS AND A FEW OF THE
EXAMPLES ARE LISTED ON THE SLIDE.
TRANSLATING THESE BROAD POLICIES
INTO CONCRETE PROJECTS IS A
PROCESS THE COMMISSION
FACILITATES TO ENSURE
DEVELOPMENT PROPOSALS REFLECT
OUR STATE, COASTAL POLICIES.
THIS SLIDE PORTRAYS THAT PROCESS
GOING FROM GENERAL TO SPECIFIC.
IT BEGINS WITH THE COASTAL
POLICIES THAT I MENTIONED. THESE
POLICIES BEGIN TO BE FLESHED OUT
IN GUIDANCE DOCUMENTS, WHICH THE
COMMISSION PRODUCES ON A VARIETY
OF TOPICS IN COORDINATION WITH
OUR STATE AND LOCAL PARTNERS.
INCIDENTALLY, THE COMMISSION IS
CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS OF
UPDATING ITS SEA LEVEL RISE
POLICY GUIDANCE TO REFLECT
CALIFORNIA'S LATEST SEA LEVEL
RISE PROJECTIONS, WHICH WERE
PUBLISHED BY THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL EARLIER THIS
YEAR. THE COMMISSION'S DRAFT
GUIDANCE IS PICTURED HERE. IT'S
CURRENTLY OUT FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT, AND YOU CAN FIND A LINK
TO THE DRAFT GUIDANCE IN THE
MATERIALS FOR THE HEARING. THE
COMMISSION AND ITS PARTNERS DRAW
FROM COASTAL ACT POLICIES AND
STATE POLICY GUIDANCES TO INFORM
PLANNING DOCUMENTS FOR SPECIFIC
COASTAL JURISDICTIONS. ONE OF
THE COMMISSION'S KEY FUNCTIONS
IS TO ASSIST LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
IN DEVELOPING LOCAL COASTAL
PROGRAMS OR LCP'S. LCP ARE THE
PLANNING FRAMEWORK BY WHICH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN THE COASTAL
ZONE IMPLEMENT THE COASTAL ACT
WITHIN THEIR JURISDICTION, AND
THEY CONTAIN SPECIFIC LAND USE
POLICIES AND ORDINANCES THAT
GUIDE COASTAL DEVELOPMENT IN
COASTAL JURISDICTIONS WITH A
CERTIFIED LCP, THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT APPROVES PERMITS FOR
PROJECTS CONSISTENT WITH THE LCP
AND THE COMMISSION ACTS AS THE
PERMITTING AUTHORITY IN
UNCERTIFIED AREAS AS WELL AS IN
CERTAIN STATE RESOURCE AREAS
SUCH AS STATE TIDELANDS, IN THE
LATE 1990S, FOLLOWING SEVERAL
SERIOUS EROSION EVENTS THAT
THREATENED THE TRACKS AND
REQUIRED STABILIZATION MEASURES,
NCTD LAUNCHED A STUDY OF THE
RAIL CORRIDOR ALONG THE DEL MAR
BLUFFS TO LOOK AT
VULNERABILITIES AND IDENTIFY
APPROPRIATE RESPONSES. SINCE
THAT TIME, THE COMMISSION HAS
ISSUED A SERIES OF APPROVALS TO
NCTD AND SANDAG FOR VARIOUS
STABILIZATION MEASURES ALONG
THIS PORTION OF THE LOW SAND
CORRIDOR. THE MOST RECENT OF
THESE, THE DEL MAR BLUFFS
STABILIZATION PROJECT, FIVE, WAS
AUTHORIZED BY THE COMMISSION IN
2022. THIS PROJECT INCLUDED
CONSTRUCTION OF BLUFF
STABILIZATION STRUCTURES
COMPRISED OF SEAWALLS, CAISSONS,
AND VARIOUS IMPROVEMENTS TO
DRAINAGE INFRASTRUCTURE. SANDAG
ALSO DESIGNED THE PROJECT TO
MAINTAIN AND ENHANCE COASTAL
HABITAT AND THE PUBLIC'S ACCESS
TO THE BEACH ALONG THE PROJECT
AREA. THE PERMIT AUTHORIZES THE
ARMORING ELEMENTS FOR A 30 YEAR
TERM, WHICH IS UNTIL 2052. THIS
FINITE TERM IS WITH THE
RECOGNITION THAT SANDAG IS
CURRENTLY EVALUATING
ALTERNATIVES TO RELOCATE. THIS
SEGMENT OF THE RAIL LINE INLAND,
AND 30 YEARS PROVIDES ADEQUATE
TIME AND A CUSHION TO
ACCOMMODATE SANDAG'S. CURRENT
TIMELINE FOR RELOCATION,
PLANNING AND CONSTRUCTION.
SANDAG'S COMMITMENT TO RAIL
RELOCATION HERE WAS A PIVOTAL
DECISION, INITIALLY TO KEEP THE
TRACKS IN PLACE FOR A LONGER
PERIOD. SANDAG WAS CONSIDERING
LARGER WALLS AND STABILIZATION
MEASURES THAT WOULD HAVE HAD
MAJOR IMPACTS TO COASTAL ACCESS
AND VIEWS ALONG THESE BLUFFS AND
BEACHES. THE COMMITMENT TO
RELOCATION BY 2035 ALLOWED FOR
LESS GRADING OF THE BLUFFS AND
SMALLER SEAWALLS THAT ARE
DESIGNED TO BE REMOVED. ONCE THE
RAIL LINE HAS BEEN RELOCATED.
THE COMMISSION'S REGULATORY
ACTIONS AT DEL MAR BLUFFS HAVE
BEEN DESIGNED TO ALLOW FOR
ARMORING NECESSARY TO
ACCOMMODATE THE NEAR-TERM NEEDS
OF THE RAIL CORRIDOR, WHILE
SPURRING CONCRETE PLANNING FOR
FUTURE RELOCATION, WHICH THE
COMMISSION SEES AS NECESSARY FOR
THE LONG TERM FUNCTION OF THE
RAIL LINE, AS WELL AS THE
PUBLIC'S CONTINUED ACCESS TO
THIS REGION OF THE COAST.
SHIFTING NORTHWARD TO SAN
CLEMENTE. AS THIS COMMITTEE IS
WELL AWARE, THERE ARE SEVERAL
EMERGENCY HOT SPOTS ALONG THE
SAN CLEMENTE SEGMENT OF THE
CORRIDOR. OVER THE PAST YEAR,
THE COMMISSION HAS ACTED QUICKLY
TO AUTHORIZE EMERGENCY WORK
NECESSARY TO KEEP THE RAIL LINE
FUNCTIONING SAFELY. THESE
EMERGENCY AUTHORIZATIONS WILL
REQUIRE FOLLOW UP PERMITS, AND
THOSE PERMITS PRESENT AN
OPPORTUNITY TO IMPLEMENT MORE
LONG TERM PROGRAMMATIC
ADAPTATION ADAPTATION STRATEGIES.
THE COMMISSION IS CURRENTLY
WORKING WITH TO FILE CDP
APPLICATIONS FOR THE BLUFF AND
SHORELINE STABILIZATION MEASURES
AT CYPRESS SHORES AND MARIPOSA
POINT. ONCE PROBLEMS STARTED IN
2021, COMMISSION AND STAFF BEGAN
MEETING REGULARLY TO COORDINATE
OUR WORK ON THEIR RESILIENCY
PLAN AND HAVE INCREASED THE
FREQUENCY OF THOSE MEETINGS. AS
A WORK ON THAT PLAN HAS RAMPED
UP. THAT PLAN TO PROTECT THE
RAIL AND NOURISH THE BEACHES
SEAWARD OF THE RAIL INCLUDES
LOOKING FOR SAND SOURCES,
ASSESSING POTENTIAL SAND
DELIVERY METHODS AND PREPARING A
COMPREHENSIVE ALTERNATIVES
ANALYSIS TO BE SUBMITTED WITH
THE FUTURE CDP APPLICATION. AND
WE ARE EXPECTING THAT
APPLICATION TO ARRIVE IN THE
NEXT COUPLE OF WEEKS. IT'S ALSO
WORTH ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THE
CITY OF SAN CLEMENTE DOES DOES
NOT HAVE A CERTIFIED LCP, THOUGH
THEY ARE WORKING ON DEVELOPING
ONE. WHILE SOME LOW SAND
PROJECTS ALONG THE SAN CLEMENTE
COAST ARE SQUARELY WITHIN THE
COMMISSION'S JURISDICTION AS
THEY ARE LOCATED ON STATE
TIDELANDS, IF THE CITY COMPLETED
ITS LCP, THERE WOULD BE FUTURE
RESILIENCY PROJECTS THAT COULD
BE PERMITTED DIRECTLY BY THE
CITY, AND I'LL HAVE POSITIVE
NEWS ON THAT FRONT IN JUST A
MOMENT. AS FAR AS NEAR-TERM
PRIORITIES AT DEL MAR, AS NOTED
BEFORE, THE COMMISSION APPROVED
ARMORING SUFFICIENT TO PROTECT
THE TRACKS IN DEL MAR WHILE
RELOCATION IS BEING PLANNED AND
IMPLEMENTED, SOME IMPACTS TO
COASTAL ACCESS WERE ANTICIPATED
IN THAT PLAN, BUT COMMISSION
STAFF ARE CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH SANDAG AND THE CITY TO FILL
IN DETAILS THAT STILL NEED
REFINEMENT, SUCH AS WHERE AND
HOW TO ESTABLISH A SAFE TRACK
CROSSING AT THE SAME TIME,
COMMISSION STAFF ARE MEETING
REGULARLY WITH SANDAG TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL AND POLICY INPUT. AS
SANDAG EVALUATES ALTERNATIVE
ALIGNMENTS FOR THE TRACK
RELOCATION. WE'RE ALSO
COORDINATING WITH PARTNERS IN
SAN CLEMENTE THROUGH THE
PLANNING, THOUGH THE PLANNING
NEEDS ARE DIFFERENT. JUST LAST
MONTH, THE COMMISSION, THROUGH
ITS LCP GRANT PROGRAM, AWARDED
$1.5 MILLION PLANNING GRANT TO
THE CITY, AND THAT GRANT WILL
SUPPORT MULTIPLE EFFORTS
CRITICAL TO THE LOW SAND
CORRIDOR. SPECIFICALLY, THE CITY
INTENDS TO USE GRANT FUNDS TO
COMPLETE THEIR LOCAL COASTAL
PROGRAM SO THAT THEY CAN
DIRECTLY ISSUE PERMITS IN THE
COASTAL ZONE. THE CITY ALSO
INTENDS TO USE GRANT FUNDS TO
IDENTIFY SAND SOURCES TO SUPPORT
THE DEVELOPMENT OF A REGIONAL
SCALE, NATURE BASED BEACH
RESTORATION PROGRAM INVOLVING
COMPREHENSIVE BEACH SAND
REPLENISHMENT AND SAND RETENTION
PROJECTS. AND FINALLY, THE CITY
WILL USE THE GRANT FUNDING TO
COMPLETE COMMUNITY SCALE SEA
LEVEL RISE ADAPTATION PLANNING,
WHICH WOULD BE INCORPORATED INTO
THE CITY'S LCP. COORDINATION
BETWEEN THE CITY AND IS NEEDED
HERE AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE, SO
THAT THESE EFFORTS PROVIDE THE
GREATEST BENEFITS. AT THE SAME
TIME, WE'RE WORKING WITH TO
REFINE AS THEY REFINE THEIR
COASTAL RAIL RESILIENCY PLAN TO
IDENTIFY THE MOST VULNERABLE
PARTS OF THE TRACK IN SAN
CLEMENTE, AND TO TAILOR THE WORK
PROPOSED SUCH THAT IMPACTS TO
COASTAL RESOURCES ARE MINIMIZED.
AS WITH DEL MAR, THE TERM OF
APPROVAL NEEDED TO SUPPORT THE
TRACKS WILL BE IMPORTANT, AS
THAT WILL INFORM THE TYPE AND
EXTENT OF SHORELINE PROTECTION.
TYPICALLY, THE LONGER THE TRACKS
REMAIN IN PLACE, THE WIDER AND
TALLER THE SEAWALLS WOULD NEED
TO BE TO PROTECT THEM, AND THE
LARGER THE MEASURES NEED TO
MITIGATE IMPACTS TO PUBLIC
COASTAL ACCESS. EARLIER
RELOCATION OF THE TRACKS WOULD
HELP AVOID IMPACTS AND REDUCE
THE AMOUNT OF INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDED IN THIS HAZARDOUS AREA OF
THE COAST. INVESTING IN BEACH
NOURISHMENT AND SIMILAR PROJECTS
WILL ALSO BUFFER THE TRACKS FROM
WAVE HAZARDS AND REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF HARD ARMORING THAT IS
NEEDED, WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY
IMPROVING BEACH ACCESS,
RECREATION AND HABITAT. SO
COLLECTIVELY, THE POINTS ON THAT
SLIDE REPRESENT THE PRIORITY
ACTIONS THE COMMISSION STAFF
BELIEVES ARE NECESSARY TO
ACHIEVE IN THE NEAR TERM. TO
ENSURE THE CONTINUED VIABILITY
OF BOTH THE RAIL LINE AND OUR
PUBLIC BEACHES IN THE LONG TERM.
WHILE THE WORK WE HAVE, WHILE
THE WORK WILL BE SIGNIFICANT, WE
BELIEVE THAT MANY IMPORTANT
PLANNING EFFORTS HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED, SCOPED AND STARTED.
THE COMMISSION WILL CONTINUE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH OUR STATE
AND REGIONAL AND LOCAL PARTNERS
TO COMPLETE THAT WORK AND
TOGETHER WE CAN SHAPE A FUTURE
FOR THE LOW SAND CORRIDOR THAT
DEMONSTRATES HOW TO RESPONSIBLY
IMPLEMENT COASTAL MANAGEMENT AND
TRANSPORTATION POLICY IN
RESPONSE TO CLIMATE CHANGE. SO
THANK YOU AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. WELL, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTARY FROM THE THREE OF
YOU. AND WE'LL JUST ASK A FEW
QUESTIONS, I WANTED TO START
WITH A QUESTION ABOUT, IT WAS A
QUESTION THAT I POSED TO THE
PREVIOUS PANEL, WHICH I THINK
PROBABLY YOU HEARD, BUT THIS IS
FOR YOU, MR. GRADINGER. IT'S
REALLY ABOUT THE GOAL SETTING.
IF WE HAVE THE STATE RAIL PLAN
WITH HIGH LEVEL GOALS, AND WE
KNOW WE HAVE 1% MODE SHARE ON
RAIL NOW IN THE STATE, AND WE'RE
TRYING TO GET TO 14%. HOW DO YOU
SEE WHAT DO YOU SEE THE STATE'S
ROLE IN SETTING THOSE RIDERSHIP
GOALS? AND WHAT ARE WE DOING TO
MORE AGGRESSIVELY SET GOALS FOR
THE DIFFERENT AGENCIES? BECAUSE
IT REALLY DOES SEEM AS IF THE
THOSE TYPES OF GOALS SHOULD BE
SET AT THE STATE LEVEL. AND I'LL
JUST LOOK OVER ONTO THE CLIMATE
PLANNING IN GENERAL, WHEN WE
LOOK AT EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS AND
THEY'RE VERY SPECIFIC, YOU KNOW,
19% PER CAPITA EMISSIONS
REDUCTION BY 2020 LEVELS. YOU
KNOW, THIS KIND OF THING, WHICH
IS VERY SPECIFIC. SO I'M JUST
CURIOUS ABOUT HOW YOU'RE
CONCEIVING OF THAT AND WHERE YOU
FEEL THAT THAT'S GOING. OKAY.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION. I
THINK ONE OF THE POINTS THAT WAS
MADE ON THE EARLIER PANEL, THAT
IS REALLY IMPORTANT IS THE
AVERAGE TRIP LENGTH OF A TRIP ON
RAIL. I THINK IT WAS SOMETHING
IN THE 30 ODD MILE RANGE FOR A
METROLINK PASSENGER. PASSENGERS
ON INTERCITY PASSENGER RAIL, OUR
AVERAGE TRIP LENGTH IS ABOUT 70
MILES OR SO. SO IF WE TALK ABOUT
TRIPS AS A PERCENTAGE OF ALL
TRIPS, WE'RE AT A VERY LOW
NUMBER. IF WE START TO TALK
ABOUT MILES TRAVELED AS A SHARE
OF ALL TOTAL TRAVEL, WE'RE IN A
BETTER PLACE, BUT WE'RE STILL
NOWHERE NEAR, INTERNATIONAL
NORMS OR WHERE WE NEED TO BE TO
MEET OUR CLIMATE GOALS. THE RAIL
PLAN IS REALLY AMBITIOUS IN
SETTING THESE LONG TERM VISIONS.
WE HAVE A 25 OR 30 YEAR LONG
TERM TIME FRAME, AND I TALKED
ABOUT THAT BEING THE ABILITY TO
SHIFT 178 MILLION PASSENGER
MILES EVERY DAY TO THE RAIL
SYSTEM, WE ARE CREATING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE RAIL PLAN BASED
ON MODELS THAT WE'VE SEEN
ELSEWHERE, WHEN YOU LOOK AT
PLACES LIKE SWITZERLAND, WHERE
THEY ALREADY HAD STRONG RAIL
RIDERSHIP IN THE 1980S, BUT THEY
TOOK A LOT OF THESE FEATURES
THAT WERE DESCRIBED EARLIER,
REGULAR PULSE SCHEDULES,
PROMISING, YOU KNOW, THE ABILITY
TO HAVE A TRAIN SHOW UP IN EVERY
VILLAGE OF A POPULATION ABOVE,
YOU KNOW, X EVERY HALF AN HOUR,
EVERY 60 MINUTES OR SO. AND, AND
THEY SET THAT LONG TERM VISION
AND SAID, WE CAN SHIFT TRAVEL,
BUT WE HAVE TO HAVE THE
INVESTMENT PLAN TO DO THAT. SO
THE VISION WAS THERE. THEY
MATCHED IT WITH THE SERVICE PLAN
WHERE THE TRAIN IS GOING TO GO
AND WHEN ARE THEY GOING TO GO
AND WHEN YOU KNOW THAT AND WHEN
YOU GET CONSENSUS AROUND THAT,
YOU CAN BEGIN TO DESIGN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS AND THE
ROLLING STOCK PROCUREMENTS AND
THINK ABOUT THE OPERATING
SUPPORT NEEDED IN ORDER TO
DELIVER THAT SERVICE. IT CAN'T
BE DONE OVERNIGHT. THERE ARE
THERE ARE THINGS, YOU KNOW, THE
OCTOBER METROLINK SERVICE
IMPROVEMENTS ARE DOING WHAT THEY
CAN WITH THE EXISTING RESOURCES
CRUISE, TRAIN AVAILABILITY,
TRACK CAPACITY, BUT IF YOU LOOK
AT IT, A 30 YEAR TIME FRAME AND
YOU SAY, HERE'S THE VISION,
HERE'S WHERE WE NEED TO GET, YOU
CAN THEN WORK BACKWARDS TO
IDENTIFY WHAT ARE THOSE
INCREMENTS, WHAT ARE THE
PROJECTS WE CAN DO NOW? WHAT ARE
THE PROJECTS WE NEED TO DO IN
THE 5 TO 10 YEAR TIME FRAME? AND
WHAT ARE THOSE STRETCH PROJECTS?
WHAT ARE WHAT ARE THE
TRANS-HUDSON TUNNELS OR THE
MEGAPROJECTS THAT ARE GOING TO
COME LATER ON AND, AND BEGIN TO
IDENTIFY THOSE, SO I THINK WHAT
WE'VE DONE IN THE LAST RAIL
PLAN, 2018 IS WHEN WE SET THAT
VISION FOR, FOR WHAT WE WANT TO,
WHERE WE WANT TO BE, WHAT WE
NEED TO DO NOW AND WILL BE
RELEASING THE NEXT RAIL PLAN
UPDATE IN THE NEXT MONTH OR SO,
IS WE REALLY NEED TO GET INTO
THE HOW ARE WE GOING TO GET
THERE? AND I THINK THE CAPITAL
I'M SORRY, THE CORRIDOR ID
PROGRAM IS GOING TO BE VERY
HELPFUL. IT'S FOCUSED ON THE
INTERCITY SIDE, BUT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A WHOLE NETWORK OF
COMMUTER, INTERCITY AND HIGH
SPEED RAIL. BUT I THINK THAT SO
MANY MILES OF THE COMMUTER
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA ARE EITHER
OPERATED ON INTERCITY CORRIDORS
OR HAVE TIGHT CONNECTIONS TO
INTERCITY SERVICES. I THINK THIS
GIVES US THE ABILITY WITH THE
FEDS TO LOOK AT AND BE HONEST
AND AMBITIOUS ABOUT WHAT ARE
THOSE CAPITAL PROJECTS TO GET US
TO GROWTH. MAYBE WE HAVE TO
BREAK IT OUT INTO FIVE, TEN, 15,
20 YEAR TIME PERIODS. BUT WE'VE
GOT TO START SOMEWHERE. AND I
THINK CIDP LETS US TAP INTO
THAT. THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WAS
NOT AT THE TABLE AFTER THE
STIMULUS, AND FY10 FY11 HAS KIND
OF DISAPPEARED. THEY'RE BACK. WE
STEPPED UP AND INVESTED A LOT.
BUT IF WE CAN LEVERAGE THAT
STATE INVESTMENT WITH NEW 80%
FEDERAL MATCHES GOING FORWARD, I
THINK THAT'S GOING TO HELP US
GET A LOT OF THE TRACTION THAT
WE NEED TO GET TO WHERE WE NEED
TO GO WITH THE STATE RAIL PLAN,
VISION. OKAY, GREAT. AND THEN
COULD YOU JUST ADDRESS THE ZERO
EMISSION GOALS AND YOU MENTIONED
SEVERAL DIFFERENT, INVESTMENTS,
BUT THEY'RE NOT ON THIS CORRIDOR.
SO YOU KNOW, WHAT IS THE THOUGHT
ON WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN WITH
CATENARY? OR IS THERE ANY
ANALYSIS OF EVEN IT BEING ON
PORTIONS OF THE LOW SAND
CORRIDOR AND MAYBE NOT ALL OF
IT, AND HYDROGEN AND THAT. SO
WHAT IS THE THOUGHT AROUND THAT.
YEAH. SO IN THE CALTRANS
INTERCITY PASSENGER RAIL ZERO
EMISSION STRATEGY, WE LOOKED AT
ALL OF THE POTENTIAL
TECHNOLOGIES. AND WE DID THIS
REPORT ABOUT THREE YEARS AGO.
AND EVEN IN THE THREE YEARS
SINCE THEN, A LOT OF THE
TECHNOLOGIES HAVE MATURED OR
FADED AWAY, BUT WE LOOKED AT
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL COUPLED WITH
BATTERIES. SO A TOYOTA PRIUS
WITH HYDROGEN INSTEAD OF GAS,
BATTERY ELECTRIC TRAINS OVERHEAD
CATENARY. AND WE LOOKED AT ALL
OF THOSE OPTIONS. AND WHAT WE
DECIDED WAS THAT FOR THE
IMMEDIATE NEEDS THAT FOR VALLEY
RAIL AND SOME OF THE PROJECTS
THAT WE HAVE, WE THOUGHT THAT
HYDROGEN IS THE BEST SOLUTION
FOR THOSE. SO WE ARE GOING WITH
THE HYDROGEN FUEL CELL HYBRID
TRAIN, SIMILAR TO WHAT SBCTA IS
ABOUT TO ROLL OUT, TO IMPROVE
SERVICE IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
BETWEEN SACRAMENTO AND MERCED
AND TO PROVIDE A GOOD CONNECTION
TO HIGH SPEED RAIL WHEN IT
ARRIVES. BUT THERE ARE OTHER
PLACES IN THE STATE WHERE OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES COULD CERTAINLY
SHINE. WE KALISTA AND INVESTED
IN, AND CALTRANS IS SUPPORTING A
CALTRAIN PROJECT TO TAKE ONE OF
THEIR NEW ELECTRIC TRAINS AND TO
PUT BASICALLY CREATE A BATTERY
CAR SO THEY CAN CHARGE THAT
BATTERY WHILE THEY'RE UNDER THE
WIRE BETWEEN SAN FRANCISCO AND
SAN JOSE. AND THEN CONTINUE WITH
CLEAN BATTERY PROPULSION ALL THE
WAY DOWN TO GILROY, THERE ARE
LIMITATIONS ON BATTERIES IN
TERMS OF RANGE, AND ESPECIALLY
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE WEIGHT
OF A TRAIN. BUT THAT COULD BE A
VERY PROMISING TECHNOLOGY FOR
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA FOR THIS
CORRIDOR. IF HIGH SPEED RAIL
MAKES IT TO, I SHOULD SAY, WHEN
HIGH SPEED RAIL MAKES IT TO
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA, THERE WILL
HAVE TO BE ELECTRIFICATION
BETWEEN BURBANK AND ANAHEIM. AND
THAT GIVES YOU A GOOD 40, 50, 60
MILE STRETCH WHERE WE COULD HAVE
A TRAIN FUNCTION ON THE SAME
PRINCIPLE CHARGE UP WHILE UNDER
THE WIRE, AND THEN CONTINUE ON,
PERHAPS DOWN TO THE MARINE BASE
IN YOUR DISTRICT, WHERE WE MIGHT
BE ABLE TO GET MORE WIRE AND
THEN GET INTO SAN DIEGO. SO
WE'RE LOOKING AT OPPORTUNITIES
LIKE THAT. WE DID LOOK AT THE
COST OF ELECTRIFICATION AND THE
FEASIBILITY OF ELECTRIFICATION.
AND WHILE BRIGHT LINE AND HIGH
SPEED RAIL HAVE TO DO IT BECAUSE
OF THE SPEED OF THEIR TRAINS AND
PHYSICS, THEY'RE ALSO
CONSTRUCTING CATENARY ON A, ON A
GREENFIELD LOCATION AND
CONSTRUCTING CATENARY ON AN
UNDER TRAFFIC ON SOMEONE ELSE'S
RAILROAD CREATES A LOT OF
HURDLES. IT IS. I'VE SAID IT
BEFORE, ELECTRIFICATION IS THE
GOLD STANDARD, BUT THERE ARE A
LOT OF OBSTACLES. COST
PERMITTING, OWNERSHIP IN THE
WAY. AND WE DID AN ANALYSIS OF
THE STATE SUPPORTED INTERCITY
PASSENGER RAIL CORRIDORS, SAN
JOAQUIN CAPITOL CORRIDOR AND
SURFLINER, AND THE COST TO
ELECTRIFY THOSE CORRIDORS ALONE
WAS $7 BILLION. AND WE ARE
PROCURING THE ZERO EMISSION
FLEET THAT, YOU KNOW, AT $20
MILLION PER TRAIN, WOULD BE ABLE
TO OPERATE ON HYDROGEN FUEL
CELLS. SO THAT'S SOME OF THE
TRADE OFF THINKING THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT. AND AGAIN, THAT'S ON
UNION PACIFIC AND BNSF. SO THAT
COMPLICATES THINGS AS WELL OKAY.
THANK YOU, SENATOR LAMONT I
THINK HAS A QUESTION OR SAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, AND I
APPRECIATE THE INFORMATION. I'M
GOING TO MAYBE SHIFT US JUST A
LITTLE BIT, WE STARTED OUT WITH
SAFETY AND LÀ. YOU KNOW, I HAVE
TO THANK THE CHAIR BECAUSE THE
CHAIR HAS REALLY DONE INCREDIBLE
WORK. I THINK, IN OUR
LEGISLATURE RELATED TO THE LOW
SUN AND JUST THE CORRIDOR
ALTOGETHER. AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT SHE'S DONE IS SHE
ORGANIZED A SERIES OF VISITS.
AND I GOT TO DO ONE OF THE
VISITS LAST FALL. I THINK IT WAS
LAST OCTOBER. AND, YOU KNOW,
BEING GROUNDED AND SEEING THINGS
WITH OUR OWN EYES, WE ALSO
SOMETIMES SEE THINGS THAT WE
MAYBE DIDN'T THINK OF OR, YOU
KNOW, THAT WE HADN'T BEEN
FOLLOWING. AND ONE OF THE THINGS
WHEN I WAS IN HER DISTRICT THAT
I GOT TO SEE WAS, A SAFETY SIGN
THAT WAS PUT UP, IT WAS RELATED
TO SUICIDE PREVENTION. I SAW IT,
IT RESONATED IN MY DISTRICT, AND
I TOOK A PICTURE OF IT. AND LAST
OCTOBER, I STARTED A PROCESS TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET
THESE UP ALONG OUR CORRIDORS AND,
IT IS AUGUST. ALMOST NOT QUITE A
YEAR, BUT, IT'S ALMOST A YEAR
SINCE I STARTED THIS PROCESS.
AND I'M SORRY THAT, YOU KNOW,
DIRECTOR JUUL IS NOT HERE FOR
THIS EITHER. I HAVE MYSELF MADE
PHONE CALLS. MY TEAM HAS SENT
EMAILS, AND I'VE BEEN STRUCK
WITH HOW DIFFICULT IT HAS BEEN
TO GET A SIGN THAT WE HAVE UP IN
CERTAIN PARTS OF THE CORRIDOR,
AND IN THE MEANTIME, WE HAVE HAD
TWO INCIDENTS, ONE WAS A
SUICIDE, ONE IS INVESTIGATED AS
AN INCIDENT, WHERE WE HAVE LOST
LIVES AND MAYBE TWO DOESN'T
SOUND LIKE A BIG NUMBER, BUT TO
THE PARENTS, THE FAMILIES, THE
SCHOOLS, THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND COMMUNITY THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY THE LOSS OF LIVES ON
OUR RAIL, IT IS A LOT. AND BOTH
OF THESE INCIDENTS HAVE BEEN
VERY PUBLIC IN THE DISTRICT, AND
I AM LOOKING TO EITHER FIRST
PANEL, SECOND PANEL TO HELP ME
FIGURE OUT WHAT IS THE
LEGISLATOR NEED TO DO TO BE ABLE
TO ACCOMPLISH, APPROPRIATE
SIGNAGE, SAFETY SIGNAGE, TO BE
ABLE TO, YOU KNOW, IMPACT A
DISTRICT. AND THIS ISN'T A DING.
THIS IS A TRUE QUESTION. LIKE, I
DON'T KNOW, I'M JUST CURIOUS.
LIKE WHAT? THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY. YOU KNOW, I KNOW,
YOU KNOW, DIRECTOR, YOU DO A LOT
IN SAFETY AND SOME OF IT IS A
LOT MORE ON THE, YOU KNOW,
SAFETY OF THE PHYSICAL SAFETY OF
THE RAIL ITSELF. BUT LIKE, I'M
TRYING TO THINK OF THE HUMAN
ASPECT HERE, BUT I AM A LITTLE
BIT AT A LOSS AND I ALSO
QUESTION, WELL, WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN? IF A LEGISLATOR WITH A
TEAM THAT'S LOOKING AT THIS IS
HAVING YOU KNOW, A YEARS LONG
PROCESS, LIKE WHAT ARE WE DOING
WRONG, AND, YOU KNOW, AND HOW DO
WE AFFECT SOME OF THIS CHANGE
ALONG THE CORRIDOR, THIS TO ME,
SEEMS LIKE A MINOR THING
BECAUSE, I MEAN, WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT MUCH BIGGER PROJECTS, BUT
I'M LOOKING FOR ASSISTANCE AND
HELP, AND JUST FEEDBACK ON HOW
WE CAN BETTER DO THIS. AND
AGAIN, THIS IS NOT I SAY THIS,
YOU KNOW, THIS QUESTION IS POSED
WITH UTMOST RESPECT. I DON'T DO
THE JOBS THAT YOU ALL DO OR THAT
OTHERS DO, BUT I ACTUALLY JUST
REALLY DON'T KNOW AN ANSWER, AND
SO I'M AT A LOSS SO ANYONE CAN
ANSWER THAT OR FEEDBACK PRIOR.
PANEL CURRENT PANEL. THIS IS THE
SAFETY PANEL. SO ANYONE SITTING
THERE WHO COULD HELP HER. WELL
I, I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING. AND I UNDERSTAND IT AS A
FORMER RAILROAD EMPLOYEE, I'VE
CLEANED UP AFTER MANY SUICIDES
AND MANY TRAIN VERSUS VEHICLE
ACCIDENTS AND THINGS LIKE THAT
OVER THE YEARS. MY STAFF
CURRENTLY WHAT WE DO IS WE
PARTICIPATE WITH OPERATION
LIFESAVER TO TRY TO GET THE WORD
OUT TO PEOPLE ABOUT STAYING AWAY
FROM TRACKS. THEY DO A LOT OF
THIS, VOLUNTEER WORK ON THEIR ON
THEIR OWN TIME. IN SO FAR AS
PREVENTING SUICIDES, WE LIVE IN
A STATE WHERE WE HAVE TO PUT UP
CYCLONE FENCES OVER THE TOP OF
OVERPASSES TO KEEP PEOPLE FROM
JUMPING OFF INTO THE PATH OF AN
ONCOMING TRAIN. SO IT'S
EXTREMELY HARD TO TRY TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT SORT OF WHAT SORT OF
SIGNAGE IS GOING TO WORK TO BE
ABLE TO GET THAT POINT ACROSS
TO, TO PEOPLE. I'VE BEEN TRYING
TO FIGURE THIS OUT MY ENTIRE
LIFE. I'M A THIRD GENERATION
RAILROADER, I THINK TO SOME OF
THE, SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE
THE INNOVATIVE THINGS THAT WE
CAN DO INSOFAR AS TRYING TO
ELIMINATE QUEUING ON AT GRADE
CROSSINGS WHERE PEOPLE ARE
COMPLACENT OR WHERE THEY'VE LOST
THEIR SITUATIONAL AWARENESS, IS
A PROJECT THAT I STARTED, TRYING
TO GET DONE OF WHERE WE ACTUALLY
PAINT THE DYNAMIC ENVELOPE OF A
AT GRADE CROSSING. THE DYNAMIC
ENVELOPE IN A RED AGGREGATE
PAINT THAT IS REFLECTIVE IS
OUTLINED WITH A WHITE LINE TO BE
ABLE TO BRING UP SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS. SO IF THEY START TO
QUÊ, THEY REALIZE I'M NOT
SUPPOSED TO BE HERE. I SHOULD
NOT BE IN THIS LOCATION,
HOWEVER, THOSE THOSE SORTS OF
EFFORTS, IT'S VERY DIFFICULT.
I'VE BEEN TRYING FOR EIGHT YEARS
TO GET THIS DONE, AND YOU RUN UP
ACROSS MANY OBSTACLES. YOU HAVE
TO GET MANY PEOPLE ON BOARD ALL
OF THE STAKEHOLDERS, THE ROADWAY
AUTHORITY, THE RAILROAD, ANYBODY
ELSE THAT'S INVOLVED IN IT. I
WORKED WITH CALTRANS, CALTRANS,
LONG AND HARD TO TRY TO GET ONE
DONE IN ESCALON. BUT BUT NOT TO
DIGRESS FROM THE POINT IS, IS
SUICIDES AND PEOPLE ARE HAVE
DECIDED TO TAKE THAT COURSE.
IT'S A VERY DIFFICULT THING.
ONE, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
DO ALSO IS THAT IN OUR OUTREACH
THROUGH THE PUC, WE GO AND WE
VISIT MUNICIPALITIES AND WE TALK
ABOUT THE 800 POUND GORILLA IN
THE ROOM, WHICH IS HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENTS ALONG RAILROAD
RIGHTS OF WAYS. AND YOU KNOW
WHAT? WHAT CAN WE DO? I HAVE TO
REMEMBER THAT THESE ARE HUMAN
BEINGS AND THAT WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO THEY HAVE TO HAVE A
PLACE TO GO. YOU CAN'T JUST MOVE
THEM AND BE DONE WITH IT. SO IT
IS A VERY DIFFICULT QUESTION.
THERE ARE THERE ARE,
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS OPERATION
LIFESAVER THAT, THAT, THAT DO
REALLY GOOD WORK, BUT BUT AGAIN,
I, I HAVE BEEN MY ENTIRE LIFE
PRETTY MUCH TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THE ANSWER IS TO REDUCING
TRESPASSING AND PEOPLE GETTING
OUT AND STANDING IN FRONT OF
TRAINS TO END THEIR LIVES. AND I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE ANSWER IS.
THANK YOU, MR. CLUGSTON. MAYBE
MR. JEWELL COULD ANSWER YES.
THANK YOU, SENATOR LEMON, FOR
THE QUESTION. AND, YEAH, WE ARE
IN THE PROCESS CURRENTLY OF
LOOKING AT A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
SIGN DESIGNS. IF YOURS THAT YOU
HAD SUBMITTED TO OUR OFFICE IS
ONE OF THEM, I APOLOGIZE. I WILL
GO BACK TO OUR TEAM AND WE'LL
WE'LL MAKE SURE THAT WE REVIEW
THE DESIGN THAT IS THAT HAS BEEN
SUBMITTED. AND IS OF PREFERENCE.
THE CHALLENGE THAT WE FACE IS
THAT WE LOOKED AT SIGN DESIGNS,
FROM ALL ALL ALONG OUR CORRIDOR
AND ESPECIALLY FROM SOME OF OUR
HOST RAILROADS THAT ALREADY
PROVIDE SIGNAGE AT VARIOUS
LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT OUR
CORRIDOR. AND EVERYONE HAS A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT MESSAGE ON
THE SIGN. AND SO WE WERE REALLY
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT THE BEST
DESIGN FOR BOTH THE SAFETY
MESSAGING AND POSSIBLY THE
MENTAL HEALTH SUICIDE PREVENTION
MESSAGING. WE ARE NOT EXPERTS IN
THAT AREA, YOU KNOW, SO WE WERE
ACTUALLY LOOKING AT FIGURING OUT
WAYS THAT WE COULD REACH OUT TO
THOSE EXPERTS AND THOSE
RESOURCES THAT CAN PROVIDE SOME
SUGGESTIONS IN WHAT IS THE RIGHT
MESSAGE TO PUT OUT THERE. WE'VE
HAD INTERNAL DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
YOU KNOW, IF WE PUT SUICIDE ON
THE SIGN, IS THAT A TRIGGER? YOU
KNOW, WHAT DOES THAT WHAT DOES
THAT POTENTIALLY WHAT MESSAGE
DOES THAT POTENTIALLY SEND. SO
AT THIS POINT WE DO WE ARE
REVIEWING A NUMBER OF SIGN
DESIGNS. AND IT'S REALLY LOOKING
FOR SOME INPUT, ESPECIALLY FROM
EXPERTS AS TO WHAT IS REALLY THE
RIGHT DESIGN THAT WE CAN PUT OUT
THERE THAT WILL PROVIDE THAT
CONSISTENT RAIL SAFETY AS WELL
AS THAT MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCE
MESSAGE. AND AGAIN, WE'LL BE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO CIRCLE BACK
WITH YOUR OFFICE IF THERE IS A
PREFERRED DESIGN THAT YOU HAVE
FOR CONSIDERATION. AND WE CAN
WORK WITH YOU ON THAT. THANK YOU.
AND CAN I FOLLOW UP ON THAT?
WHAT IS THE TIMELINE? BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE A DESIGN. WE JUST SAW
A DESIGN AND WANTED TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE COULD GET A SIGN. AND
SO WE'RE NOT IN THE DESIGN
PLACE, BUT WHAT'S THE TIMELINE?
I MEAN, AND THIS IS HELPFUL.
LIKE IT'S A LEGITIMATE QUESTION.
I JUST DON'T KNOW. YEAH YOU
KNOW, ONCE WE HAVE A DESIGN
THAT'S WE DO HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THE APPROVAL PROCESS THROUGH OUR
HOST RAILROADS, DEPENDING ON
WHERE WE WANT TO PUT IT,
ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE ON THEIR PROPERTY.
WE NEED TO GET THEIR APPROVAL
FOR THAT, AND AGAIN, DEPENDING
ON WHERE ELSE THE SIGNS ARE
RECOMMENDED TO BE PLACED, IF
THEY'RE GOING TO BE PLACED
OUTSIDE OF THE RIGHT OF WAY,
MAYBE IN ANOTHER PUBLIC AREA,
YOU KNOW, MAYBE WE'LL NEED TO
GET SOME KIND OF COUNTY OR CITY
APPROVAL, SO I THINK IF IT'S
JUST A MATTER OF GETTING THOSE
APPROVALS THROUGH OUR HOST
RAILROAD, THROUGH UNION PACIFIC
TERRITORY AND OTHERS DOWN OUR
CORRIDOR, I THINK THAT
PARTICULAR PROCESS SHOULD MOVE
FAIRLY QUICKLY. AGAIN, I THINK
OUR, MANY OF OUR HOST RAILROADS,
DOWN ON THE SOUTHERN END OF OUR
CORRIDOR ALREADY HAVE SIGNAGE UP
IN PLACE, AND WE DO HAVE VARIOUS
SIGNAGE IN PLACE ON U.P.
TERRITORY, SO IT'S JUST A MATTER
OF WORKING WITH THEM AND
DECIDING WHERE TO BEST PLACE
THIS THIS ADDITIONAL SIGNAGE OR
NEW SIGNAGE. SO I THINK THAT
THAT PROCESS CAN MOVE FAIRLY
QUICKLY. WE DO HAVE THE ABILITY
TO ACTUALLY FABRICATE AND MAKE
THE SIGNS IN-HOUSE SO THAT
PROCESS IS FAIRLY QUICK AS WELL.
SO ONCE THAT DESIGN IS APPROVED
WE CAN MOVE FAIRLY QUICKLY TO
FABRICATE THOSE SIGNS AND MAKE
THOSE. AND AGAIN, WE CAN WORK IN
TANDEM WITH UNION PACIFIC TO GET
THE APPROVALS THAT WE NEED FOR
THE PLACEMENTS WHERE WE WANT
THEM. GREAT. THIS IS HELPFUL AND
I APPRECIATE THE FEEDBACK. I
THINK THIS IS, YOU KNOW, SHOWS
PARTNERSHIP ON HOW WE CAN GET
SOME OF THESE THINGS DONE,
WHETHER THEY'RE REALLY LITTLE OR
THE BIGGER CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THE LOCATION ALTOGETHER. THANK
YOU. AND JUST AS A FOLLOW UP ON
THIS PARTICULAR POINT, I WAS THE
MAYOR OF THE CITY OF ENCINITAS
WHEN WE HAD A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT, THEY CALL THEM
STRIKES. BUT I MEAN, THEY'RE
TRAGEDIES AND SUICIDES, AND ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WAS CLEAR TO
ME AFTER SPEAKING WITH THE WIDOW
OF SOMEBODY WHO HAD TAKEN HIS
LIFE, WAS THAT WE NEEDED TO SHOW
THAT WE WERE TRYING TO HELP
PEOPLE. AND SO WE PUT UP SIGNS
THAT HAD THE ONE 800 TYPE OF
SUICIDE PHONE NUMBER, BECAUSE
PART OF IT IS THAT IF YOU HAVE
NOTHING THERE, IT DOESN'T
INDICATE THAT YOU'RE TAKING THAT
SERIOUSLY. AND WE KNOW WE HAVE
TRAINS GOING AT HIGH SPEEDS, AND
WHEN PEOPLE ARE, YOU KNOW,
REALLY IN THAT STATE OF MIND,
YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO HAVE ONE
LAST POTENTIAL INTERVENTION. SO
I THINK TO ME, THE SAFETY, THE
SIGN IS NOT JUST TRAINS ARE
MOVING FAST. WATCH OUT. BUT IF
YOU ARE CONTEMPLATING SUICIDE,
CONSIDER CALLING THIS PHONE
NUMBER SOMETHING THAT HAS THAT
MESSAGE. SO TO ME THAT SEEMS
LIKE A REALLY IMPORTANT, PART OF
THE MESSAGING, OKAY, GREAT.
THANK YOU. SENATE-TV DO YOU HAVE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS? OKAY. I HAD
ONE QUESTION I JUST WANTED TO
ASK RELATED TO THE COASTAL
COMMISSION, SO I THINK IN SAN
CLEMENTE PARTICULARLY, BUT IN
BOTH, BOTH IN THE DEL MAR AREA
AND IN SAN CLEMENTE, THERE'S A
TENSION AROUND ARMORING THE
BLUFF AND DOING SAND
REPLENISHMENT OR MORE NATURAL
SOLUTIONS. AND SO THE QUESTION
OF, BASICALLY A RELIANCE ON
EMERGENCY PERMITS CAN SOMETIMES
BE PERCEIVED AS CIRCUMVENTING A
COASTAL COMMISSION PROCESS THAT
WOULD BE LOOKING AT SOMETHING IN
MORE DEPTH AND, AND GETTING
REALLY TO, TO A NATURE BASED
SOLUTION VERSUS AN ARMORING
SOLUTION. SO I JUST WANTED TO
HAVE, SOME THOUGHTS ON THAT. YOU
KNOW, REQUIRING AN A TRANSIT
AGENCY TO DO SAND VERSUS TO DO
ARMORING OR, YOU KNOW, HOW DOES
THAT PROCESS, HOW IS THAT BEING
EVALUATED? THANK YOU. SO, THE
EMERGENCY PERMIT PROCESS, I
THINK IS SORT OF INHERENTLY
INCOMPLETE. IT'S FOCUSED ON
ADDRESSING THE IMMEDIATE NEED
AND THE HAZARDS THAT ARE
PRESENTED IN THAT IMMEDIATE
CIRCUMSTANCE. NOW, OUR PROCESS
INCLUDES A REQUIREMENT FOR A
FOLLOW UP PERMIT. AND THROUGH
THAT FOLLOW UP PERMIT, WE DO
HAVE TO GO BACK AND LOOK AT ALL
OF THE ALTERNATIVES THAT WOULD
BE FEASIBLE IN THAT CIRCUMSTANCE
AND ADDRESS THAT THROUGH THE
PERMIT PROCESS, IDEALLY, THOUGH,
WE'RE GETTING TO A POINT WHERE
WE AREN'T HAVING TO RELY ON THE
EMERGENCY PERMIT PROCESS, AND WE
ARE ABLE TO USE THE FULL COASTAL
DEVELOPMENT PERMIT PROCESS,
WHICH DOES ENABLE US TO LOOK AT
THE FULL RANGE OF ALTERNATIVES.
IT DOES ALLOW US TO ENGAGE THE
PUBLIC, THAT WANTS SO BADLY TO
BE INVOLVED WITH THESE
DECISIONS, AND TO CONSIDER, YOU
KNOW, ALL OF THE, THE RIGHT
OPTIONS THERE, YOU KNOW, IN
TERMS OF SAND, YOU KNOW, VERSUS
HARD ARMORING, THAT'S, THAT IS,
YOU KNOW, THE SIGNIFICANT ISSUE
THAT WE FACE WITH WITH ALL OF
THE RAIL AREAS IN SAN CLEMENTE,
WE ARE AT THIS POINT, WE ARE
FOCUSED ON WITH IDENTIFYING A,
MITIGATION PROGRAM THAT WOULD
INCLUDE SAND AND BEACH
REPLENISHMENT SO THAT, ALONG
WITH SOME LIMITED ARMORING WHERE
THAT'S JUST ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY,
BUT THE, THE HAVING THE SAND AND
BEACH REPLENISHMENT COMPONENTS
AS PART OF THE PROJECT IS, IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THAT IS HOW WE
PRESERVE OUR COASTAL ACCESS
ALONG OUR BEACHES. OKAY. WELL,
WE'RE A LITTLE BIT OVER TIME,
BUT I WANTED TO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR COMING TODAY AND
SPEAKING ABOUT THIS, SO I'D LIKE
TO THANK THE THREE OF YOU AND
THEN ALSO THE THREE OF THE PANEL
BEFORE THIS OF COURSE, IS A
PARTNERSHIP. YOU KNOW, THE
LEGISLATORS HAVE AN OVERSIGHT
ROLE, BUT WE DON'T DO THE WORK,
AND SO IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE DO HAVE A PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN THE LEGISLATURE AND ALL
OF THE AGENCIES THAT ARE DOING
THE WORK TODAY. WE HEARD
DIRECTLY FROM OPERATING AND
STATE AGENCIES ON THE OPERATIONS
AND PERFORMANCE OF THE LOW SAND
CORRIDOR. AND MY MESSAGE TODAY
IS THAT WE MUST CONTINUE TO PUSH
FOR AMBITIOUS PROGRESS, AND WE
MUST EXPECT RESULTS STATEWIDE.
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED ARE
INCREASING, AND THE LATEST DATA
CONFIRMS THAT WE'LL NEED PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION AND HIGHER RAIL
MODAL SHARE TO REDUCE OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. AS
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE'S WORK
CONTINUES, WE'LL REMAIN FOCUSED
ON ACCOUNTABILITY, PERFORMANCE,
AND ULTIMATELY ACHIEVING OUR
SHARED RESILIENCY AND PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION GOALS. I WOULD
LIKE TO ASK IF SENATOR LIMON
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE ANY CLOSING
REMARKS, AND THEN AFTER THAT, WE
WILL GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT. I
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE WHO'S PARTICIPATED. I
CONTINUE TO BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
THE MOST, AT LEAST IN THE EIGHT
YEARS I'VE BEEN HERE, THAT WE'VE
DONE ON LOW SAND. SO I REALLY
WANT TO THANK OUR CHAIR AND
REALLY THE COMMITTEE ON DOING
THIS, YOU KNOW, THESE ARE REALLY
HELPFUL CONVERSATIONS. SO
APPRECIATE THE ENGAGEMENT FROM
ALL FOLKS. THANK YOU. OKAY.
THANK YOU. SO NOW WE WILL GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT. SO IF ANYBODY
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU MAY COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE HERE AND STAND IN
LINE. WELCOME WELCOME. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU, SENATOR
BLAKE SPEER AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS,
THIS, LOOKING AT THIS ISSUE OF
THE OPPORTUNITY AND THE
CHALLENGES FACED BY THE LOW SAND
CORRIDOR. AND I'D LIKE TO,
PLEASE MAKE SURE AND SAY YOUR
NAME OR ORGANIZATION. STEVE
ROBERTS, I'M THE PRESIDENT OF
THE RAIL PASSENGERS ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA, AN ALL VOLUNTEER
ORGANIZATION. I'D LIKE TO
REEMPHASIZE WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT
THE NEED FOR STEPPING UP TO
AGGRESSIVE ACTION. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT CONCERNS US IS THAT
OVER THE LAST PERIOD OF TIME,
THAT WE'VE BEEN DEALING WITH
THIS ISSUE, NONE OF THE AGENCIES
INVOLVED HAVE REALLY STEPPED UP
AND TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE FORWARD.
EVERYBODY SEEMS TO BE WAITING
FOR THE NEXT STUDY TO BE DONE,
RATHER THAN THAN TRYING TO GET
OUT IN FRONT OF IT, FOR EXAMPLE,
THERE ARE THREE HIGH PROFILE
CAPACITY PROJECTS IN THE
CORRIDOR THAT WOULD ALLOW THE
REIMAGINATION OF METROLINK AND
SURFLINER OPERATIONS AND SERVICE
PACKAGE THAT THERE'S BEEN LITTLE
OR NO PROGRESS OVER THE LAST FEW
MONTHS. AND FOR THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS. AND IT'S JUST ALL WE SEE
ARE, ADDITIONAL OPTIONS. A
REPACKAGING VALUE, ENGINEERING
EVERYTHING. BUT WE NEVER SEE ANY
FORWARD PROGRESS. AND SO IN
ORDER TO GET THE VMT REDUCTIONS
THAT YOU MENTIONED, WE NEED TO
HAVE SOME SOMEBODY STEP UP AND
TAKE MORE AGGRESSIVE ACTION ON
THIS. THANK YOU. MR. ROBERTS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO JUST SHARE
WHICH THREE PROJECTS YOU WERE
THINKING OF WHEN YOU SAY THAT,
SIERRA SIDING SOUTH AND SAN
CLEMENTE, WHICH IS MID POINT IN
THE CORRIDOR AND WHICH WOULD
ALLOW ADDITIONAL METROLINK
TRAINS TO FROM OCEANSIDE AS AN
OPTION OR ADDITIONAL SURFLINER
FREQUENCIES TO PROVIDE PERHAPS
HOURLY SERVICE. THE OTHER ONE,
OF COURSE, IS LA UNION STATION.
MR. KETTLE TALKED ABOUT, GEARING
UP FOR, FOR THE OLYMPICS. WELL,
HE COULD GEAR UP A LOT MORE IF
HE HAD RUN THROUGH TRACKS AT LOS
ANGELES UNION STATION, BUT LA
METRO IS NOT IS NOT FULFILLED
THAT DESPITE YEARS AND YEARS OF
STUDIES AND THE FINAL ONE IS THE
DOUBLE TRACK BETWEEN CHATSWORTH
AND VAN NUYS, WHICH WILL ALLOW
30 MINUTE SERVICE THROUGH THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY, A HIGH
DENSITY POPULATION AREA THAT
ALWAYS SEEMS TO BE, YOU KNOW,
WANTS A LOT OF TRANSIT. SO THOSE
ARE THREE PROJECTS THAT WOULD
ALLOW 30 MINUTE SERVICE BETWEEN
CHATSWORTH AND LAGUNA NIGUEL ON
THE SOUTH, ADDITIONAL SURF LINE
SERVICE OR ADDITIONAL METRO LINE
SERVICE TO OCEAN COUNTIES,
OCEANSIDE AND EVEN THROUGH
RUNNING BETWEEN COASTER AND
METROLINK. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS, MR. ROBERTS. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS MICHAEL
CONWAY. I'M A CONDUCTOR FOR
AMTRAK OUT OF LOS ANGELES FOR
THE LAST 17 YEARS. I'M ALSO THE
SAFETY OFFICER FOR THE SMART
UNION, WHICH REPRESENTS THE
CONDUCTORS WORK IN METROLINK AND
AMTRAK. AND TO MISS LAYMAN'S
POINT, I'VE BEEN UNFORTUNATELY,
11 INCIDENCES WITH PEDESTRIAN
STRIKES. AND IT'S THE CONDUCTORS
WHO SHOW UP FIRST. AND I HAVE
ANYTHING TO GET RID OF THESE.
IT'S HARD. YOU. KNOW, AND I
THINK YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT ALL
THESE ISSUES, YOU KNOW,
ENVIRONMENTAL, YOUR CAPACITY,
YOUR GROWTH. YOU REALLY DO NEED
A BOLD VISION. AND YOU GUYS NEED
TO THINK, TO LOOK INTO AN IDEA
OF A NORTH EAST CORRIDOR STYLE
INFRASTRUCTURE, GETTING RID OF
GRADE SEPARATIONS, RAILROAD
CROSSINGS, FENCES ALONG THE
RIGHT OF WAY SO PEOPLE CAN'T
ACCESS THE TRACKS AT ALL, I
THINK THAT'S REALLY WHERE WE
NEED TO GO TO DO ALL THE THINGS
THAT YOU WERE BRINGING UP YOUR
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES, YOUR
OVERHEAD CATENARY. THAT'S THE
WAY TO GO. AND LASTLY, WE HAVE
THREE STATE SPONSORED RAIL
SERVICES. TWO OF THEM CONNECT
DIRECTLY BY RAIL THE CAPITOL
CORRIDOR AND THE SAN JOAQUINS.
THE SURFLINER IS OFF ON ITS OWN.
I WOULD THINK, EXPLORING HOW TO
GET THE SURFLINER TO HAVE A
DIRECT RAIL CONNECTION TO THE
OTHER TWO SERVICES. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, MR.
CONBOY. THAT'S ALL VERY USEFUL.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. YES OKAY.
ANYBODY ELSE WANTING TO COME
MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT? OKAY. I
DON'T SEE ANY. SO THANK YOU TO
THE TWO OF YOU WHO PARTICIPATED
IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY. YOU
MAY SUBMIT ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
OR SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. AND I THANK THOSE
WHO HAVE ALREADY DONE THIS. YOUR
COMMENTS ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND
WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR COMMENTS
IN THE RECORD. SO THANK YOU
AGAIN TO EVERYONE WHO
PARTICIPATED. WE HAVE NOW
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA AND THE
SUBCOMMITTEE IS NOW ADJOURNED.